THE SENATE COMMITTEE HEARING. TO
ORDER AS A SUB COMMITTEE. UH,
WE'LL START WITH YOU, SENATOR
DODD. SENATOR DODD IS HERE TO
PRESENT S¼ B 159. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS. UM
TODAY I'M PRESENTING S¼ B 1159
REGARDING ROADSIDE WILDFIRE RISK
REDUCTION. THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT BY JANUARY 1ST 2026, THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
EVALUATE AND THE SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
CONSIDER A CATEGORICAL EXEMPTION
FOR ROADSIDE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS THAT REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISK AND MEET
APPROPRIATE CONDITIONS. S¼ B
1159 DOES NOT CREATE A STATUTORY
EXEMPTION. RATHER IT STATES THAT
THE ROADSIDE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IS A LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY, AND THAT PROJECTS
UNDERTAKING ROADSIDE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT MEETING APPROPRIATE
SAFEGUARDS SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
FOR INCLUSION ON THE LIST OF
CATEGORICALLY EXEMPT PROJECTS. R
AND THE SECRETARY OF OUR ALREADY
HAVE A HISTORY OF EVALUATING AND
APPROPRIATING. UH, APPRO.
APPROPRIATING. EXCUSE ME.
APPROPRIATELY. TAILORING THE
CATEGORICAL EXEMPTIONS. ROADSIDE
IGNITIONS ARE SIGNIFICANT SOURCE
OF WILDFIRES WHAT IS FAR FROM A
PASSING VEHICLE OR CIGARETTE èC
INTO CONTACT WITH DRIED BRUSH
AND GRASS VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
ALONG ROADSIDES IS HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE AT LIMITING THE SPREAD
OF THESE IGNITIONS AND ALSO
DECREASES THE POTENTIAL FOR AN
EXISTING WILDFIRE TO SPREAD
ACROSS THE ROAD. WITH THOUSANDS
OF MILES OF ROADS AND WILDFIRE
PRONE LANDS. ROADSIDE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IS CONSTANTLY
REQUIRED TO MINIMIZE THE RISK OF
AN UNCONTROLLED WILDFIRE.
CURRENTLY ROADSIDE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS ARE OFTEN
SUBJECT TO S¼ QL REVIEWS THAT
CAN ADD COSTS AND DELAYS AND
ULTIMATELY REDUCING THE AMOUNT
OF WORK THAT GETS DONE
INCREASING THE RISK OF RUNAWAY
FIRES THAT ARE DEVASTATING THE
CLIMATE CHANGE AS WELL AS HUMAN
AND ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. AN
EXEMPTION FOR ROADSIDE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROJECTS
WOULD VASTLY INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF ROADSIDE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT WORK THAT CAN BE
COMPLETED IN A GIVEN AMOUNT OF
TIME. THE BILL SO FAR AS NÓ
OPPOSITION IS SUPPORTED BY A
NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS,
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATE
GENERAL CONTRACTORS. CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION. UH, KAT
SAID, UH, COUNTY COUNTY OF
SONOMA AND OTHERS WITH ME TODAY
IS FIRE CHIEF DAVE WHITAKER,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA UH,
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU. LET'S HEAR FROM YOUR
WITNESSES. CHIEF. YOU'RE RIGHT
OVER HERE. I KNOW YOU CAN COME
TO THE TABLE COME TO THE TABLE.
WE'RE CIVILIZED COMMITTEE.
DIFFERENT COMMITTEES DIFFERENT,
DIFFERENT. YEAH, I SEE THAT.
YEAH. YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS CRITICAL BILL
DAVE WINER AND FIRE CHIEF THE
RAGA ADA FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT AND A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION EXECUTIVE BOARD. IN
FIRE DEPENDENT LANDSCAPES SUCH
AS CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE IS A
NATURAL AND RECURRING FEATURE.
AS A RESULT OF THAT WE HAVE A
FUTURE THAT IN A HOTTER, DRIER
FUTURE, THERE IS NÓ CERTAINTY
THAT WE WILL NOT HAVE FIRES WHEN
WE HAVE FIRES. IT IS ONLY THAT
THE SPEED WITH WHICH THEY
APPROACH OUR COMMUNITIES, THEY
CONVERT THEM INTO DESTRUCTIVE
EVENTS CARRYING OUT ROADSIDE
FUEL REDUCTION PROJECTS ENHANCES
THE NON BURNABLE NATURE OF THE
EXISTING ROAD IN AREAS THAT ARE
LESS LIKELY TO BE CRITICAL
HABITAT AND ARE VERY TO BE
SOURCES OF IGNITION, CREATING
THIS EXEMPTION, AS WE HAVE
ALREADY DONE FOR DEFENSIBLE
SPACE WORK WITHIN 100 FT OF A
HOME WILL HAVE THE EFFECT OF
INCREASING THE EFFICIENCY OF
LIMITED WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION
RESOURCES AS WE APPROACH THIS AS
A CONSTRAINED OPTIMIZATION
PROBLEM IN A FUTURE WITH
CONSTRAINED BUDGETS, IT IS LESS
LIKELY THAT WE WILL HAVE THE
ESSENTIALLY UNLIMITED RESOURCES
THAT THE STATE HAS SHOWERED ON
THIS PROBLEM OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS, AND IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE MORE
EFFICACIOUS IN OUR WORK AND PULL
IT INTO AREAS THAT WILL HAVE USE
OF NOT ONLY PREVENTING IGNITIONS
BUT SECURING EVACUATION ROUTES,
WHICH WILL ALLOW US TO MOVE OUR
RESIDENTS TO SAFETY. BUYING TIME
FOR THE AGGREGATION OF THE
EFFECT OF FIREFIGHTING FORCE
THAT IS NECESSARY TO PREVENT THE
LOSS OF STRUCTURES. I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS NEEDED MEASURE
AND BELIEVE IT IS CONSISTENT
WITH PREVIOUS WORK THAT IS
ESTABLISHED CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTIONS FOR DEFENSIBLE SPACE
WORK AROUND HOMES. BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT, LET'S HEAR FROM OTHER
FOLKS YOU WANNA JUST WEIGH IN
AND SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. YOU
COME TO THE MIC. GOOD MORNING.
NOEL KRAMER WITH WINE INSTITUTE
IN SUPPORT IN THE 2020 FIRES
ALONE, WINERIES AND WINE GRAPE
GROWERS LOST AN ESTIMATED $3.7
BILLION FROM WILDFIRE. SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, JOHN
KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL COUNTIES
AND IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR CLARIFYING THAT THIS IS
ADDITIVE TO EXISTING S¼ QL
EXEMPTIONS AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AS IT MOVES FORWARD.
THANK YOU. ADAM REGULARLY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR CHAIR,
CHRIS MALLEY ON BEHALF OF
HUMBOLDT REDWOOD COMPANY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
FORMATION OF THE PACIFIC FOREST
TRUST. ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ROADSIDES ARE AMONGST THE MOST
IMPORTANT PLACES THAT WE CAN
WORK AND MAKING IT EASIER AND
CLEARER. WHAT WE'RE DOING. THERE
IS IMPORTANT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, SYLVIO
FERRARI ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. I DON'T WANT TO HEAR FROM
THIS GUY. GOOD MORNING, MR CHAIR
MEMBERS DYLAN ELLIOT ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTIES OF NAPA AND
SONOMA IN SPORT. THANK YOU.
SECURITY YOU CAN. GOOD AFTERNOON
. MICHELLE VC ON BEHALF OF
CONTRAST, COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. UH, THAT'S IS THAT
YOUR FIRST ME TOO, DYLAN. OH
GOSH. ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. YOU
JUST LEFT MY STAFF. SO, UH, GOOD
TO SEE YOU. ALL RIGHT, LET'S UM
UH LET'S UH, LET'S GO. LET'S
OPPOSITION ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
NÓ. OK ALL RIGHT, LET'S BRING
YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS THOUGHTS. COMMENTS
YEAH. GREAT BILL AND MOVED BY
SENATOR DOLLY, UH, YOU MAY
CLOSE. UH, WE DON'T HAVE A
MOTION WE SORRY WE'RE WE'RE
SUBCOMITTEE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE FANTASTIC,
APPROPRIATE TIME. APPRECIATE YOU
VERY MUCH, SENATOR. THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. WE
WE VERY SUPPORTED THE BILL. OK,
UM, LET'S HEAR FROM SENATOR
CABALLERO.
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU.
CHAIR I'M GLAD I WASN'T ON YOUR
SCALP AT ONE TIME, SO GOOD
MORNING, MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. UM THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT S¼ B
1420 LET ME START OFF BY SAYING
I CAN I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND I AGREE TO WORK ON
COMMITTEE AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
RESOLVE OUTSTANDING ISSUES. IT'S
A WORK IN PROGRESS AND THE
OPPORTUNITY I THINK TO REFINE
THIS AND MAKE IT WORK IN
CALIFORNIA IS REALLY IMPORTANT,
SO I REALLY I THANK APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD AND
LOOK FORWARD TO MORE. SO UM, LET
ME JUST SAY THAT, UH S¼ B 1420
IS A BILL THAT WILL CREATE THE
WORLD'S FIRST RENEWABLE HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION MANDATE MODELED ON
CALIFORNIA'S OWN RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD, OR RP S¼,
WHICH REQUIRES A DECARBONIZATION
OF THE ENERGY GRID BY 2050.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL ALLOWS A
RENEWABLE AND CLEAN HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION FACILITIES TO QUALIFY
FOR TWO RECENT ENERGY,
STREAMLINING PROCESSES AND
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW AND
CONSOLIDATED PERMITTING PROCESS.
THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES LANGUAGE
EXTENDING THE GOVERNOR'S
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS TO ADD
CLEAN AND RENEWABLE HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION FACILITIES. SB 1020
WILL ENSURE HYDROGEN IS PRODUCED
IN LINE WITH CALIFORNIA'S STRONG
ENVIRONMENTAL LOSS. ADDITIONALLY
IT WILL ALIGN THE
DECARBONIZATION OF HYDROGEN FUEL
WITH THE DECARBONIZATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S POWER GRID WHILE
GOING A STEP FURTHER AND
REQUIRING ELIGIBLE HYDROGEN TO
HAVE A CARBON INTENSITY SCORE OF
LESS THAN OR EQUAL TO THAT OF
THE GRID ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
SPECIFICALLY SB 1420 REQUIRES
THAT ON A STATEWIDE BASIS, NÓ
LESS THAN 60% OF THE HYDROGEN
USED IN TRANSPORTATION. BE
RENEWABLE BY 2030 BY 2045. THE
REMAINING 40% MUST BE A MIX OF
RENEWABLE AND CLEAN HYDROGEN.
BECAUSE IT DEFINITION OF ZERO.
CARBON RESOURCES DID NOT
CONTEMPLATE FUEL AND FOCUSES
MAINLY ON GRID RELIABILITY. THIS
BILL BORROWS FROM THE FEDERAL
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT
DEFINITION OF CLEAN HYDROGEN
HYDROGEN, WHICH IS PRODUCED
THROUGH A PROCESS THAT RESULTS
IN A LIFE CYCLE. LIFE CYCLE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS RATE OF
NOT GREATER THAN 4 KG OF CO. TWO
PER KILOGRAM OF HYDROGEN. LET'S
BE CLEAR THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD CARB IN THEIR
2022 SCOPING PLAN DETERMINED
QUITE CLEARLY THAT CALIFORNIA
COULD NOT ATTAIN ITS CLIMATE
GOALS TO DECARBONIZE WITHOUT
UTILIZING HYDROGEN AS A FUEL
SOURCE. LET ME REPEAT THAT. CARB
HAS DETERMINED OUR OWN. OUR OWN
AGENCY. IT HAS DETERMINED QUITE
CLEARLY THAT CALIFORNIA COULD
NOT ATTAIN ITS CLIMATE GOALS TO
DECARBONIZE WITHOUT UTILIZING
HYDROGEN AS A FUEL SOURCE CARB
STATES THAT CALIFORNIA CANNOT
REACH ITS EMISSION GOALS WITHOUT
EXPANDING HYDROGEN PRODUCTION.
BY 1700 TIMES THE PRESENT RATE
OF PRODUCTION. SB 1420 WOULD
ALSO ENABLE CALIFORNIA TO WORK
MORE DELIBERATIVELY TOWARDS THIS
GOAL AND ALLOW A TRANSITION IN
THE AVIATION HEAVY DUTY TRUCKING
MARITIME STREETS AND ALSO QUITE
FRANKLY, THE PORT AWAY FROM
DIESEL AND JET FUEL TO A CLEANER
, LOCALLY PRODUCED PRODUCT THAT
WOULD NOT ONLY DECARBONIZE THE
FUEL BUT ELIMINATE THE
PREDICTION OF AIR POLLUTION
CONTAMINANTS SUCH AS SULFUR
OXIDE SOCKS AND NITRIC OXIDE OR
NOX. AND THOSE ARE TH THAT'S THE
AIR POLLUTION RIGHT NOW THAT IS
REALLY CONFOUNDING THE SOUTH
COAST AIR BASES AND THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY THO THO THOSE AIR
BASES AND ARE NON ATTAINMENT AIR
BASE AND HAVE REALLY HARD TIME.
UM REDUCING THE SOCKS AND THE
KNOCKS BECAUSE THEY DON'T
PRODUCE IT. IT'S PRODUCED
SOMEWHERE ELSE, AND IT BLOWS IN.
S¼ B 1420 WOULD ALSO ENABLE
CALIFORNIA TO LEVERAGE FEDERAL
FUNDS AWARDED TO THE ARCHES
COALITION. UM OUR OWN ARCHES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR A
HYDROGEN HUB GRANT BY UNLOCKING
PRIVATE SECTOR INVESTMENT,
ESTIMATED TO BRING IN $10
BILLION IN PRIVATE INVESTMENT
JUST AS IMPORTANT, ESPECIALLY IN
MY OWN DISTRICT. UM IT. THIS
BILL ALLOWS CALIFORNIA TO CREATE
GOOD PAYING JOBS, COMPA
COMPARABLE TO THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY, AND IT IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRANSITION
WORKERS AWAY FROM THE FOSSIL
FUELS INTO GOOD PAYING JOBS THAT
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE.
NOT ONLY, UH, A HIGH WAGE
EQUIVALENT TO THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY, BUT ALSO BENEFITS THE
ABILITY TO STAY IN THE VALLEY
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES, IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO SUPPORT THE LOCAL ECONOMY IN
CONCLUSION IS 1420 WOULD
ESTABLISH THE HIGHEST EMISSION
STANDARDS FOR HYDRO. IN THE
WORLD, ALL ON CALIF. ALL ON
CALIFORNIA TO MEET ITS
ENVIRONMENTAL CLIMATE CHANGE
GOALS. CREATE THOSE HIGH ROAD
JOBS, CREATE A COMMUNITY BENEFIT
PLAN AND BRING NEW INVESTMENT
INTO THE STATE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
IS, UM, MIKE, SO SARA ON BEHALF
OF THE CAL, CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
COALITION, AND DOCTOR J JACK
BROWER, A PROFESSOR AND
CHANCELLOR, CHANCELLOR'S FELLOW
OF MECHANICAL AND AEROSPACE,
CIVIL AND ENVIRONMENTAL AND
CHEMICAL AND BIO MO. MOLECULAR
ENGINEERING. AND I SAY ALL OF
THAT, BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS, IT WILL BE
HIM. THAT ANSWERS HIM AND HE'S
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CLEAN ENERGY
INSTITUTE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, IRVINE. ALL RIGHT.
LET'S HEAR WHO'S GOING FIRST.
WHO'S GOING FIRST? NÓ, PLEASE.
OK CHAIR AND CENTERS. UH, M SLA
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COLLISION. WE'RE PROUD
SPONSORS OF SB 1420. BILL SEEKS
TO DO THREE THINGS FIRST IMPOSES
RIGOROUS STANDARD ON RENEWABLE
AND CLEAN HYDROGEN FOR
TRANSPORTATION THAT MIRRORS THE
TIMELINES AND REQUIREMENTS AND
STANDARDS ACCEPTED FOR THE
ELECTRIC GRID AND THE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD. GOES A STEP
FURTHER AND PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL BACKSTOP OF CARBON
INTENSITY OVERLAID ON TOP OF
THESE REQUIREMENTS TO ASSURE
SKEPTICS OF HYDROGEN THAT WE
WILL MEET OR BEAT THE GRID IN
TERMS OF CARBON INTENSITY
THROUGH AN OBJECTIVE AND
QUANTITATIVE METRIC. UH, THESE
ARE NOT QUALITATIVE STATEMENTS.
SECOND S¼ P 1420 ADDS RENEWABLE
AND CLEAN HYDROGEN IS AN
ELIGIBLE RESOURCE WITHIN THE RP
S¼ TO THUS ALLOWING IT TO BE
INTEGRATED INTO OUR ENERGY
SYSTEM AND UTILIZED FOR ENERGY
PURPOSES AGAIN. THIS THE PUTS US
WITHIN THE CONFINEMENT AND
STANDARDS OF A 22 YEAR POLICY
THAT'S BEEN IMPROVED AND DEBATED
. UH UH, CONSISTENTLY THROUGH
THIS LEGISLATURE AND SET
FORWARD. THIRD AND IMPORTANTLY,
IT ADDS RENEWABLE CLEAN HYDROGEN
TO THE PROVISIONS OF A B 205 AND
S¼ B 149 CONTEMPLATED BY THIS
LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE TO
ACCELERATE OUR PACE TOWARDS
CARBON NEUTRALITY. UH,
IMPORTANTLY, WE HAVE A FEDERAL
OPPORTUNITY THAT IS GENERATIONAL
. I DON'T KNOW THAT I'LL SEE
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY LIKE THIS IN
MY LIFETIME. UH BUT THERE ARE
SOME STRICT TIMELINES ON THAT
OUR HYDROGEN HUB HAS TO BE
OPERATIONAL BY 2030 IN OPERATION
FOR TWO YEARS BY 2032 IN ORDER
TO RECEIVE THE $1.2 BILLION
CERTAINLY, THE HYDROGEN HUB IS A
$12 BILLION HUB, WHICH I KNOW
SENATOR ALAN, YOU'RE WORKING ON
A $15 BILLION CLIMATE BOND. THIS
IS A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH OVER $10 BILLION
COMING FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR
ON VARIABLE RENEWABLE
ELECTRICITY GENERATED HYDROGEN.
THIS IS THE ONLY HUB OF ITS KIND
IN THE UNITED STATES AND THE
CLEANEST. ADDITIONALLY THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT SECTION
45 PROVIDES TAX CREDITS IN THOSE
FACILITIES HAVE TO BE
OPERATIONAL BY 2032 AND SO THE
PACE AND SCALE IN ORDER TO
MAXIMIZE OUR OPPORTUNITY
FEDERALLY REQUIRES US TO
ACCELERATE THE CURRENT PACE OF
INDUSTRIAL PERMITTING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO ALLOW US
TO DO THIS. WE LEGISLATURES, UH,
CREATED AAA GOOD PROCESS WITH
THE ENERGY COMMISSION AND THAT
WE SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO ENTER
INTO THAT TO HELP ACCELERATE THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THESE PROJECTS AND
MAXIMIZE CALIFORNIA'S VALUE AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. I THINK
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY SKEPTICISM
AROUND HYDROGEN AND SOME OF THE
DEBATE AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL
AROUND A CONCEPT CALLED THREE
PILLARS, WHICH IS ADDITIONALLY
TEMPORAL MATCHING SO TIME
MATCHING AND DELIVERABILITY
WITHIN THE CONSTRAINTS AND
POLICIES OF CALIFORNIA'S, UH
LEADING ENERGY STUFF. SB 100 S¼
B THREE 150. WE HAVE SOLVED AND
DEALT FOR THOSE THINGS. WE HAVE
DELIVERABILITY REQUIREMENTS WITH
THE FIRST POINT OF
INTERCONNECTION BEING THE WE
HAVE A TEMPORAL MATCHING WITHIN
THAT, AND WE ALSO HAVE
ADDITIONALITY THAT INCREMENTAL
LOAD MUST BE NEW AND ADDITIONAL
RENEWABLES. HOWEVER HYDROGEN
PRODUCERS ARE SIMPLY CUSTOMERS
OF LOAD SERVING ENTITIES. WE
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY OUTSIDE
OF PROVIDING US DIRECT ACCESS OR
A TARIFF, WHICH SENATOR BECKER
IS WORKING ON TO DO MANY OF THE
THINGS CONTEMPLATED. THREE
PILLARS. IN FACT, THREE PILLARS
JUST CREATED AN IMPEDIMENT THAT
WON'T ALLOW US TO PRODUCE
HYDROGEN COST EFFECTIVELY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO COMPETE
WITH DIESEL AND GASOLINE, WHICH
IS ULTIMATELY THE GOAL. AND SO
TO THOSE POINTS, WE URGE YOUR I
VOTE AND ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. OK ALL
RIGHT. YES SIR. YEAH. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
UH, I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
HYDROGEN TOPICS FOR THE LAST 25
YEARS AND, UH, ALL AROUND THE
WORLD JURISDICTIONS WHO HAVE
OBJECTIVELY ANALYZED WHAT WE
MUST DO NEXT TO COMPLETELY
DECARBONIZE AND DE POLLUTE
ECONOMIES HAVE DECIDED TO INVEST
BIG TIME IN HYDROGEN. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE, FINALLY. WE HAVE
HAD A LOT OF OBJECTIVE ANALYSIS
THAT SAYS HEY, IF WE'RE GOING TO
DECARBONIZE AND DE POLLUTE EVERY
PART OF OUR ECONOMY, INCLUDING
THE PORTS AND THE LONG HAUL
TRUCKS AND HEAVY INDUSTRY THAT
YOU JUST MENTIONED, UM WE NEED
TO INVEST IN HYDROGEN AND WE
HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY NOW FOR
INVESTMENT TO OCCUR AS A RESULT
OF THE HUB AND 45. THAT IS, I
THINK ONCE IN A LIFETIME, IT'S
THE BEGINNING OF THE BEGINNING
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE. I AM AN
INTERIM BOARD MEMBER OF ARCHES
AND HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE U S¼
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY ON THIS
VERY INVESTMENT. AND ONE OF
THEIR MAJOR CONCERNS IS GETTING
STUFF IN THE GROUND QUICK ENOUGH
, AND ESPECIALLY THE PERMITTING
STREAMLINING MEASURES. INCLUDED
IN THIS BILL ARE SUPER IMPORTANT
FOR THE MONEY TO FLOW TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THIS HUB
EFFORT, SO I ALSO AM IN SUPPORT
OF THIS IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE OF
THOSE STREAMLINING EFFORTS THAT
I KNOW WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE
AND CONTRIBUTE TO CLEAN AIR AND
REDUCED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS WITH
CLEAN HYDROGEN. RIGHT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. LET'S HEAR FROM
FOLKS THAT WANT TO WEIGH IN, UH,
EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL.
THAT THERE WAS JUST A MASS OF
US. THERESA COOK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN BUSINESS
COUNCIL. VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HØI GOOD MORNING, ALFREDO
REDONDO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
GREEN HYDROGEN COALITION AND
CYCLE IN STRONG SUPPORT. MORNING
MR CHAIR CHRIS M ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RENEWABLE
TRANSPORTATION ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. GOOD
MORNING, STEVE WALLACH ON BEHALF
OF THE CENTER FOR TRANSPORTATION
AND ENVIRONMENT AT FORD. GOOD
MORNING, MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BETH OLAS ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING, GREG KANE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN CAR OWNERS
ASSOCIATION AND A STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
, PHILIP VAN DER KLEY WITH LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT. MORNING MR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FAITH CONNOLLY
WITH WEITMAN GROUP ON BEHALF OF
A E AS WELL AS AIR PRODUCTS, THE
SINGLE LARGEST GLOBAL HYDROGEN
PRODUCER. UH, WE HAVE A TWEENER
POSITION. WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS,
BUT WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR, UH, TO ALLEVIATE THOSE
CONCERNS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD, AND WE APPRECIATE HER
COMMITMENT TO THIS INDUSTRY. ALL
RIGHT, UM, OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL ARE FOLKS WHO WANT TO RAISE
CONCERNS. YOU CAN COME, UM YES.
WELL, WELL, UM MAYBE WE CAN MOVE
ONE OF THE OTHER CHAIRS UP TO
THE FRONT UP TO THE FRONT SIDE
SO THEY CAN COME TO THE TABLE
HERE. USUALLY YEAH. OK? YEAH
HERE YOU GO. THIS IS FINE. AND
THEN SHE CAN GO PULL THE CHAIR.
THERE WE GO. ALL RIGHT. INTERIOR
DECORATION. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS KAYLA KREY HERE, REPRESENTING
THE CENTER ON RACE. POVERTY THE
ENVIRONMENT. UM èC R PE IS
COMMITTED TO UPLIFTING,
UNDERREPRESENTED FRONT LINE
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. THE COMMUNITIES THAT
WILL ALSO BE MOST IMPACTED BY
INCOMING HYDROGEN PROJECTS. WE
DISAGREE WITH S¼ B 14 TWENTY'S
DEFINITION OF RENEWABLE AND
CLEAN HYDROGEN, ITS
QUALIFICATION UNDER THIS
CALIFORNIA RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD PROGRAM, AND THIS BILL
S¼ STREAMLINING. THE BILL'S
DEFINITION OF HYDROGEN, UH,
FAILS TO INCLUDE CRITERIA
CRITICAL GUARD RAILS SUCH AS THE
THREE PILLARS, UM, HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION WITHOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE THREE
PILLARS IS INEFFICIENT AT BEST.
EVEN WORSE. HYDROGEN AS DEFINED
INCLUDES BIOMASS AND FACTORY
FARM DAIRY GAS, THE INCLUSION OF
WHICH IS EXTREMELY POLLUTING AND
DANGEROUS. BIOMASS FACILITIES
ARE SOME OF THE WORST POINT
SOURCES OF PARTICULATE MATTER,
AND THEY ARE BEING PLANNED FOR
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY, THE
NATION'S WORST AIR BASIN. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE
CREATION OF PROCUREMENT TARGETS
FOR RENEWABLE HYDROGEN, WHICH
WOULD PUSH MORE HYDROGEN
CREATION AND DIS DISINCENTIVIZE
INVESTMENTS INTO ALTERNATIVES
THAT ARE MORE EFFICIENT FOR OUR
CLIMATE AND HEALTHIER FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. THESE CONCERNS
UNDERLINE THE IMPORTANCE OF FULL
AND ROBUST S¼ QL REVIEWS FOR
HYDROGEN PROJECTS SQ OFFERS A
MEANS FOR COMMUNITIES TO
ACTIVELY PARTICIPATE AND
CONTRIBUTE ESSENTIAL INSIGHTS.
UM AND CONCERNS REGARDING MAJOR
PROJECTS. IT IS THE ONE
OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMUNITIES TO
BE INFORMED ON THE RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROJECTS AND
HOLD AGENCIES AND DEVELOPERS
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THEIR DECISIONS
RATHER THAN BE S¼ L AS A
HINDRANCE TO RESPONSIBLE
DEVELOPMENT. IT SHOULD BE SEEN
AS A NECESSITY THAT ENSURES
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES INFORM
DECISION MAKING AND GOVERNMENT
TRANSPARENCY. WHEN IT COMES TO
STOPPING CLIMATE CHANGE. WE
OFTEN HEAR THAT WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO TAKE TOOLS OFF THE TABLE WHEN
IN FACT, THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO WASTE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND DECADES
OF DEVELOPMENT ON CLIMATE
DISTRACTIONS THAT WILL SUBSIDIZE
UTILITIES, FOSSIL FUEL COMPANIES
, THE DAIRY INDUSTRY AND OTHERS
LOOKING TO EXPAND THEIR PROFITS
AT THE EXPENSE OF FRONT LINE
COMMUNITIES AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE
DISCUSSED OUR CONCERNS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND LOOK FORWARD
TO MORE DISCUSSIONS ON HYDROGEN
BILLS AND LANGUAGE. WE CAN
SUPPORT, HOWEVER, FOR THESE
REASONS. èC RP èC R PE ASKED
THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE NÓ ON S¼ B
1420. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SIR. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MR CHAIR, MARK
FENSTERMAKER REPRESENTING AND OR
JUSTICE. WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO S¼ P 1420. WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
HYDROGEN PRESENTS IN MEETING OUR
CLIMATE AND CLEAN AIR GOALS SO
LONG AS THAT HYDROGEN IS
PRODUCED IN A MANNER THAT ALIGNS
WITH OUR CLIMATE AND AIR QUALITY
GOALS. WHICH REQUIRES ACHIEVING
CARBON NEUTRALITY AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE, AND A WIDESPREAD
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSIONS
EQUIPMENT AND OUR MOST POLLUTED
REGIONS. WE ARE FOCUSED ON
CALIFORNIA BEING A LEADER IN THE
PRODUCTION OF GREEN HYDROGEN,
BUT IT MUST BE BASED ON THE
THREE PILLARS, MEANING THAT
HYDROGEN IS PRODUCED THROUGH
ELECTROLYSIS. IS POWERED BY NEW
OR ADDITIONAL RENEWABLE ENERGY
RESOURCES, PRODUCED AND CONSUMED
IN REAL TIME AND DELIVERED ON TO
CALIFORNIA'S GRID. WITHOUT THE
THREE PILLARS HYDROGEN CAN AND
LIKELY WILL INCREASE CARBON
EMISSIONS, AND THIS IS A KEY
CONCERN OF OURS WITH THE
PRODUCTION PATHWAYS PROPOSED IN
THIS BILL. THE US TREASURY
DEPARTMENT HAS PROPOSED RULES
FOR IMPLEMENTING THE FEDERAL TAX
CREDIT FOR ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION THAT REQUIRE HYDROGEN
TO BE PRODUCED WITH THE THREE
PILLARS TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
MOST LUCRATIVE TIER CATALYZING A
BOOM IN THE PRODUCTION OF TRULY
CLEAN OR GREEN HYDROGEN. THE
LOWEST TIER WOULD AWARD
PRODUCTION WITH A WELD GATE
LIFECYCLE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS RATE OF NOT GREATER
THAN 4 KG OF CO. TWO EQUIVALENT
PER KILOGRAM OF HYDROGEN, THE
SAME METRIC THAT S¼ 1420 USES TO
DEFINE QUALIFIED CLEAN HYDROGEN.
CALIFORNIA HAS A PROUD HISTORY
OF PUSHING THE ENVELOPE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY, A
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION, SO WE
STRUGGLE TO UNDERSTAND WHY
CALIFORNIA WOULD AIM FOR THE
BOTTOM OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
STANDARDS RATHER THAN RACE TO
THE TOP. ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AND ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS, ALONG
WITH HYDROGEN PRODUCTION
COMPANIES AND ELECTROLYZER
MANUFACTURERS HAVE ALL INDICATED
SUPPORT FOR THE THREE PILLARS
APPROACH AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD LEAN IN
RATHER THAN PUSH AWAY FROM
ADOPTING POLICY REQUIRING THE
THREE PILLARS. WE ALSO HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS WITH THE SEQUEL
STREAMLINING PROPOSAL IN S¼ B
1420. WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENT
TO REMOVE STREAMLINING FOR
PROJECTS USING HYDROGEN, BUT THE
PRODUCTION SIDE STILL WARRANTS
FULL SECRET REVIEW PROJECTS THAT
PRODUCE RENEWABLE HYDROGEN ARE
LIKE LIKELY TO BE FIRST OF THEIR
KIND FACILITIES. EACH PRODUCTION
PROJECT IS LIKELY TO POSE UNIQUE
ENVIRONMENTAL RISKS GIVEN THE
NUMEROUS DISPARATE TECHNOLOGIES
INDUSTRY MAY PROPOSE FOR
PRODUCING RENEWABLE OR
PURPORTEDLY LOW CARBON HYDROGEN,
AND THESE NOVEL APPROACHES NEED
TO BE UNDERSTOOD THROUGH THE
SECRET PROCESS TO ENSURE THE
BEST PROJECTS PROCEED. LASTLY AS
IT PERTAINS TO QUALIFYING
HYDROGEN AS AN RP S¼ RESOURCE.
WE APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS
RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS AND AT
CERTAIN SAFEGUARDS ARE NEEDED TO
MAKE SURE WE GET THIS RIGHT AND
DON'T INCREASE EMISSIONS FROM
THE ELECTRIC SECTOR. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE, THE ENERGY COMMITTEE
AND THE AUTHOR ON THESE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS. WE APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE HAD
WITH THE AUTHORS STAFF AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE, BUT
FOR TODAY WE MUST OPPOSE SB
1420. OK LET'S HEAR FROM OTHER
FOLKS WHO WANT TO WEIGH IN IN
OPPOSITION ARE CONCERNED.
MELISSA ROMERO, CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE
BILL. THANK YOU. I'M MEGAN. SOME
WAY. I'M REPRESENTING SACRAMENTO
350 CLIMATE ACTION CALIFORNIA
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING, RAL MASON, UM,
REGISTERING OPPOSITION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ALLIANCE, ALSO REGISTERING FOR
THE CENTER ON COMMUNITY ACTION
AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY. LOS ANGELES.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. JENNIFER
FEARING I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
EXPRESS THE OPPOSITION OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK AND COMMUNITIES FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR. NLA IN
CALIFORNIA WITH CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE AND OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, JAMIE
KATZ WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING,
CHRISTINA SQUARE WITH THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY AND
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, DRY
LITTLE ON BEHALF OF NRDC AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. OK? ALL RIGHT, UM HM?
BEFORE WE GET INTO OUR
DISCUSSION AMONG THE COMMITTEE.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE A FEW
REMARKS ABOUT THE BILL AND SOME
OF THE PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD WITH MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND ALSO WITH THE
AUTHOR, UM SO FIRST OF ALL, UM
THANK YOU FOR, UH, FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS WHOLE ISSUE OF
ADDRESSING THE SCOPE OF THE
PROJECTS USING HYDROGEN THAT
COULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR PERMIT,
STREAMLINE STREAMLINING. AS I
THINK THERE ARE SOME EXISTING
CONTINUING S¼ CONCERNS. HAS IT
BEEN ARTICULATED BY THE
OPPOSITION, BUT I WILL SAY THAT,
UM AS WRITTEN. THE BILL WOULD
GIVE ACCESS TO LL Dð P AND èC E
, UM, OPT IN STREAMLINING FOR
ANY PROJECT THAT PRODUCES OR
USES ANY RENEWABLE OR CLEAN
HYDROGEN, AND THAT REALLY GAVE
US PAUSE. AND IT WAS INCREDIBLY
BROAD. UM, LANGUAGE. AND IT
ALLOWED FOR SHORTENED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT AND REVIEW OF ANY
HYDROGEN PROJECT EFFECTIVELY.
AND GIVEN HOW MUCH HYDROGEN
TECHNOLOGY IS BEING DEVELOPED.
WE MIGHT NOT EVEN KNOW WHAT ALL
THOSE PROJECTS COULD END UP
BEING BEFORE STREAMLINING THEM.
SO THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK IT WAS OF REAL CONCERN FOR
THE COMMITTEE. AND, UM WE
ADDRESSED THAT, THROUGH THE
ACCEPTANCE OF THE AMENDMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE TO LIMIT TO
HYDROGEN'S PRODUCTION AND USE IN
RP S¼ ELIGIBLE FACILITIES. AND I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT NOW.
THIS IS A BIG TECHNICAL
MULTIFACETED BILL. I MEAN, FIVE
BILLS IN ONE AS I'VE HEARD FROM
SOME PEOPLE, UM SO CERTAINLY,
UH, ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE ALONE
DOESN'T ADDRESS ALL THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE. AND I. I THINK YOU KNOW,
THE AUTHOR KNOWS THIS. UM, WE
DON'T SHARE THE ANTIPATHY TOWARD
THE THREE PILLARS THAT HAS BEEN
EXPRESSED. YOU KNOW, THERE ARE A
LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY OPPOSITION AS WELL.
THAT I THINK ARE IN LINE WITH
WHERE WE ARE. AS A COMMITTEE.
THE ANALYSIS FLAGS A NUMBER OF
THESE QUESTIONS. I HOPE IT CAN
TRY A PATH FORWARD, UM, FOR US
TO FOLLOW AS THE BILL GOES
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
I UNDERSTAND THIS IS THE VERY
FIRST COMMITTEE, AND IT IS A
LONG AND WINDING ROAD. SO SOME
SOME EXAMPLES ON ON ON PAGE 12
OF THE ANALYSIS. UH, YOU KNOW,
THE COMMITTEE STAFF DISCUSSES
THE DEFINITION OF QUALIFIED
CLEAN HYDROGEN IN THE BILL. UM
YOU KNOW SPECIFICALLY HOW EVEN
THOUGH IT SETS A CLEAR AND
IMPROVING TARGET FOR THE CARBON
INTENSITY OF HYDROGEN, IT DOES
NOT ENTIRELY PROHIBIT THE USE OF
FOSSIL FUEL FEED STOCKS. NÓ, THE
AUTHOR. AND I, UH, I KNOW THIS
IS A CONCERN OF SEVERAL MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. THE AUTHOR AND
I SPOKE ABOUT THIS ON MONDAY
WHEN WE MET, UM THE USE OF
FOSSIL FUEL. FEEDSTOCKS DOES NOT
, UH, YOU KNOW SHE'S EXPRESSED
TO ME IT'S NOT OUR INTENT WITH
THE BILL. UH, YOU KNOW, THE REAL
FOCUS IS ON. YOU KNOW AND
BIOMASS. AND I THINK THE FUTURE
AMENDMENTS COULD HELP TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE BY
CLARIFYING THAT, AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE AGREED TO
WORK ON. AND GET RESOLVED. UM,
SIMILARLY, PAGE 13. OF THE
ANALYSIS NOTES THAT THE BILL
ELIMINATES A PROHIBITION ON
PROJECTS USING BIOMASS FUELS
USING LDP. STREAMLINING. AGAIN
THE AUTHOR HAS DESCRIBED TO US
THAT HER INTENT IS JUST TO
ENABLE SOME PROMISING STATE OF
THE ART TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN
PRODUCE HYDROGEN FROM WASTE
WITHOUT THE SAME AIR POLLUTION
ISSUES THAT OLD BIOMASS PLANTS
HAD. AND I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
CONCERNS ON THAT FRONT. I'VE
BEEN WORKING IN THE SPACE FOR A
WHILE AND I. I REMEMBER UH AND
I'VE CERTAINLY HEARD CONCERNS
FROM ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES ON THAT QUESTION, SO
IT WOULD YOU KNOW, WE NEED TO
GET THAT CLARIFIED AS WELL.
THEN, OF COURSE, RP S¼. NOW, UM
THAT'S TECHNICALLY, UH, ENERGY.
COMMITTEE. ENERGY UTILITIES
COMMITTEE PURVIEW WHERE THE BILL
GOES NEXT, BUT IT CERTAINLY
DESERVES OUR ATTENTION. TODAY WE
ARE THE LEAD COMMITTEE ON
CLIMATE POLICY. AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT RP S¼ IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT TOOL IN ADDRESSING OUR
OUR CLIMATE, UH, CHALLENGES IT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT WE CARE
A GREAT DEAL ABOUT, UM SO THE
AUTHOR DID KEEP ONE PARTICULAR
ELEMENT OF SENATOR ARCHULETA S¼
S¼ B 663 THAT WE HEARD LAST YEAR
THAT RELATES TO THIS, UH,
SPECIFICALLY SAYING THAT OUR P
S¼ ELIGIBLE HYDROGEN PROJECTS,
YOU KNOW, MUST NOT RESULT IN A
NET INCREASE IN AIR POLLUTION OR
IN G HÌ G S¼ FROM THE ELECTRICAL
SECTOR. UM OF COURSE, AS SEEMS
TO BE THE CASE IN ALL THINGS
HYDROGEN. THE DEVIL IS REALLY IN
THE DETAILS HERE. UM BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
ACKNOWLEDGMENT. OBVIOUSLY
HYDROGEN ONLY MAKES SENSE AS A
DECARBONIZATION SOLUTION WHEN IT
TRULY REDUCES GHG EMISSIONS
ACROSS THE BOARD. SO I KNOW THAT
THE NEXT COMMITTEE IS GONNA BE
WORKING ON THIS. UM AND I'M
WE'RE CERTAINLY YOU KNOW.
HOPEFUL AND CONFIDENT THAT THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE, YOU
KNOW, WILL MAKE SURE THAT THIS
IMPORTANT PROVISION INCLUDES ALL
THE DETAILS NECESSARY TO ENSURE
THAT EMISSIONS ARE CORRECTLY AND
FULLY ACCOUNTED FOR, BECAUSE RP
S¼ IS A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF
OUR CLIMATE. CHANGE FIGHTING.
TOOLBOX. SO. THE AUTHORS AGREED
TO THE SPECIFIC AMENDMENTS
WRITTEN IN THE IN THE ANALYSIS.
WHAT WE ARE ASKING FOR, AND IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT AUTHORS
AGREE TO IS THAT THAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR THE AUTHOR'S
COMMITMENT TO RESOLVING THREE
ISSUES MOVING FORWARD. UM NUMBER
ONE FOSSIL FUEL. PRE QUALIFIED
CLEAN HYDROGEN. TO ONLY ADVANCE
BIOMASS FACILITIES FOR
STREAMLINING. AND THREE,
PROVIDING MORE DETAIL ON HOW
EMISSIONS RESULTING FROM
HYDROGEN'S USE IN RP S¼ ELIGIBLE
FACILITIES IS ACCOUNTED FOR. UM
YOU KNOW? KNOW THE BILL HAS A
LONG WINDING ROAD AHEAD. UM AND
YOU KNOW, I'M YOU WANT TO LET
THE AUTHOR CONTINUE TO WORK ON
ON IT? UH, I'M I'M ULTIMATELY
WILLING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY WITH THE AMENDMENTS AND
THE COMMITMENT TO WORK TOWARDS
RESOLVING AT LEAST THESE THREE
OTHER ISSUES. I KNOW THAT
COLLEAGUES MAY HAVE DIFFERENT
OPINIONS, AND I KNOW THERE'S
SOME KIND OF EXISTING CONCERNS
OUT THERE ABOUT VARIOUS ASPECTS
OF THE BILL. BUT I KNOW THAT THE
STAFF AND MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE WILL CONTINUE TO BE I
REALLY CLOSELY ENGAGED EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY WE MAINTAIN THE
RIGHT TO PULL IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE IF THE NEED ARISES,
GIVEN THE TERMS OF OUR
UNDERSTANDING, BUT I DO WANT TO
THANK YOU, UH, SENATOR CABALLERO
FOR, UM YOU KNOW YOUR EARNEST
COMMITMENT TO WORKING THROUGH
THE YOU KNOW THESE CONTINUING
CONCERNS ON THE BILL, AND I KNOW
TODAY IS NOT THE LAST TIME WE'RE
GONNA BE SPEAKING ABOUT THIS,
AND SO, UM, I WISH YEAH. AND SO
II. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
KIND OF INITIAL REACTIONS TO MY
COMMENTS AND THEN WANNA OPEN UP
THE FLOOR TO COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR.
LET ME JUST SAY THAT I AM I
ALWAYS APPRECIATE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU ABOUT, UM
, CRUNCHY BILLS. UM IT IT'S UM
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE GET THIS
RIGHT. AND IT'S IMPORTANT. IN IN
TERMS OF OUR FUTURE. EFFORTS TO
DECARBONIZE THE STATE. AND IT'S
IMPORTANT. TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES. THAT
WILL MAKE A TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCE IN COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THEY'RE RIGHT NOW, AS WE
STAND. I HAVE NÓ PATHWAY. AT
ALL. TOWARDS A JUST TRANSITION.
AND IF I COULD SAY MY LABOR
FRIENDS DON'T LIKE THAT WORD.
JUST TRANSITION. UM BECAUSE IT
IT IT THEY FEEL LIKE IT'S BEEN
IMPOSED ON THEM. THEY'VE THEY'VE
GOT THEIR OWN IDEA ABOUT WHAT
SHOULD HAPPEN, BUT WE DON'T HAVE
ANY WAY TO GET FROM THE
REDUCTION OF JOBS IN FOSSIL
FUELS, TOO. A COMPARABLE SALARY
IN, UH, THE ENERGY INDUSTRY. AND
SO THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES. AND
THIS IS ONE OF THEM. IT IS. I
HAVE NEVER SAID THIS IS THE
SILVER BULLET, SO WHOEVER IT IS,
HAS SAID THIS ISN'T A SILVER
BULLET. I'VE NEVER SAID THAT.
I'VE HAD MULTIPLE BULLETS IN
FRONT IN FRONT OF THIS
LEGISLATURE AND I WON'T GO INTO
THEM. BUT THEY'VE ALL BEEN
ENERGY PRODUCING AND THEY GET
RID OF WASTE. WHICH IS ONE OF
THE THINGS WE DESPERATELY NEED
TO DO IS TO GET RID OF WASTE,
WHETHER IT'S AGRICULTURE OR
DAIRY WASTE OR TRASH THAT THAT
WE HAVE OR OUR OWN SOLID WASTE.
WE HAVE WASTE AND WE NEED TO GET
RID OF IT. AND IF WE CAN TURN IT
INTO ENERGY THROUGH A PROCESS,
THEN I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
THING. BUT LET ME JUST SAY THAT
THAT, UM, THAT FOR EVERY CONCERN
, THERE'S AN ANSWER. WE JUST
NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THE
LANGUAGE THAT HAS PEOPLE FEELING
THE MOST. UM UH, THAT THAT WE
HAVE TAKEN CARE OF AN ISSUE
THAT'S BEEN RAISED. AND SO THE
THREE ISSUES YOU RAISED. WE DID
WE? WE AGREED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON IT AND THE LANGUAGE
BECOMES REALLY IMPORTANT. SO UM
UH UH. WE WILL PROPOSE SOME
LANGUAGE AND WE CAN GO BACK AND
FORTH THAT IF IT MOVES OUT OF
THE COMMITTEE TODAY, THAT'S NOT
THE END OF WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE. I I COMMIT MY MYSELF
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
DIALOGUES AND TO SEE IF WE CAN
WORK THROUGH SOME OF THE, UM
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT UH, THAT
YOU RAISED AND THERE ARE OTHERS
AS WELL. BUT I, BUT I WANNA SAY
IN REGARDS TO THE THREE PILLARS,
UM NOT OPPOSED TO THE THREE
PILLARS. THEY JUST DON'T WORK IN
CALIFORNIA. THEY DON'T WORK IN
THE STATE OF WASHINGTON. THEY
DON'T WORK IN THE STATE OF
OREGON. IT'S THE REASON THAT THE
WESTERN STATES AND THERE MAY BE
MORE SIGNED A LETTER TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, SAYING WE
HAVE HIGHER STANDARDS IN OUR
STATE ALREADY THAN THE THREE
PILLARS. SO LET US DO OUR
PROJECT. OUR ARCHES PROJECT. UM
UH, UTILIZING THOSE HIGH
STANDARDS IN TO MEET OUR GOALS.
NOT ONLY IS CALIFORNIA PART OF
THAT LETTER, BUT IT'S THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD,
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
, THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION, AND GOBI
THEY ARE THEY SENT THEIR LETTERS
TO THE TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AS WELL. SO UM, THE TAX CREDIT
45 B IS BEING THE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORKS BEING ESTABLISHED AS
WE SPEAK, AND, UM AND THERE'S
FAIRLY SOLID UNANIMITY AMONG THE
THAT, UM, THAT THERE'S A
DIFFERENT WAY TO DO IT. OTHER
THAN THE THREE PILLAR. THE THREE
PILLARS HAVE BEEN ENCAPSULATED
IN THE WORK THAT WE'VE WE'VE
DONE ALREADY. SO I. I JUST PUT
THAT OUT THERE BECAUSE, UM, THAT
THAT'S THE MANTRA IS THAT YOU
KNOW, WE'RE TRYING TO SOMEHOW
CIRCUMVENT. UM UH UH,
RESPONSIBILITY, ACCOUNTABILITY
OR, OR? UM, UH UH. WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO CALL IT, UM TO THE
HIGHEST STANDARDS. THAT'S NOT
THE CASE. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS TO SAY, YOU KNOW, WE'VE
ALWAYS SAID CALIFORNIA IS
DIFFERENT, RIGHT? WELL IF WE'RE
DIFFERENT, THEN WHY NOT, UM, USE
THESE HIGHER STANDARDS AND
PRODUCE A PRODUCT THAT'S GOING
TO BE OF BENEFIT TO THE
COMMUNITY? NOT ONLY BECAUSE IT
HELPS US REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS.
IT HELPS US REDUCE OUR SOS AND
OUR KNOCKS. BUT IT ALSO STARTS
TO PROVIDE A TRANSITION TO, UM
UH, FOR OUR WORKFORCE. A
WORKFORCE THAT IS GOING TO BE
DECIMATED IN RURAL CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE IN MY REGION, WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS, UM INDUSTRIAL
SOLAR HAS MOVED IN, AND IT HAS
TAKEN OVER FARMS. IT HAS REDUCED
THE NUMBER OF WORKERS THAT HAVE
JOBS. IT HAS A DELETERIOUS
EFFECT ON LOCAL, SMALL LOCAL
COMMUNITIES, AND, UM IT IT
REDUCES REVENUE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE WE DON'T TAX
SOLAR BIG SOLAR PROJECTS SO
THERE'S THIS THIS THIS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT PERIOD OF
TIME WHERE IF WE MAY, IF WE PICK
THE RIGHT ROAD, WE CAN MAKE A
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE IN THE
STATE BY ACCOMPLISHING A NUMBER
OF OUR GOALS AND IF PART OF THAT
IS WORKING ON THE LANGUAGE THAT
WE CAN GET IT RIGHT. I'M THERE.
UM BUT I NEED LANGUAGE SO FAR.
UM I'VE GOT THE OPPOSITION
LETTERS AND NONE OF THEM HAVE
LANGUAGE. THEY DON'T PROPOSE
SOLUTIONS. IT'S JUST NÓ. WELL,
YOU CERTAINLY HAVE THE COMM. OF
THE COMMITTEE TO WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH YOU ON, UM THOSE
THREE AND SEVERAL OTHER ISSUES I
DO WANT TO, AND I WANT TO OPEN
UP THE DISCUSSION, I WILL SAY,
UM UNLESS I'M GROTESQUELY
MISINFORMED. IT IS MY VERY
STRONG UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
DON'T HAVE. WE DON'T ALREADY
HAVE HIGHER STANDARDS THAN THREE
PILLARS FOR HYDROGEN. IN IN
CALIFORNIA. UH, SO AND I, YOU
KNOW, AND II. I DON'T THINK
WE'RE WEDDED TO IF THERE IS, IF
THERE IS AN ALTERNATIVE APPROACH
THAT'S WORKABLE THAT ALSO MEETS
OUR HIGH ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
THAT IS NOT, YOU KNOW, IN STRICT
COMPLIANCE WITH THE THREE
PILLARS. I THINK WE'RE VERY OPEN
TO THAT. BUT UH YOU KNOW, I
UNDERSTAND IT WAS WRITTEN IT IT
IT. THESE THINGS GET WRITTEN,
AND THEY'RE NOT SACROSANCT, BUT,
UM, THEY REFLECT A SPIRIT AND A
SET OF CONCERNS ABOUT THIS. FUEL
THAT ARE VERY REAL. THAT UM THAT
THIS COMMITTEE IS GONNA BE
CONTINUE TO BE REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT IF I JUST PUT THAT OUT
THERE IN TERMS OF THE FUTURE OF
CO-OPERATION ON THIS TOGETHER,
SO I AGREE, MR CHAIR. WOULD YOU
LIKE AN A TECHNICAL EXPLANATION?
I GIVE YOU THE IMPASSIONED
EMOTIONAL EXPLANATION, BUT IN
TERMS OF THE THREE PILLARS, OK,
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM FIRST,
UM YEAH. LISTEN. SENATORS, ALLEN
ALAN HERE, DOLLY DALI PRESENT
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HERE, HURTADO.
MENJIVAR MENJIVAR HERE WHEN
SKINNER. OK? UM SO WHAT? YOU
WANTED HIM TO SAY SOMETHING, BUT
IF, UH IF IN TERMS OF THE THREE
PILLARS OK, SURE, AND THEN WELL,
LET'S LET'S OPEN UP THE FLOOR OF
THE DISCUSSION, SO THE THREE
PILLARS ARE THE THREE PILLARS
ARE ONE WAY TO ACHIEVE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL OUTCOME. BUT M I
Tð UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA,
IRVINE, AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS HAVE HAD
RESEARCHERS AND PROFESSORS WHO
HAVE, UH, YOU KNOW STUDIED THIS
AND WE CAN ACHIEVE THE SAME
ENVIRONMENTAL OUTCOME WITH LOWER
COSTS. UH E, THREE WHO MODELS
THE SCOPING PLAN, THE IRP. THE I
IS INDICATED THAT IN ALL 40
SCENARIOS THAT THEY MODELED, UH,
THERE WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN COSTS OF PRODUCING
THIS TYPE OF HYDROGEN, WHEREAS
THE ENVIRONMENTAL OUTCOME THE
0.45 KG PER KILOGRAM OF HYDROGEN
COULD BE ACHIEVED WITH DIFFERENT
STANDARDS IN THE Dð Ó E S¼ OWN
WHITE PAPER ON ACHIEVING 45 TAX
CREDIT, YOU KNOW THE STANDARDS
OF 0.45 KI PER KILOGRAM OF
HYDROGEN. INDICATES THAT
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY HAS A MORE
ADVANCED CARBON MODELING THAN
THE REST OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND WE DO WE HAVE BEEN FAR OUT
AHEAD OF THIS FOR DECADES, AND
SO TO BIT THREE PILLARS WITHIN
THE CONFINES OF CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING POLICY STRUCTURES WOULD
BE DETRIMENTAL TO THE
ADVANCEMENT AND PROLIFERATION OF
HYDROGEN. I THINK THE OPPONENTS
DON'T WANT TO SEE THE
PROLIFERATION OF HYDROGEN, WHICH
IS WHY THEY'RE TRYING TO IMPOSE
THREE PILLARS WHEN THREE PILLARS
WERE IMPOSED IN THE EUROPEAN
UNION. WE SEE THE LOWEST FINANCE
DECISION RATE OF ANY
JURISDICTION IN THE WORLD. UM
THIS THIS IS NOT A POLICY
INTENDED TO HELP. LOOK I'M I'M
NEUTRAL ON THE POLLUTION.
HYDROGEN I JUST WANT TO SEE IF
WE'RE GONNA DO IT. IT NEEDS TO
MEET OUR ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AND
WE CAN ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS AND
SO WITHIN THE CONFINES OF THE RP
S¼ WITHIN THE CONFINES OF THE
CAP AND TRADE. WE'RE REALLY,
REALLY CAREFUL. IF WE'RE REALLY,
REALLY CAREFUL ABOUT HOW WE
FRAME THIS, THAT'S THE KEY HERE.
SO LET'S OPEN THIS UP TO
DISCUSSION. UH FROM MEMBERS. UH,
SENATOR THANK YOU, MR CHAIR. UH
SENATOR I. I SHARE A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS FROM THE EJ GROUP AND
I. I DO WANNA THE FIRST SAY THAT
I. I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT
TO THE THREE ITEMS THAT THE
CHAIR MENTIONED, BUT I STILL
HAVE SOME OUTSTANDING CONCERNS,
AND ONE OF THE ONE OF MY BIGGEST
CONCERNS IS RELATED, UM TO
POTENTIALLY REMOVING PUBLIC
INPUT. AND YOU KNOW, THE
ANALYSIS SHARED JUST ONE EXAMPLE
OF ORANGE GROVE AND THAT WE HEAR
THAT KIND OF STORY EVERYWHERE,
RIGHT? WHERE CERTAIN MORE
AFFLUENT AREAS WILL HAVE A
LOUDER VOICE AND GET TO MOVE
PROJECTS ELSEWHERE. AND IN THIS
CASE, UM WAS IT SOCAL GAS? MOVED
THERE FACILITY TO ORANGE GROVE.
THAT IS 96% LATINO. I MEAN,
THAT'S THE STORY THAT WE HEAR
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. I'D LIKE TO
LEARN A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
PROTECT, UM, COMMUNITY
EMPLOYMENT WHEN WE'RE
STREAMLINING THIS AND IN
RELATION TO STREAMLINING S¼.
THIS BODY HERE I THINK HAS A
HUGE BURDEN OR HUGE
RESPONSIBILITY TO THINK. NOW.
WHAT ARE WAYS THE SEQUEL PROCESS
? WE HAVE FOUGHT VERY HARD TO
KEEP TO PROTECT A LOT OF THESE
COMMUNITIES. UM, WE WERE A BILL
GOT PULLED FROM THIS COMMITTEE
BECAUSE IT WAS LOOKING TO DO THE
SAME THING THAT WE SOME OF US
FELT DIDN'T OUTWEIGH THE
BENEFITS AND STREAMLINING A
BILLION QUESTIONS. BUT I'M GONNA
JUST START WITH THAT ONE
QUESTION IN RELATION TO
STREAMLINING, POTENTIALLY
REMOVING COMMUNITY INPUT, SO
IT'S NOT THE INTENTION OF THE
BILL TO ELIMINATE COMMUNITY
INPUT BECAUSE I AGREE WITH YOU.
100% SEQUELS ARE REALLY, REALLY
IMPORTANT TOOL. THE PART THAT WE
ARE FOCUSED ON IS A SEQUEL TO,
UM IT'S A STREAMLINING THE
JUDICIAL REVIEW, NOT THE PUBLIC
INPUT IN THE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
THE ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE. THE
ARCHES PROJECT, WHICH IS THE
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAM. THAT
IS THE UNDERPINNING OF THIS
BILL. PART OF THE REQUIREMENT
THAT FEDERAL GRANT IS A
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT PROCESS,
AND IT'S IT IS NEW AND IT'S
ROBUST AND IT'S THE IT'S ONE OF
THOSE, UM OBLIGATIONS AND YOU
HAVE TO, UM, YOU BASICALLY YOU
HAVE TO GIVE THE COMMUNITY THE
ABILITY TO DECIDE WHETHER THEY
WANT THE PROJECT IN THEIR
BACKYARD OR NOT, OR IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD OR IN THEIR AREA
BECAUSE IT COULD BE THAT IT'S
OUTSIDE OF A COMMUNITY, BUT IT
STILL COULD HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THE COMMUNITY. SO A BIG PART OF
ARCHES IS TO GO IN AND DO A
COMMUNITY EDUCATION. HERE'S WHAT
IT IS. HERE'S WHAT WE WOULD DO
THAT KIND OF THING, AND IT'S
GRASSROOTS ENGAGEMENT. UM THAT
THAT IS REQUIRED IN ORDER FOR
YOU TO BE ABLE TO FIRST MOVE
FORWARD AND ACCESS THE GRANT
MONEY, SO THERE'S NO INTENTION
TO TAKE THAT AWAY. THE INTENTION
IS TO BE ABLE TO EXPEDITE
PROJECTS ONCE THEY'VE ONCE
THEY'VE PASSED A CERTAIN LEVEL.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY'VE DONE THE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. THEY'VE
HAD INPUT FROM THE COMMUNITY.
THERE IS A COMMUNITY BENEFIT
OBLIGATION, SO THEY HAVE TO
AGREE TO FUND THINGS AND ONE OF
THE ONE OF THE OPTIONS MAY EVEN
BE THE COMMUNITY MAY SAY WE WANT
TO OWN IT OR WE WANT TO BE
PARTNERS. WE WANT TO BE, UH YEAH
PARTNERS. UM AND THEY CREATE THE
FRAMEWORK FOR THAT TO BE ABLE TO
HAPPEN, BUT AT A MINIMUM, THERE
IS A COMMUNITY BENEFIT THAT THEY
CAN THEY CAN IDENTIFY. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE JOBS ARE
LOCAL. AND SO WE WANT TO
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT'S
COMMUNITY BENEFIT. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS OUTDOOR
SPACE OR, UM, YOU KNOW, I'M
MAKING UP THINGS NOW. BUT
WHATEVER IT IS THAT THE
COMMUNITY DECIDES IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT PART OF THE RESPONSIBILITY
SO THERE WILL BE IN TERMS OF THE
ARCHES, UM, FUNDING AND, UM,
COMMITMENT. THERE IS A VERY
ROBUST THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING
THAT AND I'LL DO ONE MORE
QUESTION BEFORE I WE PLAYED TAG
HERE, UM SENATOR QUÊ. YOU KNOW,
THIS IS I FEEL LIKE FIVE BILLS
IN 12. REALLY BIG, BIG LIFT TO
CHANGE A LOT OF POLICY HERE.
MAYBE IF YOU CAN SHARE A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT WHY NOT ALLOW
MORE THOROUGH POLICY? DISCUSSION
ON ONE PER. WHY LUMP THEM ALL? I
FEEL LIKE WE MIGHT BE RUSHING A
HUGE, HUGE LIFT ALL IN ONE BILL.
WELL YOUR POINT IS WELL TAKEN,
AND I THINK MY EXPERIENCE IS
THAT, UM IS THAT WHAT YOU YOU
HAVE TO DO IS PROPOSED. WHAT YOU
THINK, ARE THE SOLUTIONS TO BE
ABLE TO GET THINGS DONE? WE JUST
SAY THAT THE FRAMEWORK FOR THIS
IS WORKING WITH ARCHES SO THAT
WE CAN ACCESS THE RESOURCES
RESOURCES THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
AVAILABLE BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. NUMBER ONE NUMBER
TWO IS THAT, UM, UM PART OF SO
FIRST IT IS THE DEFINITION SO
THAT WE KNOW WHAT WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH HYDROGEN, BUT THE
OTHER WERE THE TWO BILLS THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE, UM, RESOLVED LAST
YEAR AND JUST NEVER GOT TO IT.
UM CAN THE BILL BE PULLED APART
INTO DIFFERENT PIECES? YES, IT
CAN. AND MAYBE IN ONE COMMITTEE
THAT THERE'S A REQUEST THAT THAT
HAPPENED, BUT ULTIMATELY, EVERY
SINGLE PART OF THE BILL NEEDS TO
BE. WE NEED TO MOVE AT SOME
POINT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW. ARTIST
IS NEGOTIATING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ABOUT WHAT PROJECTS
AND THE DETAILS OF THE TIMING OF
HOW THEY SHOULD HAPPEN. BUT WE
HAVE TO THAT PROJECT HAS TO
SPEND THE MONEY FAIRLY
EFFICIENTLY. AND EXPEDITIOUSLY.
OTHERWISE IT GOES TO OTHER
STATES. SO THAT'S THE REASON FOR
THIS, THE EXPEDITED SECRET
JUDICIAL REVIEW AND THAT'S ALSO
THE REASON FOR THE CONSOLIDATED
PERMITTING PROCESS WHERE, UM THE
PERMITTING HAPPENS IN IN ONE OR
ENTITY, AND THEY'RE ALL WORKING
TOGETHER. SO CAN IT BE? PULLED
APART. YES IT CAN BE. UM, BUT MY
ATTITUDE IS WE GO BIGGER. WE GO
HOME, AND, UM AND A BIG PART OF
THIS IS TO TAKE THE TIME TO GET
THROUGH AND EXPLAIN WHAT IT IS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
THIS AND ENGAGE. AND IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE. TO ENGAGE UNLESS YOU
HAVE SOMEONE ON THE OTHER SIDE.
IT'S A WILLING PARTNER. AND SO I
WANT TO COMMEND THE CHAIR
BECAUSE WHAT HE HAS SAID IS HE
STILL GOT SOME CONCERNS AND HE'S
WILLING TO HELP TO WORK ON IT.
BUT WE NEED LANGUAGE IN ORDER TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
GETTING IT RIGHT. I WANT TO GET
IT RIGHT. I DON'T WANT TO JUST
JAM SOMETHING THROUGH. I WANT TO
GET IT RIGHT. SENATOR DOLLY
GONZALEZ. YEAH. OKAY? I WILL
YIELD THE FLOOR TO YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. UM WELL, THANK YOU,
MR CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR AS WELL. I DO COMMEND YOU
AS WELL FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR SOME TIME.
WE CERTAINLY SHARE DIFFERENCES
IN THIS ASPECT. AND YOU KNOW,
THAT'S CERTAINLY NOT ANY SECRET
WHATSOEVER. BUT UM, SHARING THE
SAME CONCERNS. LOOK I'M ALL FOR
PREEMPTING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. BUT I WANT TO BE
ABLE TO PREEMPT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHEN WE HAVE THE BEST
AND HIGHEST STANDARDS. UM, WE DO
HAVE COMMUNITIES MANY OF US
SHARE AND THAT LOOKS SIMILAR
THAT STILL SEE THIS AS VERY
NASCENT TECHNOLOGY AND STILL
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
UTILIZING HYDROGEN TO THE BEST
OF ITS ABILITY AND THE MOST
CLEAN AND RENEWABLE WAY. BUT WE
DON'T REALLY HAVE. THESE
DEFINITIONS ARE ARBITRARY AND
ALL OVER THE PLACE, IT SEEMS AND
IF WE'RE GOING TO PREEMPT 45 VÆ
THAT IS STILL GOING THROUGH
CONVERSATIONS AND PUBLIC COMMENT
RIGHT NOW, AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL,
I WANT TO ENSURE THAT NUMBER ONE
WE HAVE COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
THAT IS REALLY MEANINGFUL. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT BACK HOME THROUGH
THE ARCHES PROCESS. I FEEL LIKE
MANY OF MY COMMUNITY MEMBERS
DON'T FEEL AS THOUGH THE ARCHES
PROCESS HAS BEEN AS A PUBLIC AND
TRANSPARENT AND MEANINGFUL AS IT
SHOULD BE. THESE ARE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE HIT THE HARDEST ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AND I KNOW I KNOW
YOU UNDERSTAND THIS AND YOU
SHARE THAT SAME VALUE THAT I DO.
AND ALSO AGAIN INCLUSIVE OF THE
THREE PILLARS. IT'S EASY FOR US
TO DISMISS THAT THE THREE
PILLARS SHOULDN'T BE INCLUDED
HERE. BUT THERE IS A PROCESS
THAT WE SHOULD ALL BE GOING
THROUGH AT HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO
BE ABLE TO FIND A WAY TO COME TO
SOME COMPROMISE OVER THIS THREE
PILLARS AND TO REALLY AGAIN
ENSURE THAT WE'RE APPLYING THE
BEST AND MOST MEANINGFUL AND
HIGHEST STANDARDS FOR THIS AND
THEN ALSO UTILIZING THE SEQUEL
PRIVILEGES AGAIN. IT'S REALLY
HARD FOR US TO FOR ME TO COME TO
THAT PLACE WHERE I FEEL LIKE
THIS COULD BE APPLIED. TO THIS
TO THIS BILL, STILL SHARING
THOSE CONCERNS WITH YOU? UM YOU
KNOW, I WILL SIT AND LISTEN TO
THE ARGUMENTS AND DISCUSSIONS
MADE HERE, BUT THIS IS REALLY
HARD FOR ME PERSONALLY TO
SUPPORT. UM BUT I KNOW THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT HAPPENS TODAY
. I KNOW THAT YOU AND I WILL
CONTINUE SITTING DOWN AND MAKING
SURE THAT WE COME TO SOME SORT
OF AGREEMENT. AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE DEDICATED TO THAT. SO
WITH THAT, THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IF I IF I COULD, MR
CHAIR ON THE THREE PILLARS.
QUITE FRANKLY, UM, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS TRYING TO DECIDE
WHAT THEIR STANDARD IS GOING TO
BE IF THEY SAY IT'S THE THREE
PILLARS AND THEN UNTIL UNLESS
THEY GIVE US AN EXEMPTION OF
SOME KIND. IT WILL BE THE THREE
PILLARS. SOMEHOW IT HAS TO WORK.
RIGHT? UM UH HUH. THE REASON
THAT WE'VE PICKED THIS STRATEGY
IS BECAUSE IT'S A STRATEGY THAT
ALIGNS WITH OUR SISTER STATES IN
THE REGION AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT I THINK THERE'S ROOM
TO NEGOTIATE WITHIN THE THREE
PILLARS TO GET TO GET IT RIGHT.
BUT ULTIMATELY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL MAKE THAT
RESOURCE AVAILABLE AND WE'LL
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO ACCESS
IT. FOR THE IT'S THE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT INTO THE PROJECTS
THAT BECOME REALLY IMPORTANT.
THAT'S THE POINT. YEAH, SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT. SARAH, DARLING.
THANK YOU, MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
I JUST WANT TO START OFF BY
SAYING I'M GOING TO TRY TO, UH,
JUST BRING SOME COMMON SENSE TO
THE ISSUE HERE. IT'S BEEN
SOMETHING I KNOW THAT SENATOR
HAS BEEN WORKING ON TECHNOLOGY
JUST STATEWIDE, BUT FURTHER FOR
THE FOLKS IN YOUR DISTRICT THAT
ARE SUFFERING FROM UM,
POLLUTION. QUITE FRANKLY, UM I
HAVE BEEN TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND SAN WALKING VALLEY AND TO
THE TWO OF US HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON BIOMASS. UM SINCE THE TIME WE
HAVE BEEN HERE IN THIS
LEGISLATURE, BUT I WANTED TO SAY
THAT JUDICIAL REVIEW IS NOT.
WE'VE DONE THIS FOR SPORTS
ARENAS. WE'VE DONE IT FOR SITES
RESERVOIR. WE'VE DONE IT FOR ALL
KINDS OF PROJECTS. THIS IS NOT
EXCLUDING THE PUBLIC IN ANY WAY.
IT'S THE JUDICIAL REVIEWS. I
WANT TO I WANTED TO SET THAT OUT
RIGHT OUT OFF THE TOP. I AM VERY
FRUSTRATED. THE FACT THAT WE LET
THE WE MAKE THE PERFECT WE GET
IT. WE WANT THE PERFECT BUT
GETTING IN THE WAY OF THE GOOD.
WE HAVE FOCUSED IN THIS STATE ON
OUR RENEWABLES AS WIND AND
SOLAR. THOSE ARE THE TOP TWO
THINGS THAT WE LOOK AT. AND WE
REALLY QUITE FRANKLY, UM, NEED
SOME DIVERSITY AND HYDROGEN.
ALLOWS US TO HAVE SOME DIVERSITY
TO CONTINUE. CALIFORNIA JUST
READ AN ARTICLE YESTERDAY. THAT
IS, WE'RE SLIPPING TO THE SIXTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
APPARENTLY THE FOURTH TODAY, BUT
WE'RE LOSING GROUND HERE BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT, UM AS AS OUR GOALS
FOR CLIMATE HAVE PUSH US INTO A
SPOT WHERE WE CAN BE
COMPETITIVE. AND THAT THAT'S WE
HAVE EXEMPTED SOLAR FROM
PROPERTY TAX LOCALLY, WE HAVE
GIVEN TAX CREDITS TO WIN. AND
WHEN IT COMES TO HYDROGEN,
SOMEBODY IN THE TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY MYSELF. UM ELECTRICITY
JUST DOESN'T COMPETE WITH
DIESEL. BECAUSE IT'S NOT USABLE.
SO LET'S SO WE NEED HYDROGEN
WOULD WOULD MAKE IT COMPETE WITH
DIESEL. ON THE OTHER SIDE OF IT
IS THAT WE HAVE WE HAVE ALL
THESE COMMUNITIES. I'M GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY FOR A MOMENT IF YOU TOOK
EVERY PERSON AND EVERY CAR OUT
OF SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. YOU WILL
STILL HAVE POLLUTION THERE, AND
IT WON'T MEET THE STANDARD. WHY
IS THAT? IT'S BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTED FROM THE POLLUTING
AREAS WHICH ARE TO THE WEST OF
THEM. AND THE WINDS BLOW TOWARDS
THE EAST. AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE
THOSE FOLKS LIVE THERE AND THEY
HAVE THIS YEAR'S WHICH THE AIR
PULLS UP IN THE VALLEY THERE,
AND THEY THEY'RE STUCK THERE.
AND MY FRUSTRATION IS THAT THE
FOLKS THERE HAVE HAVE BIOMASS
THEY HAVE THEY HAVE DAIRIES.
THEY HAVE ALL KINDS OF THINGS
THAT THEY COULD ACTUALLY REDUCE
THE POLLUTION. BUT WE WANT TO BE
100% WE CAN'T GET WE CAN'T GET
95. WE HAVE TO GET 100. SO THIS
BILL, WHICH IS A VERY HEAVY
LIFT, BILL, I AGREE. I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF NUANCES HERE,
BUT WE TALKED ABOUT BRINGING IN
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO OUR STATE IF
WE'RE GOING TO LEAD WE HAVE TO
TAKE SOME RISK AND WE HAVE TO DO
AND WE HAVE TO DO WE WANT TO
MANAGE THOSE RISKS, OBVIOUSLY,
AND I THINK THIS BILL STRIKES IS
TRYING TO STRIKE THAT ABILITY TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT. SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT LOOK AT SOME
POINT WE CAN'T JUST HAVE SOLAR
AND WIND. IT'S NOT. IT'S NOT
GOING TO DO THE JOB. WE HAVE TO
HAVE SOMETHING THAT IS USABLE BY
INDUSTRY THAT WILL WILL HELP
FLATTEN OUT THAT DUCK CURVE AND
DRIVE DOWN THE RATES OF
ELECTRICITY. AT THE SAME TIME
SAVING THE ENVIRONMENT. AND I
BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL HELP
THAT. I'M NOT GOING TO SAY IT'S
A IT ISN'T THE SILVER BULLET,
BUT IT'S PART OF THE SOLUTION.
WE CAN'T JUST CONTINUE TO PUT
ALL OF OUR EGGS IN TWO BASKETS,
WIND AND SOLAR AND I JUST WANT
TO END WITH THIS. THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM THAT REPRESENTS THE
IMPERIAL VALLEY. WE'RE DOING ALL
KINDS OF EXEMPTIONS TO GO OUT
THERE. LITHIUM. BECAUSE LABOR
LOVES IT. AND IT CREATES
BATTERIES. WHICH WE NEED TO
OFFSET SO WE CAN STORE SOME OF
THIS ENERGY. THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE APPROACH. I BELIEVE THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING. I WOULD JUST ASK FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO GET THIS BILL OUT.
LET'S WORK ON IT. IT DOES. IT
NEEDS SOME WORK YET. I DON'T
WANT TO SEE IT DIE HERE TODAY, I
WILL HAVE TO GO TO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE BECAUSE ONLY TWO BILLS
LEFT AND NEEDED MY VOTE OVER
THERE. BUT I WILL MOVE THIS BILL
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. AND I
WOULD JUST ASK TWO SENATORS TO
GIVE IT A CHANCE BECAUSE WE
REALLY DO NEED THIS AS A BUCKET
ANOTHER BUCKET IN THE SOLUTION
TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND TO DRIVE
DOWN THE COST AND TO DO THE
RIGHT THING FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
IS IT PERFECT? NO, BUT NONE OF
THEM ARE AND ALL OF THEM HAVE
THEIR ABILITY TO GET TAX CREDITS
INTO IN THE LOBBY IS PLAYING IN
THAT, BUT THIS THIS BILL REALLY
NEEDS TO MOVE FORWARD. I THINK
IT'S UH WOULD HELP CALIFORNIA
SOLVE SOME OF OUR PROBLEMS. IS
IT TOUGH? YES, BUT I THINK WE
SHOULD MOVE IT FORWARD AND I'LL
BE HAPPY TO DO THAT. WHEN THE
TIME COMES, I WILL BE BACK. MR
CHAIRMAN IN A MOMENT, OKAY.
CENTER SKINNER. THANK YOU. UH
APOLOGIES. I DID NOT. I WASN'T
ABLE TO HEAR ALL OF THE DEBATE,
BUT I WANTED TO FIRST START UP
THAT I THOUGHT THE BILL ANALYSIS
IS VERY EXCELLENT, REALLY GOES
INTO GREAT DETAIL OVER MANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT NOT ONLY
CONCERNED THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
REALLY I MEAN IT REFERENCES THE
SCOPING PLAN, FOR EXAMPLE, AND
THE ESTIMATIONS OF WHAT THE
SCOPING PLAN THE 1700 TIMES.
INCREASE IN HYDROGEN DISCUSSING
PLAN IS EXPECTING AND THEN
LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
DO WE FEEL THAT WE'RE GONNA GET
THERE, SO I JUST WANTED TO GIVE
KUDOS TO COMMITTEE STAFF BECAUSE
I THINK THIS ANALYSIS IS RARE.
VERY, VERY GOOD. IT'S ONE OF THE
BETTER. DETAILED FOR THOSE OF US
WHO ARE TRYING TO REALLY GET IN
THE WEEDS ON THESE ISSUES OF THE
CARBON IZING AND HOW HYDROGEN
FIX FITS INTO THAT
DECARBONIZATION. I THINK IT'S A
REALLY, REALLY GOOD ANALYSIS.
NOW. THE AND SO I HAPPEN TO BE
SOMEONE WHO WHILE I DO NOT THINK
HYDROGEN IS THE END ALL BE ALL
FOR OUR DECARBONIZATION OR THE
ONLY PANACEA I ABSOLUTELY
THERE'S A ROLE FOR IT, AND I
HAVE BEEN DOING A VARIETY OF
BILLS IN THE SPACE TO CREATE
THAT PATHWAY. UM AH, AND MY
ISSUE, I THINK, UH, SENATOR
MENJIVAR MADE THIS POINT THAT
THIS BILL IS SORT OF THREE BILLS
IN ONE I DON'T. I'M NOT GOING TO
OPPOSE IT. FOR THAT REASON I'M
NOT OPPOSING IT AT ALL. BUT I'M
MORE I PROBABLY WOULD HAVE LIKED
IT TO BE PARSED OUT A LITTLE
MORE. HOWEVER I THINK THE POINT
THAT MEANING NOT ALL THREE OF
THESE THINGS IN ONE BILL,
HOWEVER, I FEEL LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE. BECAUSE
OF FEDERAL ACTION AND THE
FEDERAL FUNDING. IT MAY BE THE
PATH WE NEED. WE HAVE TO TAKE
NOW, SO IT'S PERHAPS PUSHING US
A LITTLE FASTER THAN WE'D WANT
TO BE. WE MIGHT WANT TO BE MORE
METHODICAL AND THIS IS WHY I
LIKE IF I UNDERSTAND THIS
CORRECTLY AND AGAIN, I WAS NOT
IN THE ROOM. BUT I UNDERSTAND
BECAUSE MY STAFF WAS FILLING ME
IN WHILE I WAS TAKING CARE OF
THE OTHER JUNK I WAS HAVING TO
TAKE CARE OF THAT THE CHAIR HAS
ASKED FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE EXCUSE
ME ENSURING THAT THE HYDROGEN
AND ELIGIBILITY IN THE RPS WOULD
BE NOT FOSSIL FUEL THAT THERE
WOULD BE SOME MORE BELTS AND
SUSPENDERS ON THE BIOMASS AND ON
THE THIRD ONE WAS REMIND ME TO
DO SO. FOSSIL FUEL. UM BOTH THE
TOTAL THAT DERIVED BUT ALSO NOT
ADDING G H E S TO THE ELECTRICAL
SECTOR. BUT I THINK THERE WAS A
THIRD HOW EMISSIONS RESULTING
FROM HYDROGEN IS USE IN THE RPS
FACILITIES ENCOUNTER FORK ANYWAY
, SO I REALLY I LIKE THOSE
ADDITIONS, THOSE THREE BELTS AND
SUSPENDERS THAT THE CHAIR WOULD
LIKE YOUR AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU HAVE COMMITTED TO WORK ON
THOSE. WHICH I APPRECIATE. UM
NOW, ALL OF THAT SAID. THE
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS PEOPLE HAVE
RAISED DO NOT WANT TO MINIMIZE
THOSE, HOWEVER. WHAT I DID WANT
TO RAISE IS THAT IF WE THINK
ABOUT WHERE SOLAR TECHNOLOGIES
WERE 25 YEARS AGO. AND WHAT
THEIR COST WAS. WE COULD NEVER
HAVE IMAGINED THAT WE'D BE WHERE
WE ARE TODAY, OR THAT WE WOULD
THAT IT WOULD COST WOULD HAVE
COME DOWN TO THE LEVEL IT IS AND
THE ABUNDANCE FOR WHICH WE WOULD
BE UTILIZING IT IF WE TAKE
BATTERY GRID LEVEL BATTERY
TECHNOLOGY, AND FOR EXAMPLE,
WHEN I DID THE BILL IN 2010, I
THINK I WAS FORTUNATE BECAUSE
ABLE TO GET THAT BILL THROUGH
BECAUSE NOBODY BELIEVED IT WOULD
HAPPEN. EVERYBODY THOUGHT IT WAS
JUST A PIPE DREAM OVER THERE,
TOO. LOVELY IDEA, SKINNER. SO
THEY KIND OF WENT WITH IT, EVEN
THOUGH THEY WOULD OTHERWISE
TOTALLY OPPOSED. EXT ANYTHING.
WHATEVER HAPPENED. WE'RE NOW WE
HAVE INSTALLED BATTERY CAPACITY
IN CALIFORNIA, EQUIVALENT TO
FOUR TIMES THE GENERATION OF
FOUR DIABLO POWER PLANTS. AND AT
A MUCH MORE REASONABLE COSTS AND
WE WOULD HAVE EVER EXPECTED SO
WHY I'M SAYING THAT IS BECAUSE I
FEEL LIKE WE NEED IN DUE
MEASURES LIKE THIS TO SEND THE
RIGHT MARKET SIGNALS. IT IS
ABSOLUTELY THE CASE THAT
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN IS STILL
TOO EXPENSIVE, AND IT IS STILL
TOO ENERGY INTENSIVE. BUT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGES COULD
HAPPEN. AND WHILE I AM NOT
SOMEONE WHO IS GOING TO
COMPLETELY THROW MY, YOU KNOW,
SAY ORGANISM SOLVE EVERYTHING
AROUND THE CLIMATE CRISIS
BECAUSE TECHNOLOGY ADVICE
ADVANCE. NO BUT WE HAVE SEEN
SOME AMAZING TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES IN A VARIETY OF THESE
AREAS. AND SO BY SENDING THE
RIGHT MARKET SIGNALS. I HOPE
THAT WE WOULD CONTINUE TO AND
THEN WHAT'S WHAT THAT DOES IS IF
WE ADOPT POLICIES LIKE THIS, AND
IF, OVER TIME THOSE ADVANCES
DON'T RESULT IN EITHER. REDUCED
GHG. PRODUCTION OF THESE THINGS,
OR IT CAUSES HIGHER COSTS THAN
WE HAVE TO, AND I WON'T BE HERE,
BUT WE HAVE TO BE THE ONES TO
PULL BACK, AND I THINK THE
LEGITIMATE FEAR BY MANY OF US
AND BY MANY ADVOCATES IS THAT IF
WE GO TOO FAST NOW, BEFORE WE
KNOW THAT THESE THINGS ARE
SECURED, THAT WILL NEVER PULL
BACK. AND THAT'S OKAY. THAT'S
LEGIT, BECAUSE OFTENTIMES WE
DON'T PULL BACK. HOWEVER I THINK
WE'RE AT THE CUSP IN THIS
CLIMATE CRISIS AND WITH THE
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES THAT WE
SHOULD NOT USE THAT AS THE THING
TO STOP US AT THE MOMENT, BUT WE
DO HAVE TO BE WILLING. WE HAVE
TO BE THE RIGHT KIND OF WATCH
DOGS TO PULL BACK. IF SOME OF
THE ISSUES, FOR EXAMPLE THAT ARE
LAID OUT IN THE ANALYSIS WERE TO
BUT, YOU KNOW, MATERIALIZE MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY. SO I APOLOGIZE
FOR SAYING ALL THAT, BUT I HAVE
BEEN, UH, PLAYING IN THIS FIELD
FOR A WHILE. SO I AM SUPPORTING
THE BILL. I AM VERY APPRECIATIVE
THAT THE AUTHOR IS TAKEN. THE
NOT ONLY THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE OUTLINED IN THE, UH,
ANALYSIS BUT ALSO THE ADDITIONAL
COMMITMENTS. THE CHAIRS ASKED,
AND I APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR MITCH FOR THANK YOU, UM,
A COUPLE OF THOUGHTS FIRST. I
THINK I'M OF THE OPPOSITE
MENTALITY WHERE I THINK WE'VE
DONE A COUPLE OF THINGS REALLY
FAST. AND NOW WE'RE TRYING TO
CATCH UP A COUPLE OF THINGS.
I'VE MENTIONED THIS COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE ALL THESE DEADLINES. 23
2030 2035 THAT WE'RE NOWHERE
NEAR TO REACHING BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T THINK ABOUT THE FINE
PRINT OR THE IMPLEMENTATION TO
GET TO THESE POINTS. MR CHAIR
LAST YEAR, YOU HAD A BILL
RELATED TO BIOGAS AT DAIRY
FARMS, BECAUSE WHAT WE INTENDED
TO DO WAS HAVING AN OPPOSITE
EFFECT WHERE THEY'RE CREATING
MORE. JUST TO BE ABLE TO CAPTURE
WHERE THESE THINGS ARE COMING
UP. YEARS AFTER WE PUSH POLICY
THAT WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, I
THINK NEEDS MORE TIME TO REALLY
WEED OUT. UM, YOU KNOW, SENATOR
SKINNER YOU HAD TO BUILD TWO
YEARS AGO FOR A REPORT THAT IS
COMING OUT IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR
ON HYDROGEN ON DEVELOPMENT. THE
DISTRIBUTION DEPLOYMENT OF THAT.
WHY ARE WE AHEAD OF THE GAME AND
I WENT INTO THAT REPORT COMES
OUT TO REALLY SHARE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEN PUSH
POLICY FROM THAT. SENATOR I'M
I'M ALSO DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS BILL,
AND I WANT TO DO THE OPPOSITE.
WHERE WHEN I SEE LANGUAGE
FURTHER LANGUAGE. I RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO CHANGE IT BECAUSE I DO
WORRY THAT UM AND I AND I AGREE
WITH YOU. THIS IS JUST
TRANSITION. 100% I'D LIKE THAT
PHRASE. WE NEED TO HAVE JUST
TRANSITION. HYDROGEN IS GOING TO
PLAY A ROLE. I THINK WE NEED WE
NEED TO LOOK AT EVERYTHING. BUT
WHEN IT COMES TO THE SPACE, I AM
I'VE BEEN VERY CRITICAL OF OUR
APPROACH AND HOW TO ADDRESS IT.
WE'RE JUMPING THE GUN, AND THEN
LATER ON IN YEARS FOR RING OUT
HOW TO PUT IT ALL TOGETHER, SO I
WANT TO BE MORE MINDFUL IN THIS
SO I WILL BE STAYING OFF THIS
BILL BUT WILL BE RESERVING THE
RIGHT TO COME BACK AND SUPPORT
ON THE FLOOR. ONCE I SEE IT MORE
UM, FLUSHED OUT, OKAY? OKAY? UM
YEAH. APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS
VERY MUCH TO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE. WHY DON'T
WE GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE THANK YOU, MR CHAIR, AND I
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY THAT'S
SPOKEN AND EXPRESSED CONCERNS.
UM PART OF THE CHALLENGE, SO LET
ME JUST SAY THAT I WANT TO AGREE
WITH SENATOR SKINNER THAT THE
REPORT IS REALLY WELL DONE. IT
HAS EVERYTHING BUT THE KITCHEN
SINK, AND THERE'S A LOT TO
DEBATE. ON WHICH MEANS THE BILL
HAS A LOT OF PIECES, RIGHT? A
LOT OF MOVING PIECES. UM I MAKE
THE COMMITMENT AGAIN TO WORK
WITH THE STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE
AND THE CHAIR TO GET THIS RIGHT
AND TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT HAS
PEOPLE FEEL COMFORTABLE AS
UNCOMFORTABLY COMFORTABLE AS WE
CAN GET THEM BECAUSE THIS IS
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT. AND TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION THAT THAT
YOU RAISE SENATOR THE REASON
WE'RE HERE AND WE'RE DOING THIS
NOW IS IT IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACCESS FEDERAL FUNDING AND TO DO
IT IN A WAY THAT CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND TO DO THAT JUST
TRANSITION AND TO ALSO CREATE
ENERGY THAT WOULD BE IS GOING TO
BE REALLY IMPORTANT FOR OUR
GRID, BUT TO DO IT IN A WAY THAT
SOCIALLY RESPONSIBLE, SO I DO. I
DO AGREE THAT THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. SO WITH THAT,
UM MR CHAIR, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
TODAY. OKAY I'M WITH THAT
UNDERSTANDING. CERTAINLY ONE OF
SUPPORT TODAY AND I WANT TO
REITERATE THANK THE MEMBERS FOR
THEIR RECOGNITION OF OUR STAFF
WORK. I THINK ERIC'S LONGEST.
ANALYSIS AND, YOU KNOW, JUST
ABSOLUTELY LAST NIGHT WE WERE.
WE WERE STILL, UM YOU KNOW,
DEALING WITH SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT YOU KNOW. QUITE FRANKLY,
LOOK, I MEAN, I THINK YOU'VE
HEARD ME TO THE VERY SERIOUS
CONCERN. UH, FROM THIS
COMMITTEE. AND ANYHOW, LOOKING
FORWARD TO A LOT MORE WORK GOING
FORWARD. I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
VOTE FOR IT. TODAY. IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR DOLLY
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS ALAN ALAN, I DALI DALI.
I GONZALES HER TAITO. MENJIVAR
WHEN SKINNER. OH, MY SORRY. YOU
KNOW, LET ME GO BACK. SB 1420.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY, UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS. I'M GONNA GO
BACK AND DO THAT SENATORS ALLEN
AYE. ALAN I DALI DALI. I
GONZALES HER TAITO MENJIVAR.
WHEN SKINNER SKINNER. I OKAY.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
FOLKS THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT. OKAY LET'S NEXT
HEAR FROM SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
TO ANNOUNCE ABOUT WIENER. OH AND
WHILE SHE'S COMING UP, I JUST
WANT TO ANNOUNCE THAT SENATOR
WIENERS. SB 1227 HAS BEEN PUT
OVER TO THE NEXT HEARING ON THE
17TH. SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR.
YOU'RE HERE TO PRESENT TWO
BILLS. SB 1066 SPECIAL DATE AND
BRITISH HISTORY. AND SP 1361 AS
WELL. SO LET'S START WITH 1066,
OKAY? WELL, THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. SB 1066 IS A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE TO ENSURE THE SAFE
DISPOSAL OF PYROTECHNIC MARINE
FLARES. DO I HAVE THE PERMISSION
OF THE CHAIR TO SHOW A
PHOTOGRAPH OF A OF A MARINE
FLARE? SURE YES, WITH PLEASURE.
SO THIS THIS IS WHAT THEY LOOK
LIKE IN A BOX DELIVERED TO A
FIRE DEPARTMENT THAT THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT THAT NEEDED TO DEAL
WITH THESE, SO THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY. THE U. S. COAST GUARD
REQUIRES VESSELS THAT ARE LONGER
THAN 16 FT AND ARE OPERATING ON
OCEANS TO CARRY APPROVED VISUAL
DISTRESS SIGNALS FOR USE IN
EMERGENCIES. MOST OFTEN VOTERS
CARRY THREE PYROTECHNIC FLARES
THAT ARE APPROVED FOR BOTH DAY
AND NIGHT. TIME USE. WHILE THERE
ARE SEVERAL BRANDS OF BATTERY
POWERED ALTERNATIVES, MANY
VOTERS PREFER FLARES DUE TO
THEIR INCREASED VISIBILITY
DURING THE DAY. THESE FLARES
EXPIRE 42 MONTHS AFTER THEIR
MANUFACTURED, MEANING THEY NO
LONGER SATISFY THE COAST GUARD
REQUIREMENTS UNUSED EXPIRED
MARINE FLARES CANNOT BE DISPOSED
OF IN THE REGULAR TRASH OR THE
RECYCLING. THEY ARE EXPLOSIVES,
AND THEY MUST BE TAKEN TO
FACILITY PERMITTED TO ACCEPT
EXPLOSIVES. FLARES ALSO CONTAIN
CHEMICALS THAT CAUSE POLLUTION
AND HARM HUMAN HEALTH. WHILE THE
EXACT NUMBER CAN BE DEBATED
CALIFORNIA'S DIVISION OF VOTING
AND WATERWAYS ESTIMATES THAT
174,000 FLARES EXPIRE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR.
CONSERVATIVELY THERE ARE AT
LEAST TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
FLARES AND NEED OF DISPOSAL EACH
YEAR, BUT NEARLY ALL HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES
REFUSED TO ACCEPT THEM. IN FACT,
ALAMEDA COUNTY IS THE ONLY
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA THAT WE
HAVE FOUND THAT ACTIVELY ACCEPTS
FLARES. BUT EVEN THEY LACK LACK
THE PERMITS NECESSARY TO DISPOSE
OF THEM. AS FAR AS WE KNOW THERE
IS ONLY ONE FACILITY IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY THAT CURRENTLY
ACCEPTS FLARES FOR DISPOSAL. AND
IT IS OVER 1500 MILES AWAY IN
MISSOURI WITHOUT VIABLE OPTION
VOTERS REPORT STORING THESE
FLARES ON THEIR BOAT, SHOOTING
THEM UP INTO THE AIR OR DUMPING
THEM INTO THE OCEAN. STOCKPILED
FLARES ARE A FIRE FIRE HAZARD,
SHOOTING A DISTRESS SIGNAL
OUTSIDE OF AN EMERGENCY IS A
FEDERAL FELONY. DUMPING UNUSED
FLARES INTO THE OCEAN OR
OTHERWISE CAN LEACH, TOXIC
METALS AND OTHER POLLUTANTS INTO
THE WATER. EXPIRED FLARES CAN
OFTEN END UP IN THE TRASH OR
LEFT IN FRONT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS LIKE THAT
PHOTO THAT I SHOWED YOU LIKE AT
POLICE STATIONS OR FIRE
STATIONS. THIS RESULTS IN HIGH
COSTS THAT ARE BORN BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, AS THEY THEN BECOME
RESPONSIBLE FOR ARRANGING FOR
PROPER DISPOSAL. THESE COSTS ARE
SOCIALIZED THEN ONTO LOCAL
TAXPAYERS INSTEAD OF THE VOTERS
WHO USE THEM. WE ARE ACTIVELY
COLLABORATING WITH ORION SIGNALS
. THE PRIMARY PRODUCER OF MARINE
FLARES AND THE RECREATIONAL
BOATERS ASSOCIATION TO ENSURE
THE COSTS ARE NOT SO HIGH THAT
VOTERS STOPPED CARRYING THESE
EMERGENCY SAFETY DEVICES. SB
1066 WILL PUT THE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR FUNDING AND OPERATING A
CONVENIENT TAKE. BACK SYSTEM
ONTO THE PRODUCERS WITH
OVERSIGHT, BUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL SP 1066
IS SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF STAKEHOLDERS,
INCLUDING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
PARK DISTRICTS. TEAMSTERS
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND INDIVIDUAL FIRE
DISTRICTS, WASTE HAULERS, HARBOR
DISTRICTS AND ENVIRONMENTAL AND
PUBLIC HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS WITH
ME TODAY, I HAVE LESLIE LUCAS ON
BEHALF OF THE ZERO WASTE SONOMA
ORGANIZATION. THEY ARE CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL, AS WELL AS
JUST IN MILAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS WHO ALSO HAPPENS
TO BE AN AVID BOATER. SO IF
THERE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THESE
FLARES, SPECIFICALLY, HE CAN
ANSWER THEM. AH SO WITH THAT, IF
YOU IF YOU DON'T MIND SHARING, I
WILL TURN IT OVER TO MY LEAD
WITNESSES. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR BLAKE SPHERE CHAIR AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE OF
ROME INEQUALITY COMMITTEE, AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY. MY NAME IS LESLIE
LUKASH. I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ZERO WASTE SONOMA, A
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY THAT
COVERS THE UNINCORPORATED AREA
OF NINE CITIES AND THE TOWN OF
CINEMA COUNTY AND SERVES
APPROXIMATELY 500,000 RESIDENTS.
ZERO A SNOWMAN'S PROUD SPONSOR
OF SB 1066, WHICH SOLVES A
SERIOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT PROBLEM
PLAGUING CALIFORNIA'S CLOSE LINE
COMMUNITIES LIKE CINEMA COUNTY,
WHICH HAS OVER 76 MILES OF
COASTLINE. CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR PLANNING.
THE MANAGEMENT OF HOUSEHOLD HAS
THIS WASTE OTHERWISE KNOWN AS H
H W AND OUR MANAGEMENT PLANS ARE
APPROVED BY CALVIN CYCLE. OR
AGENCY OPERATES AT H W FACILITY
IN CINEMA COUNTY, AND WE'RE
BUILDING A SECOND FACILITY AT
THE ESTIMATED COST OF $14
MILLION TO OUR RATEPAYERS TO
BUILD A FACILITY TO BUILD THIS
FACILITY, AND THAT DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE MANAGEMENT OF
EXPLOSIVES LIKE MARINE FLARES.
THE COST OPERATOR H W FACILITY
IS EXPENSIVE AND REQUIRE HIGHLY
TRAINED STAFF TO IMAGINE MANAGE
TOXIC MATERIALS. IN FACT, R H W
FACILITY COSTS AROUND $2 MILLION
A YEAR TO OPERATE. MOST H A W
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE
CANNOT AFFORD THE LABOR,
TRANSPORTATION AND PURCHASE OF
EXPLOSIVE STORAGE CONTAINERS,
CALLED MAGAZINES NEEDED TO
SAFELY ACCEPT AND MANAGE
EXPLOSIVE PRODUCTS. OUR FACILITY
, H W FACILITY IS NOT PERMITTED
TO ACCEPT MARINE FLARES, AND WE
DO NOT ACCEPT THEM FROM THE
PUBLIC, BUT RESIDENTS OFTEN
LEAVE THEM AT OUR FACILITY
WITHOUT OUR PERMISSION BECAUSE
THEY HAVE NO NO LOCAL ART OPTION
TO SAFELY DISPOSE OF THEM.
SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR SHOWED YOU
THIS PICTURE. THIS IS ACTUALLY
LEFT AT A FIRE DEPARTMENT IN THE
TOWN I LIVE IN AND WINDSOR JUST
LAST MONTH, AND THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH THIS PRODUCT, SO
IT'S STILL AT OUR AT OUR LOCAL
FIRE DEPARTMENT RIGHT NOW.
COUNTY BOATERS SENT ME AN EMAIL
AND STATED THERE IS LITERALLY
NOWHERE TO DISPOSE OF EXPIRED
MARINE FLARES IN OUR COUNTY, AND
HE GOES ON TO STATE THAT MANY
BOATERS HAVE TOLD ME THAT THEY
SOAK MARINE FLARES AND BUCKETS
AND WAIT FOR THE FLARES TO
DISINTEGRATE AND THEN SPREAD THE
REMNANTS EITHER ON THE GARBAGE
OR DOWN THE DRAIN IN THE
WATERWAYS BECAUSE THEY REALLY
DON'T KNOW WHERE TO PUT THE
MATERIALS. BUT WHAT HAPPENS TO
THOSE CHEMICALS THAT ARE IN THE
WATER IN THE BUCKET? WE KNOW
THAT THE FLARES CONTAIN HARMFUL
CHEMICALS AND METALS THAT CAN
NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR WATER
QUALITY. FURTHERMORE IMPROPER
FLARE DISPOSAL AND TRASH AND
RECYCLING CAN EXPOSE HAZARDS TO
OUR WORKERS WHO WORK IN THE
RECYCLING FACILITIES AND IN THE
LANDFILL. THAT IS WHY WE HAVE
SUPPORT FROM THE WASTE
MANAGEMENT AND HAULING INDUSTRY.
THE MAJORITY OF VOTERS LITERALLY
HAVE NO OPTION TO PROPERLY
DISPOSE OF FLARES OR CONFUSED ON
WHAT TO DO WITH THEM. YESTERDAY
I WENT TO A LOCAL MARINE STORE
HERE IN SONOMA COUNTY IN
SACRAMENTO TO PURCHASE A SIGNAL
SO YOU CAN SEE WHAT A REASONABLE
ONE LOOKS LIKE ALSO TO START
WRAPPING UP, SO I JUST WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE COST IS THE LAST
THING AND THAT IS WE ORGANIZED
AN EVENT IN PARTNERSHIP WITH TWO
OTHER COUNTIES, MARINE AND
CONTRA COSTA. IT COSTS US
$11,000 TO MANAGE TWO BUCKETS OF
MARINES. THERE'S THAT WAS THE
COST OF ROUGHLY $185 PER FLAIR.
WHEN THE PRODUCT IS ONLY $12 TO
BUY. AND THERE ARE MORE COST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO DO THIS.
ALAMEDA COUNTY DOES HAVE THE
MAGAZINE TO PROPERLY STORE THEM
AND WHEN THEY WORK WITH THE
ECONOMIES OF SCALE IT COSTS
ABOUT $16 TO MANAGE THE FLARES.
SO WITH THAT, IF WITH THE PROPER
PARTNERSHIP AND WORKING TOGETHER
WITH THE MANUFACTURERS, WE LOOK
TO FIND A MORE COST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO MANAGE FLARES. AND SO
WITH THAT, I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY. OKAY THANK YOU, MR CHAIR
MEMBERS. THANK YOU, SENATOR JUST
IN MILAN WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH ASSOCIATION, AND WE
PROVIDE THE OVERSIGHT FOR BOTH
THE COOPERS THE HAZMAT FOLKS AND
THE SOLID WAYS PEOPLE SO WE WHEN
WE HAVE THIS ISSUE IN BOTH CAMPS
, SOME SOMETIMES THESE FLARES
END UP IN SOLID WASTE
FACILITIES, SOMETIMES A
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES. BUT
ALSO WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT MY
EXPERIENCES. ABODE. I'VE CROSSED
TWO OCEANS, THE PACIFIC A COUPLE
OF TIMES AND THE ATLANTIC AND I
WOULDN'T GO TO SEE THAT A MARINE
FLARE SO I WOULDN'T LIKE TO SEE
A BAN OF THE MARINE FLARE, BUT I
CAN ALSO TELL YOU MY EXTREME
FRUSTRATION OVER 40 YEARS IN
OTHER COUNTRIES AS WELL AS THIS
IN GETTING RID OF THESE THINGS
SAFELY AND I'M NOT PREPARED TO
JUST THROW IT IN THE WATER. I'M
NOT PREPARED TO FLARE IT OFF
WHEN I'M NOT SUPPOSED TO. I'M
NOT PREPARED TO DROP IT INTO A
SOLID WASTE FACILITY WHERE I
KNOW SOMEBODY CAN GET INJURED
AND HURT. AND I'M ALSO NOT GOING
TO TAKE IT HOME WHERE MY KIDS
AND MY FAMILY CAN BE INJURED
BECAUSE THESE THINGS BECOME
UNSTABLE, OFTEN NUMBER OF YEARS.
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVEN'T EXPIRY
DATE. SO THERE IS AN ISSUE. IT'S
AN ISSUE NOT ONLY IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S AN ISSUE AROUND THE NATION,
AND THE COST IS EXORBITANT. AND
THE SAFETY FOR EVERYBODY. THE
BOAT OPERATOR, THE HANDLERS IS
SIGNIFICANT AND THE COOPERS HAVE
FOUND ON MANY OCCASIONS THAT
PEOPLE CAN BE IN VIOLATION OF
TAKING THESE THINGS IF THEY
DON'T HAVE THE PROPER PROTOCOLS
IN PLACE IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE
PROPER HANDLERS, SO IT IS
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATING FOR VOTERS
TO FIND A PLACE TO PROPERLY
MANAGE THESE FLARES. AT THE END
OF THEIR USABLE LIFE. THERE IS
AN EXPIRY DATE ON THAT, AND YOU
CAN GET BUSTED BY THE COAST
GUARD FOR HAVING A FLARES THAT
EXPIRED. SO YOU HAVE TO TURN
THESE FLARES OVER. AND I HAVE ON
MY OWN BOAT. I MUST ADMIT I HAVE
GOT 12 FLARES THAT ARE STILL
HAVEN'T GOT A HOME FOR SO I JUST
KEEPING THEM ON MY BOAT. BUT
THESE ARE PYROTECHNIC THINGS. SO
IF THERE'S AN INCIDENT ON MY
BOAT, IT CAN GO UP. AND I'M
VERY, VERY NERVOUS ABOUT THAT.
JUST DISTRESS. THE REASON WHY
THE HAZMAT FOLKS WHILE THE
COOPERS AND THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH ARE SO
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS IS WE JUST
HEAR FROM THE PEOPLE THAT
OPERATING THESE HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES,
EITHER THEY CANNOT DO IT LEGALLY
OR FINANCIALLY OR PRACTICALLY,
OR THE GENERAL PERSON THAT HAS A
BOAT FROM ANY SIZE 15 FT TO 500.
FT I'VE JUST SEEN A POLL HERE
OVER 50% OF PEOPLE ARE DISPOSING
OF THESE THINGS ILLEGALLY BY
JUST HOLDING ON TO THEM. THEY'RE
REALLY EXPIRED. THEY SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PROPERLY DEALT WITH. SO IT
IS A CONCERN. IT'S A CONCERN FOR
THE REGULATORS, YOU KNOW THAT
THE FIREFIGHTERS ARE IN SUPPORT.
IT'S A CONCERN FOR THE
FIREFIGHTERS TO GO INTO A
FACILITY. AND YOU MIGHT HEAR
ABOUT THE COST AND YOU MIGHT
HEAR ABOUT AN INCONVENIENT AND
HAVE AN EPO PROGRAM. YOU CAN
HAVE AN NPR PROGRAM BECAUSE I
HAVE TAKEN USED OIL BACK TO THE
MARINAS AND THE PORTS AND THEY
HAVE A PROCESS OF DEALING WITH
IT, SO THEY ARE USUALLY SECURE
FACILITIES WITHIN EACH MARINA,
EACH PORTS WHERE YOU COULD
INCORPORATE THIS COLLECTION AND
DO IT SAFELY SO WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. IT'S NOT
JUST A FLIPPANT ISSUE. IT'S A
SERIOUS ISSUE IN THE STATE AND
ELSEWHERE. THANK YOU TO THE
SENATE FOR BRINGING FROM HAPPY
TO ASK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM A
TECHNICAL AND A VOTING
PERSPECTIVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY, LET'S HEAR FROM
ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. GOOD
MORNING, MR CHAIR MEMBERS, LUIS
SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WASTE HAULERS,
COUNSEL AND SUPPORT THANK YOU,
JORDAN WELLS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL STORAGE OF ACTION
COUNCIL OR A CO SPONSOR, AND I'M
ALSO GOING TO LIFT THAT LIST OFF
A COUPLE OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE ASKED ME TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT, INCLUDING NAPA
RECYCLING AND WASTE SERVICES,
THE NORTH AMERICAN HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION
RESOURCE RECOVERY COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA, SONOMA COUNTY
REGIONAL PARKS DEPARTMENT.
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY.
SAN MATEO COUNTY HARBOR DISTRICT
, DELTA DIABLO SANITATION
DISTRICT, SAN FRANCISCO
BAYKEEPER HEAL THE BAY MONTEREY
REGIONAL WASTE MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT. SAVE OUR SHORES BOAT
SAFE NORTHWEST AND SERIOUS
SIGNAL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, ARIANA CREED ON
BEHALF OF CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS
AND SUPPORT. ALSO THOSE ARE IN
SUPPORT OUR CALIFORNIA NURSES
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL, HEALTH AND
JUSTICE, FACTS, GRANDPARENTS AND
ACTION MAMA'S NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE, INTERFAITH
COALITION FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND NCC, A THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. JUST ONE
ORGANIZATION, SARAH POLO ME WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THAT'S GOOD. MELISSA SPARKS
CRANES WITH THE LEGAL CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL
COUNTIES AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANDREA VENTURA WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION AND SUPPORT. MORNING,
MICHAEL CAPRIO WITH REPUBLIC
SERVICES HERE IN SUPPORT. ON
BEHALF OF WASTE MANAGEMENT AND
SUPPORT. ON BEHALF OF SALMON,
TAIL COUNTY AND SUPPORT. MORNING
NICK LAPTOPS WITH CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE AND SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, DAVID KRIEGER FOR WASTE
CONNECTIONS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING, ELIZABETH ESPINOSA ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTY OF
SANTA BARBARA. AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. CRYSTAL LIKE YOU'D ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING CLIENTS.
WESTERN PLASTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY STOP WASTE SOLID WASTE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTH AMERICA
LEGISLATIVE TASK FORCE ON
SUPPORT AND SUPPORTING CONCEPT.
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
, CURE ROSS ON BEHALF OF THE
TOWN OF TRUCKEE AND SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING, SAMANTHA SAMUELSON ON
BEHALF OF RETHINK WASTE AND
SUPPORT. I'M MAKING SOME WAY.
REPRESENTING SACRAMENTO. 315
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OKAY
OPPOSITION. YEAH. OKAY. ONCE YOU
COME, YOU COME UP HERE. YES.
GOOD MORNING, MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. GOOD MORNING, MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JIM LIGHTS
ON BEHALF OF ORION SAFETY
PRODUCTS, ONE OF THE PRIMARY
MANUFACTURERS OF MARINE SAFETY
FLARES WERE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
FOR A COUPLE OF REASONS. WE
WANTED TO NOTE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE IN PARTICULAR THAT
SOME OF THE CHEMICALS OF CONCERN
THAT POTASSIUM PER CHLORATE IS
NOT A COMPONENT OF MARINE FLARES
. IT HAS NEVER BEEN A COMPONENT
OF AERIAL FLARES AND WAS
ELIMINATED FROM HANDHELD FLARES
IN 2022 ALSO WANTED TO KNOW THAT
THE BUREAU OF ALCOHOL, TOBACCO
AND FIREARMS HAS CONSISTENTLY
DEEMED ORION FLARES TO BE EXEMPT
FROM THEIR EXPLOSIVE DEVICE
REGULATIONS. UM ANOTHER REASON
IS THAT NOT ALL FLARES ARE
CREATED EQUAL. HANDHELD FLARES
CAN BE SAFELY BURNED IN A SAFE
LOCATION, NOT AROUND WATER, NOT
AROUND OTHER COMBUSTIBLE DEBRIS,
MUCH LIKE A GROUND FLARE WOULD
BE BURNED. OUR TEST RESULTS SHOW
THAT THE ASH FROM THOSE BURN
FLARES DOES NOT CONTAIN ANY
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS. BUT THE
AERIAL FLARES IS WHERE WE THINK
THE DISCUSSION HERE REALLY
SHOULD BE HAD. THERE ARE FEWER
DISPOSAL OPTIONS FOR AERIAL
FLARES, AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE PROPONENTS IN
THE AUTHOR TO DISCUSS HOW THOSE
MIGHT BE MANAGED A LITTLE BIT
BETTER. SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR DID
MENTION ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE MOST CONCERNED ABOUT, AND
THAT IS THE COST OF FLARES
POTENTIALLY GOING UP. AS A
RESULT OF A PROGRAM LIKE THIS IN
DISCOURAGING VOTERS FROM HAVING
THE FLARES THAT ARE APPROVED FOR
DAY IN THE EVENING USE, WHEREAS
THE BEACONS ARE GOOD AT NIGHT,
BUT THEY'RE NOT APPROVED FOR
DAYTIME USE THE ELECTRONIC LIGHT
BEACONS ARE EXPERIENCES ALSO
THAT SOME OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
COLLECTION AND DISPOSAL PROGRAMS
ARE LOCALIZED. SOMETIMES, YOU
KNOW EVENTS THAT MAY TAKE PLACE.
IN A DAY OR OVER A WEEKEND. AND
WE WOULD LIKE TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE CAN BETTER OPERATE SOME OF
THOSE LOCALIZED PROGRAMS THAN A
BROADER STATE PROGRAM. AND SO
WITH THAT, WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
NO VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YES, SIR. REMEMBER JERRY
DESMOND? THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JERRY DESMOND WITH
RECREATIONAL BOATERS OF
CALIFORNIA ARE BOC, MAYBE JUST
START OFF OUR BèC HAS BEEN A
STATEWIDE ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
FOR THE STATE'S VOTERS SINCE
1968 AND WE BECOME ENGAGED IN A
VARIETY OF ISSUES AFFECTING
EVERYTHING FROM BONING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE ON THE WATERWAYS TO
THE USE OF OUR GAS TAX DOLLARS
TO RULES OF THE ROAD TO COPPER
BASED ANTI FOULING PAINTS AND
HAVE A TRADITION OF REPRESENTING
OVER A COUPLE 100,000.
INDIVIDUAL VOTERS BELONG TO
DIFFERENT BOATING AND SAILING
CLUBS. ORGANIZATIONS AND ARE
CONCERNED WITH THE LEGISLATION
AT THIS POINT IS REALLY THE
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE. OUR
ORGANIZATION AND ARE IN THE
STATES. VOTERS HAVE BEEN
FINANCING FOR YEARS, A VOLUNTARY
TURN IN PROGRAM FOR VESSEL
FLARES THROUGH THE BOATING,
CLEAN AND GREEN CAMPAIGN
FINANCED BY THE DIVISION OF
VOTING OR WATERWAYS, AS WELL AS
THE COASTAL COMMISSION AND HAVE
ENCOURAGED VOTERS TO TURN IN
THEIR FLARES. WHAT WE FIND IS
THE EXPERIENCE IS SIMILAR TO ONE
OF THE PROPONENTS THAT A VOTER
WILL KEEP THE FLARES ON THEIR
BOAT, EVEN IF THEY'RE EXPIRED AS
BACKUP. THERE'S ABOUT A THREE
YEAR LIVE DATE WHERE THEY WORK,
BUT THEY'LL JUST KEEP THEM ON
THEIR BOAT, JUST AS WAS
TESTIFIED TO EARLIER AND THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT DURING THE
DAY THESE FLARES THE
ALTERNATIVES TO THESE FIGHTERS
DON'T WORK DURING THE DAY. SO
WHAT WE'RE SENSITIVE TO AND
WE'RE ENGAGED WITH THE AUTHOR
AND THE PROPONENTS. AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS IS TO ENSURE THAT
AS WE ADDRESS THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND YOU KNOW THE HAZARDOUS AND
TOXIC MATERIALS AND THE
EXPLOSIVE NATURE OF THESE
DEVICES THAT WE RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY BENEFIT OF A BOATER
HAVING THIS ON THEIR BOAT WHEN
THEY'RE OUT ON THE WATERWAYS.
THIS BILL DOESN'T THREAD THAT
NEEDLE YET. WE'VE HEARD OF
DIFFERENT IDEAS FOR OUR PROGRAMS
. WE HAVE HEARD OF LOCAL PROGRAM
ALTERNATIVES. WE HEARD A
STATEWIDE WE HEARD COSTS BETWEEN
$15 A FLARE $158. THOSE AREN'T
IRONED OUT YET AND WITHOUT THEM
BEING IRONED OUT YET, AND WE'RE
ENGAGED TO WORK THOSE OUT. BUT
AT THE PRESIDENT WITHOUT KNOWING
THAT WE'RE NOT WILLING TO
SACRIFICE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY AT THIS, YOU KNOW, AS
IT'S CURRENTLY WORDED, NOW, ARE
WE COMMITTED TO TRY TO DEVELOP A
PROGRAM THAT WORKS THAT DOESN'T
END UP IN A BOAT OR HAVING TO
PAY $100 PER FLAIR TO DISPOSE OF
REFERRING MOST CERTAINLY, WE ARE
AND FOR THAT REASON WE
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT AND
LOOK FORWARD TO DEVELOPING THE
SOLUTIONS THAT WORK ON THE
WATERWAYS. OKAY ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. OKAY OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT
TO WEIGH IN OPPOSITION OR HIS
CONCERNS. IF WE EVEN GOT A
LETTER FROM REAL GREG, OKAY? WE
SENT A LETTER IN ON MONDAY LIGHT
LETTER, BUT A LETTER. OKAY,
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. YES MR CHAIR
MEMBERS FAIRNESS ITO ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL MARINE
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. OKAY
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
APPRECIATING AND I TOTALLY GET
LOT OF YOUR CLIENTS AND I'M
REALLY GLAD THAT ORION'S
RETAINED YOU MR LIGHT BECAUSE IT
WILL HELP WITH THE DISCUSSIONS.
THAT IS A RECENT THEY RECENTLY
BROUGHT YOU ON THIS ALL RIGHT?
YEAH. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO, UM UH
, HOW ARE THE CONVERSATIONS GOT?
I MEAN, THIS ISN'T HAVE YOU GUYS
BEEN ABLE TO SIT DOWN AND TALK
SHOP. WE HAVE, AND WE HAVE
ANOTHER CALL SCHEDULED THIS
FRIDAY. OKAY ALL RIGHT, BECAUSE
I KNOW I KNOW THAT I KNOW THAT
SOME OF THE FOLKS FROM THE
NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL HAVE BEEN REACHING OUT
TO RYAN FOR A LONG, LONG TIME.
AND I'M JUST GLAD NOW THAT WE'VE
GOT SOME PEOPLE THAT CAN TALK TO
AND ENGAGE WITH BECAUSE WE
REALLY ARE LOOKING FOR A WAY TO
MAKE THIS YOU KNOW, I THINK
EVERYONE HERE KNOWS WHAT A
BELIEVER I AM AN NPR AND YOU
KNOW, IT'S A IT'S SOMETHING THAT
IF WE'VE DONE RIGHT CAN BE DONE
COLLABORATIVELY AND THE
PRODUCERS ARE ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL PART OF THE
CONVERSATION. YOU KNOW, THEY
KNOW THEIR PRODUCTS BEST. THEY
KNOW THEIR MARKETS BEST, AND
THEY ALSO KNOW DEVELOPMENT AND
IN POTENTIAL AND INDUCE BEST,
AND IT'S MY OPEN OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHER STAFF
AND AUTHOR THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
SEEKING TO GET HERE. AND YOU
KNOW, HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS
WITH AN OPEN MIND FROM YOUR
CLIENTS. I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO
REACHING A AGREEABLE SOLUTION
HERE. IT'S GOING TO DO RIGHT BY
OUR ENVIRONMENT AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT COMPROMISING
SAFETY FOR VOTERS. SO I'M JUST
GLAD THAT I'M GLAD THAT YOU KNOW
YOU'RE ON THE JOB AND WILL BE
WORKING ON THIS. UM SO DO YOU
HAVE ANY KIND OF INITIAL
REACTIONS TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTARY MADE SENATOR OR I
MEAN, I CAN I CAN WRAP IT UP IN
MY CLOTHES. OK OK. YEAH THAT'S
QUESTIONS. YES SENATOR. I JUST
WANT TO SAY I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY. I
THINK THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO A PROBLEM. OBVIOUSLY
WE HAVE BUT AT THE SAME TIME
SOMEBODY WHO'S WORKED WITH THE
COOPERS SUPERVISOR AND YOU KNOW
WE HAD LEAD BASED PAINT ALL
KINDS OF STUFF COMING IN, AND WE
AND PEOPLE REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY DO TO DO WITH IT. AND
QUITE FRANKLY, A LOT OF IT GOES
DOWN THE DRAIN OR GETS TOSSED,
AND THAT'S THE WRONG THING. SO
OBVIOUSLY IN THIS CASE, WE DON'T
WANT THAT TO HAPPEN EITHER. BUT
AT THE SAME TIME WE WANT TO PUT
A PROGRAM TOGETHER, HOPEFULLY
WITH THE MANUFACTURERS THAT
THERE IS A IN MY MIND. I'M
THINKING LIKE YOU BASICALLY RENT
THE THING FOR AND THEN THEY CAN
TAKE IT BACK. YOU KNOW SOMETHING
LIKE THAT? I DON'T KNOW, BUT I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE BILL,
LIKE GET TOGETHER AND MAKE MAKE
MAKE ITSELF WITH THE VOTERS WILL
DO IT NUMBER ONE THAT THEY WANT.
THEY WON'T THROW THEM OVERBOARD
AND THAT THEY'LL USE THEM AND
IT'S REASONABLE. SO THAT'S WHAT
I'M LOOKING FOR. AND I THINK IT
SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE HEADED IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO GET THERE, SO
I'LL SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY AND
HOPEFULLY THEY CAN IRON ALL
THOSE THINGS OUT AND WE CAN
ALLEVIATE THIS PROBLEM. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LET'S LET YOU CLOSE. YES I
JUST I WANT TO SAY AGAIN. THANK
YOU TO THE SPONSORS WHO AND THE
LEAD WITNESSES WHO CAME TO SPEAK
AS WELL AS THOSE IN OPPOSITION
WHO ARE AT THE TABLE AND WE'RE
IN DIALOGUE WITH AND THEN ALSO
TO ALL THE MANY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT CAME FORWARD TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT. I THINK IT REALLY
SHOWS THAT WE DO HAVE A PROBLEM
HERE AND THE EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY APPROACH IS
DESIGNED TO HAVE THE PRODUCER AT
THE TABLE COMING UP WITH THE
SOLUTION, SO THE COST IS WHAT IT
IS. THE QUESTION IS WHO IS
BEARING? AND SO RIGHT NOW, IF
WE'RE PAYING IF SOMEONE PAYS $15
TO BIO FLAIR, AND IT COSTS $150
ON THE BACK END TO COLLECT IT.
MANAGE IT, SEND IT SOMEWHERE OR
IT JUST GOES UP IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND IT IT'S
ESSENTIALLY POLLUTION. TOXIC
POLLUTION POLLUTANT YOU KNOW WE
ARE. THAT'S NOT THE SOCIETY WE
WANT SO TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT ARE THE SOLUTIONS AND WE
WILL BE WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH ORION TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
CAN COLLECT THESE IN A WAY. THAT
IS ACTUALLY EFFECTIVE BECAUSE WE
NEED TO BE WHERE PEOPLE WITH
THEIR BOATS AND THEIR FLARES ARE
SO THAT WE CAN GET THEM BACK. I
MEAN, THE LAST THING WE WANT IS
TO HAVE A PROGRAM THAT NOBODY'S
PARTICIPATING IT SO YOU KNOW,
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A BILL LIKE
THIS THAT SENDS IT INTO THE
EXTENDED PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
REALM INSTEAD OF TRYING TO
FIGURE IT OUT OURSELVES.
LEGISLATIVELY WERE GETTING INTO
DIALOGUE WITH THEM, SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT. AND I
THINK THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
BILL AND I DRIVE OUT. YEAH YES.
ONE LAST COMMENT. IF YOU IF IT'S
$15 TO BUY THIS, AND IT'S $100
TO GET RID OF IT, THEY'LL JUST
SHOOT IT OFF SOMEWHERE AND IT
WON'T GO BACK. WE HAVE TO GET
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE PARODY
THERE SOMEWHERE, SO I KNOW YOU
KNOW THAT IT'S A GREAT EXAMPLE.
IT'S A GREAT EXAMPLE OF HOW A
COMPANY PROVIDES A SERVICE TO
PEOPLE. RIGHT MAKES A LOT OF
MONEY OFF. IT SENDS IT OUT INTO
THE MARKET. AND YET THEY HAVE NO
COST ASSOCIATED WITH THE END USE
OF THE PRODUCT AND ITS THEN BORN
BY THE ENVIRONMENT AND EVERYBODY
ELSE, AND THIS IS THIS IS A
CRYSTAL CLEAR EXAMPLE OF THE
NEED FOR ANY PR APPROACH BECAUSE
THERE'S SUCH AN EXTERNALITY COST
HERE WITH A PRODUCT LIKE THIS.
AND THEY HAVE, YOU KNOW THEY'RE
MAKING THE MONEY FROM CONSUMERS
AND THE ENVIRONMENT IS PAYING
THE COST, AND TAXPAYERS ARE
PAYING THE COSTS IN MANY
RESPECTS FOR THE GUARDS TO CLEAN
UP, AND SO THEY HAVE TO BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION. I JUST
APPRECIATE YOU FORCING THE ISSUE
AND JUST ASK, REGULATED TO HAVE
IT ON THE RIGHT. RIGHT AND SO WE
HAVE TO HAVE A PLAN FOR PROPER
DISPOSAL, LIKE WITH EVERYTHING.
ANYWAY THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET OUT HERE. CENTER.
MENJIVAR MOVES THE BILL. UH AND
LET'S CALL THE WRONG SB 1066
MOTION IS DO PASS AND WE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
SENATORS ALAN ALAN. I DALI DALI.
I GONZALES HER TATO MENJIVAR
MENJIVAR. I WIN. SKINNER. OKAY
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE IT AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE ADVOCATES
AS WELL. ENGAGEMENT LET'S HEAR
NEXT FROM YOUR NEXT BILL. CENTER
BLAKE SPIRIT HAS SP 1361. OKAY
UM, I KNOW WE'RE PROBABLY
RUNNING A BIT LATE HERE. SO
THESE ARE OUR BRIEF INTRODUCTORY
COMMENTS. SO THIS IS SP 1361. I
JUST WANT TO SAY AT THE OUTSET
THAT I APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE COMMITTEE AND AGREED TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THE CERTAIN
DEFINITIONS THAT WE'RE STILL
DISCUSSING. SO AS I KNOW, AND
MANY LEGISLATORS KNOW AND
TESTIFIED ABOUT ALMOST AD
NAUSEAM WERE IN A HOUSING CRISIS
OF UNPRECEDENTED SCALE AND DUE
TO INSUFFICIENT HOUSING
PRODUCTION FOR GENERATIONS.
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR STATE IS
GROWING MUCH FASTER THAN
EVERYWHERE ELSE IN THE COUNTRY
BETWEEN 2010 AND 2023.
HOMELESSNESS, INCREASED 47. THE
MAJORITY OF THESE CALIFORNIANS
ARE UNSHELTERED, SO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR ARE
TAKING ACTIONS TO INCREASE
HOUSING SUPPLY. BUT WHILE WE
WAIT FOR THESE INITIATIVES TO
TAKE FULL EFFECT, LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ACT EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
TO SET UP VARIOUS SHELTER
FACILITIES LIKE LOW BARRIER
NAVIGATION CENTERS AND SAFE
CAMPING AND SAFE CAR PARKING AND
SAFE STORAGE SITES. TO THIS END,
THE LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED BILLS
TO PROVIDE SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS OR
MAKE BY RIGHT THE ACTIONS OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT THEY MUST
TAKE TO ESTABLISH THESE
FACILITIES. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FACE ALREADY SIGNIFICANT
DISINCENTIVES TO EXPAND SHELTER
CAPACITIES BECAUSE FACILITIES
ARE ALWAYS REVENUE NEGATIVE, AND
THEY ARE LARGELY POLITICALLY
UNPOPULAR. SO THEY ARE NECESSARY
, BUT THEY ARE VERY DIFFICULT TO
ACCOMPLISH FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
. AND I SAY THIS HAVING COME
FROM BEING THE MAYOR OF A CITY
AND BEING IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FOR EIGHT YEARS, SO THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED BILLS
THAT PROVIDE SECRET EXEMPTIONS
FOR THE FACILITIES THEMSELVES.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IN 2019, THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SUPREME COURT
IN THE CASE UNION OF MEDICAL
MARIJUANA PATIENTS VERSUS CITY
OF SAN DIEGO THE COURT SAID IN
AN AMBIGUOUS STANDARD FOR
DETERMINING WHETHER ACTIONS THAT
HAVE AN INDIRECT ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT ARE SUBJECT TO SEEK. WHAT
REVIEW SO INTUITIVELY? THE
CONTRACT RELATED ACTIONS SHOULD
NOT REQUIRE SECRET REVIEW WHEN
THE ACTUAL LAND USE IS NOT
REQUIRING SECRET REVIEW BECAUSE
THEY CONTRACT RELATED ACTIONS DO
NOT INVOLVE CHANGES TO THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT. BUT THE AMBIGUOUS
STANDARD THAT WAS CREATED IN
THIS CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
DECISION INVOLVING THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO MAKES THIS UNCLEAR. SO
THE SPONSOR MY SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL, THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO, IS
LEADING AN AMBITIOUS CHARGED TO
SUBSTANTIALLY EXPAND HOMELESS
SERVING SHELTER FACILITIES. THEY
ARE REALLY FOCUSED ON THIS AND I
VERY MUCH WANT TO HELP THEM
ACHIEVE THEIR GOALS. THE CITY
FACES SIGNIFICANT OPPOSITION AND
THE RISK OF LITIGATION FROM
GROUPS THAT ARE OPPOSED TO
HOMELESS SERVING FACILITIES OF
ANY TYPE NEAR THEM. MY BILL.
THIS BILL SB 1361 WILL CLARIFY
THAT THESE CONTRACTS RELATED
ACTIONS ARE SECRET EXEMPT. THIS
WILL SIGNAL TO LOCALS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZES THE
CRITICAL NEED FOR EXPANDING
TEMPORARY SHELTER WITH ME TODAY
I AM HAPPY TO INTRODUCE MORE
ATOP SHE HAS A REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO. WOULD
THIS BE YOUR ONLY WITNESS? YES
GO AHEAD. YOU HAVE FOUR MINUTES.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WHO? I'M SURE ARE
LISTENING. I AM WIRETAP HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO,
SPONSOR OF SB 1361. 1ST REALLY
DO WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO YOUR STAFF WHO
SPENT MANY HOURS WORKING THROUGH
THE DETAILS ON THIS BILL, AND
WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE.
HOMELESSNESS IS ONE OF THE MOST
VEXING ISSUES THAT'S FACING
CITIES TODAY. CITY PROGRAMS LIKE
THOSE IN SAN DIEGO, HAVE
SHELTERED AND HAS TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
THROUGH SUSTAINED MULTIYEAR
INVESTMENTS WITH STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS LIKE HAP UM
, AND AS MENTIONED BEFORE, BUT I
THINK IT BEARS REPEATING THAT IN
RECENT YEARS, THE LEGISLATURE
HAS RECOGNIZED THE IMMEDIATE AND
SIGNIFICANT NEED TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS BY PASSING
LEGISLATION THAT EXEMPTS THE
LOCATING OF HOMELESS SHELTERS
FROM SEQUA. UNFORTUNATELY THE
SERVICE CONTRACTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE LOCAL EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THE HOMELESS CRISIS ARE
NOT EXPLICITLY AFFORDED THE SAME
SECRET EXEMPTION. GIVEN THE NEED
TO RAPIDLY ADDRESS CALIFORNIANS
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS, SB 1361
WOULD HELP GIVE LOCAL AGENCIES
ANOTHER TOOL TO EXPEDITE
ADMINISTRATION OF THESE CRITICAL
SERVICES. THIS BILL IS MODELED
AFTER A BILL APPROVED JUST LAST
YEAR S BEFORE 06, WHICH APPLIES
THE SAME LOGIC TO ACTIONS BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO QUOTE,
PROVIDE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE OR
INSURANCE FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
AND CONSTRUCTION OF RESIDENTIAL
HOUSING. SB 1361 PROVIDES
CERTAINTY FOR CITIES HOME,
PROVIDING HOMELESS ASSISTANCE BY
SIMPLY CLARIFYING THAT ACTIONS
TAKEN BY A LOCAL AGENCY TO
APPROVE A CONTRACT FOR PROVIDING
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS SHALL NOT BE
SUBJECT TO SEQUA ON BEHALF OF
MARY TODD GLORIA WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION TO THE SENATOR
FOR CARRYING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE AND ALSO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. OTHER FOLKS WHO WANT TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR ADAM WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. JOHN KENNEDY, RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. CAROLINE GRINDER ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGAL CALIFORNIA
CITIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
CHANDRA FINGER WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE AND SUPPORT
CATHERINE TRIALS WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHT, FOLKS, WHO
OPPOSITION CONCERNS RAISED,
OKAY. LET'S GO TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS, THOUGHTS,
COMMENTS. OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENTIMENTAL, BUT I DO WANT
TO. I JUST WANT TO PERSONALLY
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH OUR COMMITTEE, OBVIOUSLY,
UM YOU KNOW WE HAD SOME INITIAL
CONCERNS, BUT I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH US
ON THE AMENDMENTS AND DOING THEM
ADDRESS. SO WITH THAT, CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO SUPPORT. THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY CINNAMON JABBAR
AND LET'S LET YOU CLOSE. YES
THANK YOU. I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS IS A
LEGISLATIVE EFFORT THAT COMES AT
NO COST AND CUTS RED TAPE AND
PROVIDES CERTAINTY AS WE
STRUGGLE TO DO BETTER TO ADDRESS
OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS AND THIS
IS A REALLY GREAT EXAMPLE OF
MAKING IT SO THAT A CITY COULD
MOVE FASTER AND NOT BE SUBJECT
TO LITIGATION AND HAVE TO GO IN
FRONT OF A COURT AND ARGUE ABOUT
THE DEFINITION OF SOMETHING
WHICH CERTAINLY DELAYS. THINGS
AND ADD SUBSTANTIAL COSTS. SO I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION HERE AND WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S CALL THE ROLL. SP
1361. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING SENATORS
ALLEN I, DOLLY. GONZALES. HER
TATO. MENJIVAR. MENJIVAR I WIN.
SKINNER. THANK YOU. YES S
SPEECH. IT'S UNDERSTOOD THAT YOU
SIT DOWN, OKAY? LIKE YOU NEVER
KNOW. GOOD ONE. TRUST ME, HUH?
OK FILE ITEM THREE SP 1361. THE
MOTION IS DUE PAST AS AMENDED,
AND WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING THE CHAIRS VOTING NINE.
DALAI? AYE. OKAY 30, LET'S WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. LET'S NOW GO TO YOU,
SENATOR NEELA, WHO'S HERE TO
PRESENT TWO BILLS? SB 1259. WHEN
WE START WITH THAT, OKAY? THANK
YOU, UH, MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
UM THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INTRODUCE TWO USB 1259 WOULD
MAKE FOUR IMPORTANT CHANGES TO
IMPROVE THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT,
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS SEQUA. YOU
WILL REMEMBER THAT GOVERNOR
BROWN SAID THAT SEQUEL REFORM IS
THE LORD'S WORK. I'M A DISCIPLE.
FIRST IT WOULD LIMIT THE
TIMELINE FOR CHALLENGES AND
APPELLATE REVIEW TO 365 DAYS FOR
ALL MAJOR HOUSING, COMMERCIAL
AND PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS OVER
$25 MILLION THAT WILL ADDRESS
CRITICAL NEEDS SECOND. IT WILL
REQUIRE IDENTITY DISCLOSURE OF
INDIVIDUALS AND GROUPS THAT
CONTRIBUTE $10,000 OR MORE TO A
SEQUEL LAWSUIT IN ORDER TO
DISCLOSE THE ECONOMIC INTERESTS
OF THOSE SEEKING TO STOP OR SLOW
DOWN A PROJECT. THIRD IT WOULD
LIMIT THE ABILITY OF COURTS TO
STOP PROJECTS FROM PROCEEDING
ONCE THEY HAVE BEEN APPROVED,
EXCEPT IN CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE
THERE ARE CLEAR AND DIRECT
THREATS TO PUBLIC HEALTH, THE
ENVIRONMENT AND OTHER IMPORTANT
BENEFITS. THE FINAL PROVISIONS
WILL LIMIT SETTLEMENTS TO
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES RELATED TO
THE PROJECT, SUCH AS MITIGATION
MEASURES THAT MATERIALLY REDUCE
SIGNIFICANT PHYSICAL IMPACTS TO
THE ENVIRONMENT. MOMENT. AS THE
LAW CURRENTLY STANDS, SEQUA IS
USED AS A TOOL OF OBSTRUCTION TO
STOP PROJECTS OF ANY SIZE WHEN
SOMEONE JUST DOESN'T LIKE IT,
EVEN AND ESPECIALLY FOR NON
ENVIRONMENTAL REASONS. CHANGE IS
NEEDED IN ORDER FOR PROJECTS OF
ALL KINDS, ESPECIALLY HOUSING,
TO BE APPROVED TO ADDRESS
LONGSTANDING NEEDS INSTEAD OF
OCCASIONAL INDIVIDUAL EXCEPTIONS
BY LIMITING TIMELINES, THE
PROCESS WILL BE STREAMLINED.
GOOD PROJECTS WILL ACTUALLY BE
BUILT. SP 1259 HAS A HOLISTIC
APPROACH, WHICH IS A FEATURE,
NOT A FLAW, AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS MAY IN FOR, FOR EXAMPLE
, THE STREAMLINING PROVISION IS
FOR ALL MAJOR HOUSING,
COMMERCIAL AND PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS ABOVE 20 $25 MILLION.
THIS ISN'T DESIGNATED TO GIVE TO
BE A GIVE AWAY TO THE BIG GUYS.
BUT RATHER PROVIDING A GREATER
DEGREE OF CERTAINTY FOR THE
TIMELINE OF MAJOR PROJECTS THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY
. THESE PROJECTS MEAN JOBS,
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. LAST YEAR. THE
GOVERNOR ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
CURRENTLY CURRENT LAW IS FLAWED,
STATING IN A PRESS RELEASE, OUR
SECRET PROCESS IS CLEARLY BROKEN
WHEN A FEW WEALTHY BERKELEY
HOMEOWNERS CAN BLOCK DESPERATELY
NEEDED STUDENT HOUSING FOR YEARS
AND EVEN DECADES EMPHASIZE,
BLOCK IT FOR YEARS OR EVEN
DECADES, CALIFORNIA CANNOT
AFFORD TO BE HELD HOSTAGE BY
NIMBYS, WHO WEAPONIZED SEQUEL.
TO BLOCK STUDENT AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AGAIN, THE WORDS OF THE
GOVERNOR. THIS SELFISH MINDSET
IS DRIVING UP HOUSING PRICES AND
MAKING OUR STATE LESS
AFFORDABLE. ADDITIONALLY
INFRASTRUCTURE STREAMING
LEGISLATION FROM THE GOVERNOR
LAST YEAR ALSO PROVIDED NUMEROUS
STREAMLINING, BUT FOR SOME, BUT
YET AGAIN FELL SHORT OF A
HOLISTIC REFORM THAT SEQUA
NEEDS. 1259 PREVENTS THOSE WITH
ULTERIOR AND NON ENVIRONMENTAL
INTERESTS FROM HIDING BEHIND
SEQUA TO BLOCK PROJECTS WITH
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS. IT DOES SO
BY MIRRORING LANGUAGE THAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED BY THIS
COMMITTEE IN SENATOR GLACIERS SP
393. BUT EXPANDS IT TO ALL
PROJECTS. ALL TOO OFTEN. THOSE
ENFORCING SEQUA DO SO FOR NON
ENVIRONMENT REASONS RAGING FROM
LABOR UNION INTEREST,
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGES OR THOSE
SEEKING TO PREVENT DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES FROM COMING INTO
THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD BY REMOVING
ANONYMITY. FROM THOSE WHO FILE
NAMELESS LEE TRANSPARENCY WILL
BE ENSURED FOR ALL RIGHT NOW.
APPEALS OF PROJECTS PROJECT
APPROVALS ARE SURPRISINGLY EASY
AND AFFORDABLE, DEFILE,
ESPECIALLY SINCE IT CAN BE DONE
ANONYMOUSLY, ESSENTIALLY GIVING
EVERY NEIGHBOR OF VETO OVER A
NEW PROJECT. SEQUA IS KNOWN TO
BE CALIFORNIA'S MOST IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW. AND IT IS BUT
WHEN INDIVIDUALLY FAVORED
PROJECTS BY THE POWERS THAT BE
HAS, AS HAS TO BE DONE, IT IS
EXEMPTED FROM SEQUA, FOR EXAMPLE
, STADIUMS SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT PLANS AND
PROJECT ROOM KEY. ONE LOCAL
EXAMPLE, HERE IN SACRAMENTO OF
SEQUEL BEING ABUSED BY NON
ENVIRONMENTAL REASONS WAS THE
SUTTER MEDICAL CENTER, BUILT
ALONG HIGHWAY 80, THE CAPITAL
CITY FREEWAY IN MIDTOWN, BEING
DELAYED FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
DUE TO SECRET CASE FILES. OF
SECRET LAWSUIT PROCESSES FILED
BY S E I U MOTIVATED PRIMARILY
BY LABOR DISAGREEMENTS WITH THE
HOSPITAL. ONE STUDY DEMONSTRATES
THAT 64% OF THOSE FOLLOWING
FILING SEQUEL LAWSUITS ARE
INDIVIDUALS OR LOCAL
ASSOCIATIONS, THE VAST MAJORITY
OF WHICH HAVE NO PRIOR TRACK
RECORD OF ANY ENVIRONMENTAL
ADVOCACY AND SEQUEL LEGISLATION.
ABUSES PRIMARILY THE DOMAIN. OF
NIMBY OPPONENTS AND SPECIAL
INTERESTS SUCH AS COMPETITORS
AND LABOR UNIONS SEEKING NON
ENVIRONMENTAL OUTCOMES. SP 1259
WILL LIMIT SETTLEMENT MEASURES
TO INCLUDE ONLY THOSE THAT
ACTUALLY HELPED MITIGATE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS OR
IMPACTS THAT WILL HELP ADDRESS
SYSTEMIC SECRET ABUSE.
LITIGATION OR THE THREAT THEREOF
CREATES DELAYS AND UNCERTAINTY
LEADS TO INCREASED PROJECT
TIMELINES AND COSTS OR
ABANDONING THE PROJECT
ALTOGETHER. SOMETIMES IT'S JUST
A WEIGHT OUT HOPE THE OTHER SIDE
RUNS OUT OF MONEY STRATEGY
WITHOUT A LIMITS LIMITS ON THE
TIMELINES FOR THESE CHALLENGES
TO BE LITIGATED. THE CHALLENGE
WILL ESSENTIALLY RUNNING UNTIL
ONE PARTY RUNS OUT OF MONEY OR
GIVES UP. WITH THAT. I'D LIKE TO
INVITE JORDAN'S PANAMA CARBON
HALL WITH CALIFORNIA, MD. AND
JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA TO JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS JORDAN
BANANA, GOT A HARD LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIA AND BE
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
1259, CALIFORNIA ME THE
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION OF OVER
80,000 NEIGHBORS DEDICATED
MAKING CALIFORNIA EIGHT
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE WORK
AND RAISE A FAMILY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS IS LARGELY DUE TO
THE UNDER PRODUCTION OF HOUSING
IN MANY INSTANCES, THE ABUSE OF
SECRET LAWSUITS CONTRIBUTED
UNDER UNNECESSARY DELAYS IN
DEVELOPMENT, EXAGGERATING THE
PROBLEM ON THE CURRENT LAW,
SECRET LOSSES CAN BE FOUND
ANONYMOUSLY. PARTIES ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO DISCLOSE IDENTITIES,
FINANCIAL DONORS OR CONFLICTING
INTERESTS. IN SOME CASES,
PARTIES FILED LAWSUITS AGAINST
PROJECTS UNDER CEQA WITH THAT
REGARD TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL
EFFECTS. BUT ONLY TO START THE
PROJECTS WITHOUT TRANSPARENCY
AND SECRET LAWSUITS. CALIFORNIA
IS DESTINED FOR NEVER ENDING
LITIGATION INCREASED, CAUSING
ONGOING DELAYS AND WE DO NOT
MAKE MEANINGFUL REFORMS WITH
HIGH LITIGATION COSTS.
UNCERTAINTY COMES INCREASED
PROJECT CAUSED ARE EITHER PASS
ON TO THE FUTURE CONSUMER OF THE
OF THE DEVELOPMENT OR LEAD
DEVELOPERS TO ABANDON THE
PROJECT ALTOGETHER. AS WE TRY TO
FIT IN. I WILL INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY BY REQUIRING
PARTIES FILING SECRET LAWSUITS
TO IDENTIFY INDIVIDUALS OR
GROUPS PROVIDING $10,000 OR MORE
TO THE LAWSUIT. IN ADDITION,
THIS BILL WOULD LIMIT THE
ABILITY OF THE COURSES STOP
PROJECTS PROCEEDING ONCE THEY
HAVE BEEN APPROVED IN LIMIT
SENTIMENTS. ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES
RELATED TO THE PROJECTS. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WILL
IMPROVE SEQUEL AND PROVIDE
CRITICALLY NEEDED TRANSPARENCY
TO ADDRESS SEQUEL LITIGATION
ABUSES. REMOVING AND BARRIER TO
INCREASE CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
SUPPLY. IT'S FOR THIS REASON
CALIFORNIA AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR VITRO
59. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
. GOOD MORNING, JOHN KENNEDY
AGAIN WITH OUR CRC. I'LL TRY TO
BE BRIEF. WE REPRESENT 40 WORLD
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT INTEREST IN
SEQUEL PROJECT PROPONENTS WERE
LEAD AGENCIES WERE PETITIONERS
WERE DEFENDANTS WERE ON EVERY
SIDE OF SEQUA. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SEQUELS, INFORMATION
DISCLOSURE, ENVIRONMENTAL
MITIGATION REQUIREMENTS. THEY
DRIVE BETTER PROJECTS BETTER
OUTCOMES, AND WE WANT TO SUPPORT
THOSE AND CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THOSE OUTCOMES. BUT SEQUELS
EVOLVED OVER THE YEARS INTO A
LITIGATION TRAP THAT, AS THE
AUTHOR MENTIONED, SOMETIMES
EXPLOITED FOR ANTI COMPETITIVE
OR FINANCIAL GAIN OR TO DELAY A
PROJECT PAST THE POINT OF
ECONOMIC VIABILITY. SEQUENCE
EVER CHANGING AND COMPLEX MAKES
IT REALLY DIFFICULT FOR PROJECT
PROPONENTS AND LEAD AGENCIES TO
NAVIGATE THE SEQUEL PROCESS WITH
CERTAINTY AND NAVIGATE IT IN A
TIMELY MANNER. WE APPRECIATE
THAT SP 1259 TRIES TO TAKE A
DEEPER SYSTEMIC LOOK AT SOME OF
THE UNDERLYING POLICIES AND
PROBLEMS ASSOCIATED WITH SEQUEL,
LITIGATION, CHALLENGES AND
PRESERVES THOSE INFORMATION
DISCLOSURE AND MITIGATION
REQUIREMENTS GOING FORWARD. WE
OFTEN SEE A SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS
AND TO BE HONEST, WE OFTEN
SUPPORT AND SPONSOR OF MANY OF
THOSE SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS, BUT
THEIR BAND AIDS TO SOME OF THE
LARGER SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS THAT
EXIST OUT THERE. WE NEED SOME
REAL CAREFUL SCRUTINY AND
EVALUATION OF STRUCTURAL CHANGES
, AS WELL AS THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED. 1259 IS A FOUR PART
BILL SEEKING TO PROMOTE
TRANSPARENCY, PREDICTABILITY AND
SIMPLIFICATION OF THE SECRET
PROCESS. WITH RESPECT TO THE
EXPEDITED LITIGATION REVIEW OF
MAJOR PROJECTS. SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS CAN BE REALLY
TRANSFORMATIVE. I THINK, MY, UM
UH, REALLY INCREDIBLY OPTIMISTIC
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS IS LOOK, WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S 365 DAY
PROCESS IS BETTER THAN A 3 TO 4
YEAR PROCESS THAT WE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCE AND IF FEASIBLE,
RIGHT, BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
WE'RE HOPING THAT HAVING A
COMPRESSED PROCESS WILL DRIVE
THE COURTS TO DEVELOP CLEAR
SOLUTIONS MAKE SECRET EASIER TO
NAVIGATE EASIER TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE EASIER EXPECTATIONS SO
IT TAKES COURTS LESS TIME TO
REVIEW THESE CHALLENGES BECAUSE
THEY'RE LESS COMPLEX. WE THINK
JUDICIAL REVIEW OF SEQUENCE
SETTLEMENTS AND NON
ENVIRONMENTAL SETTLEMENT
PROVISIONS WILL PROVIDE A LOT OF
TRANSPARENCY. SUNSHINE'S ARE
REALLY GREAT DISINFECTANT. NOT
EVERYONE HAS VARIOUS MOTIVATIONS
. SOME DO. WE HAVE SEEN THOSE
FREQUENTLY IN THE CONTEXT OF
STUDENT HOUSING, ESPECIALLY DOWN
AT USC, WHERE WE HAD ONE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS DOING TO STOP THE
PROJECT FROM ANOTHER HOUSING
DEVELOPER. WE'VE HAD PROJECTS
WHERE YOU HAVE GAS STATIONS THEY
CAN TO STOP COMPUTING GAS
STATIONS ACROSS THE STREET AND
EVEN UM, SOME ACTIVISTS SEEKING
TO STOP REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CLINICS, ARGUING THAT THEY
THEMSELVES AND THEIR PROTESTS OF
THESE CLINICS ARE GOING TO CAUSE
A SIGNIFICANT EFFECT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT AND SO SEEK WHERE
THERE HAS TO BE PERFORMED FOR
THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS. SO
SEQUEL HAS A PATHWAY FOR ANYONE
AND EVERYONE TO COME IN AND TRY
AND DERAIL SOMETHING, AND THAT'S
A PROBLEM. THAT'S NOT WHAT IT
WAS INTENDED TO DO, BUT WE
RECOGNIZE THIS IS ONLY PART OF
THE ISSUE BECAUSE THERE ARE A
LOT OF OTHER SITUATIONS. WHERE
SETTLEMENTS AND THREATS OF
LITIGATION ARE RESOLVED BEFORE
ANYTHING IS FILED WITH THE
COURTS. AGAIN TRANSPARENCY OF
CONTRIBUTORS, I THINK IS WHAT
HELPED TREMENDOUSLY TO GET A
BETTER GRASP OF WHO IS BRINGING
THESE ACTIONS AND MAYBE WITH
SOME OF THEIR UNDERLYING
MOTIVATIONS MAY BE AND ON RELIEF
FROM INJUNCTIVE RELIEF, THE LAST
PART OF THE BILL, I THINK IT
MAKES SENSE AS A WAY TO PROVIDE
MORE EQUITY BETWEEN SOME OF THE
MEGA PROJECTS LIKE THE KING'S
ARENA, THE CAPITOL ANNEX ANY
RANK AND FILE PROJECTS THAT NEED
SIMILAR RELIEF. SO WE SUPPORT SP
1259 BECAUSE IT SEEKS TO TAKE A
HARD LOOK AND IMPROVE SEQUEL
WITHOUT NOT REALLY CHANGING THE
INFORMATION DISCLOSURE OR
MITIGATION REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
THE CORE FUNCTIONS OF THE LAW.
AND SO WE URGE YOUR I VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU, JOHN. ONE
CLARIFYING QUESTION BECAUSE I
FOUND YOUR TESTIMONY REALLY
INTRIGUING. IN MANY, MANY CASES,
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS THE RIGHT
TO MAKE THESE KINDS OF PROJECTS
MINISTERIAL AND BYPASS. SEQUA SO
ARE ARE YOU MAKING THE ARGUMENT
THAT YOU WANT TO HAVE, UM, SOME
SECRET PROCESS, BUT NOT NOT NOT
NOT NOT THE FULL BOND PROCESS
THAT'S CREATED ALL THE
CHALLENGES RIGHT SO LOCALS CAN
AND HAVE DEVELOPED STREAMLINED
MINISTERIAL PERMIT REVIEW
PROCESSES. ON OCCASION, THE
LEGISLATURE'S DEVELOPED MANY OF
THOSE OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AS A BACKDOOR WAY TO GET A
SEQUEL EXEMPTION WITHOUT REALLY
HAVING TO A LOT OF TIMES. THESE
ARE PROJECTS THAT ARE REALLY
GOING TO HAVE SECOND EVENT
EFFECTS ON THE ENVIRONMENT. BUT
FOR THOSE PROJECTS WHERE SECRET
IS TRIGGERED, WE THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE SOMETHING
THAT'S CLEAR THAT'S PREDICTABLE
THAT PROVIDES THE INFORMATION.
DISCLOSURE AND MITIGATION
REQUIREMENTS WITHOUT OPENING THE
DOOR FOR PEOPLE TO COME IN AND
SUE AND DELAY PROJECTS FOR LESS
THAN IDEAL PURPOSES. THANK YOU.
OKAY, LET'S HEAR FROM OTHER
FOLKS WHO WANT TO WIN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON. YEP NOPE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ADAM REGULAR ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SHARON ISSUED ON
BEHALF OF THE SACRAMENTO
REGIONAL BUILDERS EXCHANGE IN
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDERS,
ALLIANCE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SILVIO FOR OUR
BEHALF TO CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
DANGER OFF OF THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ALRIGHT,
OPPOSITION. TESTIMONY. HMM. YOU
COULD. WELL COME OUT FUNNY ONE
IF YOU WANT. YEAH. JUST COME TO
THE MIC. OKAY? ALRIGHT. OKAY?
GOOD MORNING, SENATOR. THERE YOU
GO. GOOD MORNING. SENATORS BAKER
PLAYING CONTRIBUTION THAT WASN'T
PLANNING ON BEING PRIMARY ON
THIS, BUT, UM BEAR WITH ME, BUT,
UM, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
AUTHOR, AND THE PROPONENTS HERE
THAT WE WORK WITH OFTEN ON THESE
ISSUES, WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THE BRIGHTNESS OF THIS PROPOSAL.
WE UNDERSTAND THE INTENT OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE. BUT AS
I OFTEN SAY WITH THESE BILLS, WE
CAN'T THROW THE BABY OUT WITH
THE BATHWATER ON SEQUA. I MEAN,
I APPRECIATE THAT WE WANT TO GET
OF THIS EFFORT TO TRY TO INHIBIT
GOOD PROJECTS BEING DELAYED BY
INDIVIDUALS OR INDIVIDUAL
INTEREST. NÓI THE INFANTS IS
THAT THAT HAPPENS, IT'S PROBABLY
A FRACTION OF THE OVERWHELMING
NUMBER OF PROJECTS THAT ARE
IMPROVED BY THE COMMUNITY
PROCESSES SECRET PROVIDES THAT
WHERE ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS
ARE MADE AND COMMUNITIES ARE
PROTECTED. WHERE THEY OTHERWISE
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN. IF THAT
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
WASN'T THERE, UM HMM. WE AGREE
WITH THE ANALYSIS IS THE
CONCERNS ACROSS THE MULTIPLE
ASPECTS OF THE BILL EXPRESSED IN
THE ANALYSIS, BUT I WANT TO
SPEAK TO ONE SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE IT COMES UP EVERY YEAR.
THIS IDEA OF NEEDING TO DISCLOSE
CONTRIBUTORS TO LITIGATION IN
SEQUA AND, UM, YOU KNOW SECRET
REQUIRES UM PUBLIC ENFORCEMENT
TO BE IMPLEMENTED AND REQUIRING
OR GIVEN THE ABILITY TO DISCLOSE
CONTRIBUTORS TO LITIGATION WITH
SEVERELY UNDERCUT, YOU KNOW,
SMALL COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS,
ABILITY TO FUNDRAISING SUSTAIN
THEMSELVES THAT WELL, IT WOULD
GIVE DONORS HESITANT TO
CONTRIBUTE TO ORGANIZATIONS FOR
FEAR THAT THEY WOULD GET NAMED
IN A LAWSUIT THAT THEY HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH, YOU KNOW.
AND RIGHTFULLY SO AND THAT BUT
THAT WOULD SEVERELY LIMIT SMALL,
HUMBLY FUNDED COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS, ABILITY TO
FUNDRAISE AND SUSTAIN THEMSELVES
. I WORK FOR ONE OF THOSE I KNOW
IT FIRSTHAND, REALLY, REALLY
HAVE GREAT CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
PROVISION THAT THAT PROPOSAL
COMING BACK YEAR AFTER YEAR. UM
RESPECTFULLY. URGE A NO VOTE.
DON'T YOU STAY UP HERE, MATT AND
LET'S HEAR FROM ANYONE ELSE WHO
WANTS TO HAVE EXPRESSED
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. 40 MIGHT
FALLS AWAY WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENT HOLDERS AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING THAT SAID IN
OPPOSITION. OOH, OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. OH, YES. HEY. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR KEITH DONE HERE ON
BEHALF OF BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO THE DISTRICT COUNCIL LINE
WORKERS IN OPPOSITION. HMM. MR
CHAIR MEMBER SARAH FLOCKS,
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ALRIGHT
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS AND THOUGHTS. UM
YEAH. OKAY NICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR. THIS IS FIRST OF
ALL. THANKS FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FORWARD. I KNOW THAT THIS
BILL HAS GOT A TOUGH ROAD TODAY.
BUT REALLY, BUT I THINK WE OUGHT
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION AND I
REALLY THINK IT'S FUNNY THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO LET PEOPLE
KNOW WHO THEY ARE FUNDING THESE
CAMPAIGNS. BUT THERE ARE THESE
LAWSUITS, BUT THEY SURE WANT TO
KNOW WHO'S FUNDING CAMPAIGNS AND
I THINK THOSE TWO THINGS GO
TOGETHER. I THINK WE SHOULD KNOW
WHO'S DOING THESE PRISONERS
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS AT THE END OF
THE DAY. YOU KNOW THIS BILLS
LIKE I SAID, I THINK HAS A TOUGH
TIME HERE. BUT I THINK WE NEED
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA YOU CAN'T
AFFORD TO BUILD HERE. I MEAN,
SENATOR SKINNER WAS JUST HERE
YESTERDAY TALKING ABOUT HOOKUP
FEES, AND THERE'S A REASON WHY
THOSE HOOK UP. THESE ARE CAUGHT
COSTLY IS BECAUSE IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE TO ANYTHING IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE WE ARE NOT
DOING IT IN A IF IT'S ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT, AND I LOVE SEQUEL.
I'VE SAID THAT FROM THE START
SEQUEL IS A GREAT LAW AND I
THINK CALIFORNIA'S LEAD, BUT
IT'S BEEN USED. FAR TOO MANY
TIMES FOR UPON UPON FOR AS THE
AUTHOR STATED A LABOR AGREEMENT
OR OR COMPETITOR WHEN I WAS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL, I HAD ONE
MINING COMPANY SUING ANOTHER
MINING COMPANY OVER SECRET
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
COMPETITION. IF IT'S ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND LET'S FOCUS ON
THE ENVIRONMENT AND LET'S DO
WHAT SEQUELS ACTUALLY MEANT TO
DO, WHICH IS MITIGATE THOSE
IMPACTS. AND IF THOSE IMPACTS
CAN BE MITIGATED IN THE PROJECT
CAN'T GO FORWARD IF THEY CAN BE
MITIGATED. THEN WITH THE PROJECT
SHOULD GO FORWARD. SO I THINK
THAT I'LL MOVE THE BILL WHEN THE
TIME COMES, AND I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW, EVEN GOVERNOR GOVERNOR
NEWSOM AND GOVERNOR BROWN. NO
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME WORK DONE
IN THIS AREA. AND WE SHOULD WE
SHOULD. MAYBE THIS IS A LITTLE
TOO BROAD FOR YOU. BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY, CALIFORNIA
CANNOT MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
PROJECT THAT WE NEED TO GET
DONE, WHETHER IT'S TRANSMISSION.
WHETHER IT'S MINING FOR LITHIUM.
WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING HERE
BECAUSE WE'RE MIRED IN, UM THE
PROCESS, ANALYSIS, PARALYSIS AND
TOO MANY POWERBROKERS, QUITE
FRANKLY, USING SECRET AS A
OPPORTUNITY TO EXTRACT OR RUN
THE RUN THE GAME OUT, SO I THINK
THAT, UM, YOU KNOW I THINK THE
PUBLIC IN GENERAL IT'S STARTING
TO UNDERSTAND IT, AND THAT'S WHY
YOU DON'T SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
HERE. AND THEN THE OPPOSITION
DIDN'T EVEN REALLY FORMALLY
COMING BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT'S
GOING TO DIE TODAY, BUT THEY
CAN'T REALLY WITH A STRAIGHT
FACE. SAY, HEY, THIS IS ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE IT'S
ABOUT A LOT OF OTHER THINGS, AND
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY IT BECAUSE
IT NEEDS TO BE SAID, AND I
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIANS WILL
WAKE UP AT SOME POINT AND IT
WILL GET ON THE BALLOT AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO WAR. AND WE NEED
TO HAVE THAT BECAUSE WE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING IN CALIFORNIA. I'M IN
BUSINESS, AND I WAS ALSO AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL FOR 16 YEARS. RURAL
COUNTY, CHINA APPROVED PROJECTS
GOOD PROJECTS THAT JUST THE
CLOCK RAN OUT OR THEY OR THEY
BANKRUPTED THE PROPONENTS AND
WERE ABLE TO GET THINGS DONE. SO
FOR THOSE REASONS, I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. GOOD
LUCK, SENATOR. THANK YOU. LET ME
JUST YEAH. UM NO. I APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS. I AM. WELL, I
THINK WHEN OUR STAFF HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUR STAFF
SENATOR, YOU KNOW, AND ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS WAS DO YOU WANT TO
PRESENT THE BILL, AS IS OR DO
YOU WANT TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT AMENDMENTS? I THINK YOU
WERE. IT SEEMED LIKE YOUR STAFF
FORCE INTERESTED IN KIND OF
LAYING OUT YOUR VISION AND
HAVING THAT BE AN UP OR DOWN
VOTE. UM I DO THINK THAT I HAVE
LISTENED CAREFULLY TO THE
TESTIMONY AND ALL THE ALL THE
COMMENTS. I THINK THERE'S SOME
MERIT TO SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN SAID. UM YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT ARE IN THE BILL IS WRITTEN.
THAT JUST ARE REAL CHALLENGE FOR
US. I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW,
THE IDEA OF EXPEDITED JUDICIAL
REVIEW HAS BEEN GRANTED IN ALL
SORTS OF DIFFERENT CASES. AND
INDEED THERE IS A BILL THAT
WE'RE NEGOTIATING RIGHT NOW THAT
HAS TO DO WITH THAT QUESTION. IN
THE WAY. OF COURSE IN THIS BILL,
THERE WERE NO ENVIRONMENTAL YOU
KNOW CRITERIA. THAT WERE PUT IN
PLACE. BEEN RETURNED FOR, UM,
FOR STREAMLINING. WE'VE ALWAYS
ASKED FOR SOME FORM OF
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP. BEFORE
A PROJECT GETS SPECIAL TREATMENT
UNDER SEQUA. SO I, YOU KNOW, BUT
BUT I DO AGREE THAT THE IDEA
THAT WE'VE GOT CASES JUST GO ON
YEAR AFTER YEAR HANGING OUT
THERE, AND IT IS INSTRUCTIVE TO
HEAR FROM OUR FRIENDS FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WHO HAVE CONCERNS
THAT THAT THAT'S AN ISSUE. I
THINK WE NEED TO SPEND SOME TIME
ON THE OTHER THING. OF COURSE
THAT WAS IN THE FILM WAS OF REAL
CONCERN. WAS THE PROHIBITION ON
STAYING A PROJECT UNLESS THE
PROJECT JEOPARDIZES HUMAN SAFETY
OR HARMS CULTURAL TRIBAL
RESOURCES. AND AGAIN, YOU KNOW,
YOU COULD HAVE ENVIRONMENTAL
HARM WOULD NOT BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION UNDER THE WAY THAT
YOU HAD IT FRAMED. YOU KNOW,
WITH THE BILL. SO, UM THAT THAT
ALSO, OF COURSE, WAS A CONCERN.
I THINK THAT WE HAD THERE WAS
ANOTHER PORTION OF THE BILL THAT
PROHIBITED APPROVING SETTLEMENTS
ON ON ENVIRONMENTAL PROVISIONS.
UM YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, AS WE
ALL KNOW, SETTLEMENTS ARE
OFTENTIMES PART OF A BIG DEAL
THAT STRUCK BETWEEN PLAINTIFFS
AND, UM AND THE DEVELOPERS AND
OFTENTIMES THERE ARE THINGS THAT
ARE INCORPORATED INTO A DEAL
THAT UM THEY COULD, THEY COULD
BE BENEFICIAL. I AM OPEN TO
THESE CONVERSATIONS. I ACTUALLY
THINK THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S NOT
THERE MAY BE SOME SPACE FOR, UM
YOU KNOW, EVEN LISTENING TO THE
TESTIMONY OF THE OF THE
SUPPORTING OPPOSITION, UM
BECAUSE I THINK IN THE END OF
THE DAY WE WANT WE WANT EQUAL TO
BE A TOOL THAT TRULY IS A
PROTECTOR FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
AND YOU KNOW, AND I UNDERSTAND
THERE'S ALWAYS PRESSURE TO TRY
TO DO AWAY WITH IT, AND I THINK
THERE'S SOME CHANGES THAT NEED
TO BE MADE. THEY WILL HAVE TO
MAKE IT A MORE EFFECTIVE TOOL
INTO THE FUTURE. I JUST THINK
THAT THE WAY THAT IT WAS FRAMED
IN THIS BILL GOES CERTAINLY
BEYOND WHAT I'M COMFORTABLE
SUPPORTING UM SO I'M CERTAINLY
NOT GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY, BUT BUT I DO. I DON'T I
THINK THAT THERE IS SOME SERIOUS
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED.
THEY NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. AND I
KNOW THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS THAT HAVE INTEREST IN
THIS SPACE AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT
WE CAN GET A REAL CONVERSATION
TOGETHER WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY. TO TALK ABOUT WAYS TO
MAKE SOME COMMON SENSE CHANGES
TO SEE CHOIR THAT WILL THAT WILL
? YEAH MEET ALL OF OUR MUTUAL
NEEDS AND I KNOW THAT'S A
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION. I'M SURE
THAT GETS PEOPLE NERVOUS. BUT I
THINK IT'S A WORTHWHILE
CONVERSATION FOR US TO HAVE AND
SO I JUST WANT TO THROW THAT OUT
THERE IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS
THIS PARTICULAR BILL, WHICH I AS
I SAY IT GOES TOO FAR FROM ME
FOR THE REASONS THAT I JUST
STATED BUT I'M CERTAINLY HAPPY
TO HEAR OTHER PEOPLE'S COMMENTS
AND THOUGHTS. SENTIMENTAL ART.
THANK YOU, MR CHAIR, UNIVERSAL.
A INVITE THROUGH. I AGREE WITH
YOU, I THINK I THINK WE HAD A
COUPLE OF BILLS LAST YEAR THAT I
THINK ON BOTH SIDES SHOULD BE
TRANSPARENT AND WHO'S PAYING FOR
ALL THESE THINGS? I DO I AGREE
WITH YOU ON THAT. I'D LIKE TO
HEAR A LITTLE BIT MORE, MR. SURE
IF I COULD DIRECT MY QUESTION TO
CALIFORNIA. UM BE SURE BECAUSE
YOU KNOW, YOU JUST HEARD MY
COMMENTS IN THE PREVIOUS BILLS
RELATED TO SICKO STREAMLINING,
BUT I TEND TO DRAW THE LINE WHEN
IT COMES TO MORE HOUSING, AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE AND I'D LIKE
TO HEAR A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
DIRECTLY HOW YOU'RE SEEING A
BARRIER IN IN PRODUCING MORE
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA AND
DIRECTLY HAD THIS WILL HELP
CREATE MORE HOUSING PROJECTS.
OKAY AND JUST WITH THAT, I LIKE
THAT QUESTION. AND I MEAN ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES HERE. WE'VE
CREATED 120, YOU KNOW, TARGETED
EXEMPTIONS, INCLUDING SO MANY
EXEMPTIONS MINISTER OF
PROSECUTING FIRST SPECIFICALLY
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOUSING MORE BROADLY THAT
THERE'S VERY LITTLE HOUSING LEFT
UNDER THE PURVIEW SEEK WHEN I SO
I THAT WAS ANOTHER, LIKE DO WITH
THAT. I'D LIKE TO ADD THAT IN
THERE AS YOU ANSWER. I DIDN'T
KNOW YOU WERE. I MEAN, IT WASN'T
ON THE ANALYSIS THAT YOU WERE,
UH, SPORT OR SPONSOR SUPPORTER.
SO THIS WAS NEW TO ME. I'M SORRY
. THIS IS WHERE I'M GETTING
DRAWN INTO THE HOUSING PORTION.
PART OF IT. YES ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR MENJIVAR.
WE'RE PROUD SUPPORT OF SB TRUCK
59. ONE OF THE REASONS ONE OF
THE THINGS I MENTIONED IN MY IN
MY TALKING POINTS IS THE LONG
LITIGATION COSTS BEHIND IT
BEHIND THE LAWSUITS AND HOW
SPECIFIC PROJECT PROJECTS WE'VE
SEEN DELAYED. THE SENATOR NEAL
MENTIONED SPECIFICALLY
UNIVERSITIES AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM RC RC MENTIONED SPECIFIC
UNIVERSITIES FOR STUDENT HOUSING
SPECIFICALLY ARE BEING DELAYED
DUE TO SEEK THE LAWSUITS. AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE WAYS WE SEE
THE SEEKERS BEING USED AS A TOOL
TO KIND OF DELAY PROJECTS
INCREASED COST FOR THAT. AND
REALLY NOT PRODUCE THE HOUSING
THAT WE NEED THAT WE NEED TO
PRODUCE IN CALIFORNIA. I'M HAPPY
TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR OFFICE
SPECIFICALLY IN EXAMPLES IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS OR SPECIFIC
YEARS, OR MAYBE IN THE DISTRICT
AS WELL AROUND THE DISTRICT
ABOUT HOW SUPER HAS BEEN USED TO
REALLY USE AS A STALL TACTICS
WHEN IT COMES TO PRODUCING
HOUSING. AND I RECOGNIZE. I'M
NOT TRYING TO NEGOTIATE FROM THE
DIOCESE OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
BUT IF THERE ARE STILL GAPS THAT
EXIST, YOU KNOW YOU'VE MENTIONED
100 AND SOMETHING, MR CHAIR ON
REMOVING HOUSING FROM THIS AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE. BUT IF THERE'S
STILL GAPS EXIST A BEAR'S I'D BE
REALLY INTERESTED THAT WERE
FURTHER ADDRESSING THOSE, BUT I
AM NOT SO IF I STADIUM SO FORTH,
I'M NOT A PROPONENT OF
STREAMLINING ANY PROJECTS LIKE
THAT. I REALLY AM NOT. I THINK
THEY NEED TO GO THROUGH ALL THE
ENTIRE REVIEW, REGARDLESS OF THE
INVESTMENT BECAUSE MOST OF THE
TIMES THE INVESTMENTS ARE
COMMUNITIES OF COLORS RIGHT, AND
THERE'S UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES,
BUT FOR HOUSING SPECIFICALLY
WILL BE MORE INTERESTED IN
SEEING A NARROW VERSION OF THIS
BILL. SPECIFIC HOUSING. YES I
KNOW ON THAT ISSUE, BERKELEY
SENATOR WEINER HAS BEEN WORKING
ON THAT THERE WAS A BILL THAT
GOT THROUGH AND THERE'S MORE
WORK HAPPENING, BUT, UM, I WILL
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
REQUEST OF YOU. BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN SO MUCH WORK TO TAKE
HOUSING OUT OF, UM SEQUENCE SUCH
THAT WHEN THERE'S OTHER SECRET
BILL THAT WEINER'S BROUGHT
FORWARD WITH REGARDS TO DOWNTOWN
SAN FRANCISCO. IT'S BASICALLY
NOT HOUSING AT ALL. I MEAN, YOU
KNOW VERY FEW EXEMPTIONS, BUT
IT'S A COMMERCIAL. BECAUSE THERE
IS A RECOGNITION OF HOW MUCH
FLEXIBILITY IS NOT BEEN GIVEN
FOR HOUSING. SO I'M INTERESTED
IN HEARING MORE ABOUT YET, SO
THERE IS ONE THING, BUT I THINK
IT'S A LOT MORE COMPLICATED
BECAUSE IT'S HOW SEQUEL WAS
DESIGNED RIGHT? AND SO ONE OF
THE MITIGATION TOOLS UNDER SEQUA
, WE OFTEN SEE THE SIZE OF THE
HOUSING PROJECTS SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCED FROM WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY
CONTEMPLATED. SO YOU HAVE LESS
UNITS DELIVERED AS PART OF
WHATEVER HOUSING PROJECT THEN
WAS OTHERWISE PROPOSED AT THE
BEGINNING, SO I THINK THERE ARE
A LOT OF REASONS WHY SECRET CAN
BE AN IMPEDIMENT TO HOUSING.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PLACES WHERE
SOME OF THOSE EXISTING AND
RECENT MINISTERIAL PROCESSES
DON'T WORK. THERE ARE A LOT OF
HOUSING EXEMPTIONS ON THE SECRET
BOOKS TODAY THAT ARE ILLUSORY
BECAUSE OF ALL THE OTHER
PROVISIONS IN THERE, ONE OF
WHICH CAN BE LOCATED WITHIN THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE STATE
CONSERVANCY, WHICH IS PROBABLY
ABOUT 60 70% OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO A LOT OF THOSE
LITTLE CHECK BOXES THAT YOU HAVE
TO CHECK OFF WERE DESIGNED TO
LIMIT THE SCOPE AND PRECLUDE THE
ABILITY TO USE THESE EXEMPTIONS
FOR HOUSING AND OTHER IMPORTANT
PROJECT. YEAH ANOTHER THING BY
THE WAY, I MEAN, THERE'S A LOT
OF MERIT TO EXPEDITE REVIEW DID
IT PUTS A MASSIVE BIRD ON THE
COURTS AND I WILL SAY TO FOLKS
IF WE'RE REALLY SERIOUS ABOUT
THIS, WE'VE GOT TO GIVE THE
COURTS THE RESOURCES THEY NEED.
I MEAN, STANDALONE SECRET COURTS
HELP FOLKS WITH REAL EXPERTISE
THAT CAN DO THE WORK IS IN THE
END OF THE DAY. WE WANT THESE
REVIEWS TO HAPPEN. THEY REALLY
DO CREATE A LOT OF THEY BECOME
SUCH AN IMPORTANT TOOL FOR
PROTECTING COMMUNITIES AND
ALLOWING FOR PUBLIC INPUT AND
QUITE FUNNY, BETTER PLANNING.
OFTENTIMES THERE'S PROJECTS THAT
I THINK I THINK YOU KNOW, THIS
IS FROM COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT YOU KNOW, HAVING
THAT ROBUST REVIEW PROCESS IS
IMPORTANT. THE CHALLENGES IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO DRAG ON FOR
YEARS. AND YET WHEN WE WHEN WE
CREATE THIS EXPERT REVIEW THE
COURTS KICKING SCREEN WITH GOOD
REASON. BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
PROVIDED WHEN THE RESOURCES TO
REALLY DO THE WORK TO GET THESE
CASES DONE IN A MORE EXPEDITED
AND TIMELY MANNER THAT THAT HAS
TO BE PART OF ANY KIND OF
SOLUTION. YOU KNOW IF WE'RE
REALLY GOING TO DRAMATICALLY
EXPANDED, EXPEDITED REVIEW
APPROACH BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT
TO TAKE AWAY. I DON'T WANT TO
SEE, YOU KNOW PROJECTS MOVE
FORWARD BECAUSE THEY JUST RAN
OUT OF TIME WHEN THEY REALLY
STILL REQUIRED, UM WHEN THEY
STILL REALLY NEEDED PROPER
JUDICIAL CONSIDERATION, AND
PUBLIC INPUT AND COMMUNITY
INPUT, AND ALL OF THE ENGAGEMENT
THAT SEQUA ENCOURAGES AND SO
ANYHOW, UM WITH THAT? I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR UM FOR? YEAH
SPARKING THE CONVERSATION. YOU
KNOW, AS I SAY, I'M CERTAINLY
OPEN TO A TONIGHT AND I DO
ENCOURAGE, UM, BRIBE BASED
ENGAGEMENT. THE BILL IS TOO
BROAD FOR ME TO SUPPORT TODAY.
BUT BUT I THINK THERE'S AREAS IN
THIS BILL FOR CONVERSATION
FURTHER. SO WITH THAT, I'D LOVE
TO ASK YOU TO CLOSE. THANK YOU,
MR CHAIR AND THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMENTS. OUR STAFF AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF DID HAVE SOME
DISCUSSIONS RELATIVE TO MENDING
THE BILL. AND THE REASON THAT I
WASN'T INTERESTED IN THE SORTS
OF AMENDMENTS THAT WE WERE SORT
OF CONCEPTUALLY TALKING ABOUT
WAS IT DID COMPROMISE MY ABILITY
TO PRESENT WHAT VISION I HAVE
FOR SEQUEL REFORM. NOW I SAY THE
WORD SECRET REFORM. THIS REALLY
ISN'T SEQUEL REFORM. I'M NOT
REFORMING THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACTOR. I'M
NOT PROPOSING TO. IT IS A GOOD
ACT BUT 50 YEARS AGO, UM WHEN IT
WAS ADOPTED, AND I THINK SIGNED
BY GOVERNOR REAGAN I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY ENVISIONED. THAT THAT
LAW WAS GOING TO BE USED TO
PROTEST. AH PROJECTS FOR REASONS
OTHER THAN ENVIRONMENTAL. AH!
ASPECTS. AND YOU STAYED A
CONCERN WITH REGARD TO THE
LANGUAGE. AH DEFINING THE
STANDING IF YOU WILL DUBBED THE
PROTEST, AND ALSO THE ABILITY
FOR THE PROJECT TO GO AHEAD
UNLESS THE PROTEST WAS BASED
UPON CERTAIN ASPECTS THAT YOU
HAD CONCERNS ABOUT BUT THE
SEQUEL AND PUBLIC INPUT AND THE
LIKE, BUT THE SECRET PROCESS
ITSELF IS AN OUTSTANDING
PROCESS. AND I WHEN I WAS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL, WE OBVIOUSLY HAD
PROJECTS THAT WERE, UH, REVIEWED
UNDER SEQUA AND WE WOULD GET THE
REPORTS AND I WOULD TRY TO PLOW
THROUGH THEM. THEY'RE KIND OF
LENGTHY. BUT THEY POINT OUT
NUMBER ONE SPECIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF THE
PROJECT. AND IT'S QUITE COMPLETE
AND ALSO, UH, STATES SUGGESTED
MITIGATION MEASURES OR IF IT
CAN'T BE MITIGATED, BUT THERE'S
A THERE'S A PUBLIC COMMENT
PROCESS. THERE IS THE ABILITY
FOR THE PUBLIC TO MAKE COMMENTS
ON THAT REVIEW BEFORE IT GOES TO
THE GOVERNING BODY THAT MAKES
THE FINAL POLICY DECISIONS SO
ALL OF THAT PUBLIC INPUT HAS
PERFECTLY ADEQUATE. AH TIME AND
SCOPE. TO BE AIRED AND BACK TO
THE WEAPONIZATION OF IT. TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT, THE OPPOSITION
KIND OF MADE MY CASE. TWO OF THE
OPPONENTS ARE LABOR UNIONS. NOW
I'M NOT GOING TO CHALLENGE THEIR
STANDING TO OBJECT TO A PROJECT
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL REASONS. BUT
LABOR UNIONS DON'T TYPICALLY
OBJECT TO A PROJECT UNDER SEQUEL
REVIEW FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
REASONS, IT'S USUALLY DUE TO
LABOR DISPUTES SUCH AS WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE CENTER.
MEDICAL CENTER. AND THERE IS AN
ISSUE OF EQUALITY HERE WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT PROJECTS THAT HAVE
EXEMPTIONS JUST BECAUSE THE
POWERS THAT BE WANT THOSE
PROJECTS TO GO FORWARD. WHEN I
WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY, THERE WERE
SEVERAL OF THOSE PROPOSALS AND I
VOTED AGAINST EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THEM. I WILL ADMIT THAT IF I
WAS A LEGISLATOR, WHEN THE
GOLDEN ONE PROJECT WENT THROUGH,
I WOULD HAVE BEEN A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE, BUT I PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE VOTED AGAINST THAT,
TOO. BECAUSE IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE. TO PROVIDE FAVOR JUST TO
THOSE PROJECTS THAT ARE FAVORED
BY THE POWERS THAT BE THEY
SHOULD GO THE SAME REVIEW OR WE
SHOULD ALLOW SIMILAR EXEMPTIONS
FOR ANY PROJECT SUBJECT TO IT
GOING THROUGH A COMPLETE SECRET
REVIEW AND THEN SUBSEQUENT
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD AND THE
REVIEW BY THE GOVERNING BOARD
THAT'S GOING TO AUTHORIZED THE
PROJECT. UM AND POINT ABOUT THE
BIG GUYS, BY THE WAY, IF THE
DESIRE IS TO LOWER THAT
THRESHOLD, I'M FINE WITH THAT.
BUT THE POINT IS THEIR MAJOR
PROJECTS THAT WERE PRESUMABLY OF
MORE IMPACT AND IMPORTANCE FROM
ALL SORTS OF ALL SORTS OF
ASPECTS. SO WHAT I'M LOOKING FOR
I'LL GO TO A CONCEPTUAL
DESCRIPTION AND THAT IS THAT WE
STOP THE WEAPONIZATION OF SEQUA.
THAT WE REQUIRE THAT ANY
CHALLENGE AND EVEN THE PROPOSAL
DOESN'T SAY THAT YOU CAN'T
CHALLENGE IT FOR WHATEVER. HE
WAS JUST REASON YOU WANT TO
CHALLENGE IT, BUT WE'VE GOT TO
SETTLE IT QUICKLY, AND THE
DISCLOSURE, I THINK IS IMPORTANT
. THE TESTIMONY OF THE OPPONENT
NOTWITHSTANDING, AS HAS BEEN
EXPRESSED BY TWO PEOPLE ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THAT DIOCESE. IF
WE NEED THAT DISCLOSURE AND
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS, WHY
WOULDN'T WE NEED IT THERE? SO I
DO THINK THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT.
BUT WE'VE GOT TO STOP THE
ABILITY TO USE SEQUA AS A BLUNT
INSTRUMENT FOR REASONS THAT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. THAT'S WHAT I'M LOOKING
FOR. THAT'S WHAT MY VISION IS. I
REALIZE IT'S NOT GOING TO
PREVAIL TODAY. VOTERS WILLING,
I'LL BE HERE FOR SEVEN MORE
YEARS. 6.5 MORE YEARS AND I AM
DETERMINED AND VERY PATIENT
LEGISLATOR. AH I HAVE SAID
FREQUENTLY AS A MINORITY. I
PROPOSE THINGS THAT DON'T STAND
A GREAT CHANCE HERE AND I AM
VERY ADROIT AT CRASHING AND
BURNING WITH GRACE AND MY
DIGNITY AND TACT AND TRYING
AGAIN. SO CALLING UPON GOVERNOR
BROWN'S COMMENT OF A FEW YEARS
AGO, I INVITE YOU TO BE A
DISCIPLE OF THAT GOD'S WORK, AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
VOTE. ACTIVISM MOVED BY SENATOR
DOLLY SECURITIES CORAL B 1259.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY SENATORS ALLEN DOLLY!
DOLLY! I GONZALEZ. HER TAITO
MENJIVAR WHEN SKINNER. OKAY?
ALRIGHT, WELL, HOLD ON ROBIN FOR
YOUR COLLEAGUE. OKAY LET'S LET'S
NOW GO TO ANOTHER CHALLENGING
BUT INTERESTING BILL AND SB
1393. ALLOW ME TO PRESENT
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE. NO,
YOU'RE GOING TO LOVE. SO THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR FOR THAT. AND FOR
THIS AND MEMBERS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT SP 1393 1393 CREATES
AN APPEALS ADVISORY COMMITTEE
MADE UP OF STATE AGENCIES,
INDUSTRY EXPERTS, FLEETS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO NAVIGATE
THE EXEMPTION AND EXTENSION
PROCESS FOR THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. ADVANCED CLEAN
FLEETS. CF REGULATION AS WE ALL
KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND 7920 IMPOSED MULTIPLE
STRATEGIES AND DIRECTIVES TO
HELP THE STATE ADDRESS CLIMATE
CRISIS, INCLUDING CALLING ON
MULTIPLE STATE AGENCIES TO
IMPOSE REGULATIONS TO HELP
ACHIEVE THE STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS. ONE SUCH GOAL IS MAKING
THE MOVE TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES BY CERTAIN DEADLINES.
THIS IS BEING DONE THROUGH CARB
WITH THEIR CF REGULATION. THIS
MONUMENTAL REGULATION REQUIRES
THE REDUCTION OF EMISSIONS
THROUGH REQUIREMENTS TO BOTH
PHASE IN AND USE USE OF Z V S
FOR TARGETED FLEETS AND
REQUIREMENTS THAT MANUFACTURERS
ONLY MANUFACTURER ZE'EVI TRUCKS
STARTING IN THE 2036 MODEL YEAR
CAR WAS CREATED SOME PATHWAYS
FOR NARROW EXEMPTIONS AND
EXTENSIONS IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES. IT IS A BEST
PRACTICE TO ESTABLISH SOME KIND
OF AN APPEALS PROCESS WHEN A
REGULATION GRANTS, EXEMPTIONS
AND EXTENSIONS. WE'VE SEEN THIS
IN OTHER STATE AGENCIES LIKE
OSHA, LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BUREAU OF REGISTERED
NURSING AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE, AND EVEN AT
LOCAL AIR RESOURCES BOARD, SUCH
AS THE SOUTH COAST. MD. THIS
PROCESS CAN BE PARTICULARLY
HELPFUL AND IMPACTFUL AND GIVING
CLEARER AND MORE FEASIBLE
PATHWAYS TO COMPLIANCE WELL, NOT
DIMINISHING CARBS AUTHORITY AS
IT IS A COMMITTEE OF AN ADVISORY
ROLE ONLY. IT'S NOT A DECISION
MAKER. THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THE COMMITTEE TO MEET MONTHLY ON
AN EVENLY SPACED SCHEDULE TO
RECOMMEND ACTIONS TO CARB STAFF
REGARDING ALL DENIED APPEALS
SUBMITTED TO CARB FOR EXEMPTIONS
AND EXTENSIONS AS ALLOWED FOR
AND PERMITTED UNDER THE
REGULATION. THE CREATION OF THIS
COMMITTEE WILL ENABLE THESE
MULTIPLE ENTITIES TO WORK
TOGETHER, SHARE BEST PRACTICES
AND ADVISE CARB ON THE
REGULATIONS, SO REAL TIME
DECISIONS AND ADJUSTMENTS CAN BE
MADE TO HELP MAKE THE PROGRAM
SUCCESSFUL. TODAY I HAVE WITH ME
REPRESENTED A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE BILL SPONSORS THE
BILL'S SPONSOR TO FLEET
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION, MR
MICHAEL TAYLOR, AS WELL AS MR
DAVID RENTSCHLER, PUBLIC WORKS
FLEET DIVISION MANAGER FOR THE
CITY OF FAIRFIELD. SENATOR NEAL
OH, GOOD MORNING, CHAIRMAN ALAN
MEMBERS OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY AND SUPPORT OF SB 1393. MY
NAME IS MICHAEL TAYLOR AND I
SERVE AS THE ADVOCACY LEAD FOR
NAFTA FLEET MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION, THE LARGEST
ASSOCIATION OF FLEET MANAGERS IN
NORTH AMERICA. SB 1393 WOULD
CREATE AN ADVANCED CLEAN FLEETS
APPEALS ADVISORY COMMITTEE ALL
DECISIONS REGARDING APPEALS
WOULD CONTINUE TO BE MADE BY
CARB. THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WOULD SIMPLY HELP TO INFORM
DECISION MAKING AND PROVIDE
GREATER TRANSPARENCY IN THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS. SETTING
UP IN A CF APPEALS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE CONTINUES TO BE THE
NUMBER ONE REQUEST FROM OUR
CALIFORNIA NAFTA MEMBERS ARE
MEMBERS SEE IT AS THE MOST
POSITIVELY IMPACTFUL CHANGE THAT
CAN BE MADE TO THE REGULATION.
WE BELIEVE IT WILL ENSURE THAT
CARB FLEET MANAGERS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE PUBLIC AT
LARGE. ALL HAVE ACCESS TO THE
MOST UP TO DATE AND COMPLETE A
CF COMPLIANCE RELATED
INFORMATION AND GUIDANCE
AVAILABLE. IN THIS WAY WE SEEK
TO FACILITATE THE HIGHEST
POSSIBLE LEVEL OF COMPLIANCE. IN
ADDITION, I WOULD LIKE TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT WE ARE WORKING TO
AMEND SB 1393 TO INCLUDE A LABOR
REPRESENTATIVE, SHOULD YOU VOTED
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY? WE ARE
ALSO WORKING ON GARNERING THE
SUPPORT OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND. NAFTA ACTUALLY HAS
BEEN COLLABORATING WITH E D F IN
THE AREA OF ELECTRIFICATION
EDUCATION, SO WE ARE OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT THE FINAL RESULT IN THIS
CASE. IN CLOSING. AND WORKING
WITH SO MANY FLEET MANAGERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. I KNOW THEM TO BE HARD
WORKING PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE
DEDICATED TO DELIVERING THE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES NEEDED BY THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE. THEY
SIMPLY SEEK A CLEARER AND MORE
FEASIBLE PATHWAY TO COMPLIANCE.
SO THEY MAY FULLY SUPPORT A ZERO
EMISSION FUTURE CALIFORNIA WITH
THAT NAFTA RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
FOR AN I VOTE ON SP 1393 AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. THANK YOU.
YES, SIR. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS DAVID RENTSCHLER AM THE FLEET
DIVISION MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF
FAIRFIELD HAVE BEEN A MEMBER OF
NAFTA SINCE 2006. ALSO 2022
GOVERNMENT FLEET MANAGER OF THE
YEAR AND 2023. HALL OF FAME
INDUCTEE FOR GOVERNMENT FLEETS.
I HAVE WORKED WITH CARB COOL
HALL OF FAME. THANK YOU, SIR.
THANK YOU. GOVERNMENT FLEETS
HALL OF FAMER GOVERNMENT FLEET
IN AMERICAN PUBLIC WORKS
ASSOCIATION. AH HAVE BEEN IN
FLEET FOR OVER 35 YEARS, BOTH IN
FEDERAL, PRIVATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. CURRENTLY SINCE
AUGUST OF 2006 FOR THE CITY OF
FAIRFIELD. PRIOR TO THAT WAS
CITY OF TRACY. PRIOR TO THAT WAS
PRIVATE AND PRIOR TO THAT WAS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND SO
FOR OVER 35 YEARS I'VE BEEN IN
THE FLEET INDUSTRY AND WORKING
WITH CARB SINCE 2007 ON
REGULATIONS SUCH AS THE HEAVY
DUTY INSPECTION MAINTENANCE,
WHICH IS NOW THE CPC HAVE BEEN
PART OF THAT SINCE THE VERY
BEGINNING, THE INNOVATIVE CLEAN
TRANSIT REGULATION HAVE BEEN A
PART OF THAT SINCE THE VERY
BEGINNING, ALONG WITH THE
ADVANCED CLEAN TRUCK AND THE
ADVANCED CLEAN FLEET REGULATION,
SO I HAVE HELPED CARB WITH
MOLDING THESE REGULATIONS AND
GETTING US TO DECREASE THE
CARBON FOOTPRINT OF ALL FLEETS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND WORKING
TOWARDS THE ELECTRIFICATION. AND
ELECTRICAL ELECTRIC ATION,
MEANING BOTH BATTERY ELECTRIC
AND HYDROGEN FUEL CELL ELECTRIC
40 MISSIONS. AH SO WE ARE VERY
MUCH IN FAVOR OF GETTING TO THAT
DECARBONIZATION. THAT WOULD BE
GREAT. HOWEVER THERE ARE SOME
VEHICLES AS A, UH, I'VE ALSO
BEEN WORKING AND DOING
SPECIFICATIONS WRITING DESIGNING
THESE VOCATIONAL TRUCKS THAT WE
USE IN PUBLIC WORKS. I HATE TO
CUT OFF A HALL OF FAMER, BUT IF
YOU YOU COULD JUST WRAP UP YOUR
YOUR THOUGHTS. I'M SORRY, SIR.
AH SO THERE ARE SOME VEHICLES
THAT JUST AREN'T THE TECHNOLOGY
IS NOT THERE YET. AND SO WHAT?
WHAT WE BELIEVE IN IS THAT THERE
SHOULD BE AN APPEALS PROCESS FOR
EXEMPTION THAT GETS DENIED. AND
HOPEFULLY THEY THAT AUTHORITY
STAYS WITH CARP, AND THIS IS
JUST AN ADVISORY. ASKING THEM TO
RE LOOK AT SOMETHING SO I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU VOTE. UH TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT LET'S HEAR FROM OTHERS
WHO WANT TO WAIT AND SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. NICOLE WARD ULLMAN ON
BEHALF OF SAINT BERNARDINO
COUNTY AND SUPPORT HAYDEN'S
HOLMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHECKING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
DEAN TALLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MATTHEW ALLEN WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION, PLEASE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
DAMON CONKLIN ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAK CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
STRONG SUPPORT. JULIE MALINOWSKI
BALL ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION AND SUPPORT GOOD
MORNING, MR CHAIR. BRADY BEN,
ENGLAND, CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE IS IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU. CHRISTINA GALLAGHER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND SUPPORT AND I WAS ALSO ASKED
TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, KIRK BLACKBURN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TOW
TRUCK ASSOCIATION AND THE
WESTERN STATE TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ADAM HARPER, CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION, INDUSTRIAL
MATERIALS ASSOCIATION. STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. STEPHEN
FEDERALLY, WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU AND SUPPORT OKAY.
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
YOU'RE GOING TO COME UP HERE.
THEY CAN STAY IN JUST ARE YOU
GONNA COME UP? YOU WANT TO GO UP
HERE? MELISSA CAN DO THAT. ONCE
YOU START. CHAIR. MY NAME IS
MICHELLE CANNOLIS. YOU PRESS THE
BUTTON, PLEASE. MICHELLE
CANNOLIS HAPPY THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS. AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB 1393
. YOU SEE US PARTICIPATED
EXTENSIVELY IN THE MULTI YEAR
PROCESS FOR ADVANCES CLEAN
FLEETS, RULEMAKING UCF
REGULATION, WHICH WILL HELP TO
INCREASE THE USE OF ZERO
EMISSION, MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES, WHERE FEASIBLE FOR
FLEETS MEETING CERTAIN CRITERIA.
RESEARCH HAS INDICATED THAT
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
CONTRIBUTE A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF POLLUTION TO TOTAL ON ROAD
EMISSIONS, AND SCF WILL GREATLY
REDUCE THESE EMISSIONS,
SPECIFICALLY, OZONE FORMING
NITROGEN OXIDES BY MORE THAN 60%
AND LUNG DAMAGING FINE
PARTICULATES BY AROUND 35% BY
2050. THE REDUCTION IN EMISSIONS
ESTIMATED WILL TRANSLATE TO AN
ESTIMATED 2500 FEWER DEATHS. AND
OVER, 2000 AVOIDED
HOSPITALIZATIONS OVER THE SAME
PERIOD. ADDITIONALLY A CF WAS
CRAFTED IN A PRACTICAL MANNER TO
ENSURE THAT FLEXIBILITY WAS
AVAILABLE FOR REGULATED FLEETS.
AND THIS IS WHY THEY REPRESENTED
BY THE MANY EXEMPTIONS UNDER THE
ROLE AS WELL AS THE MULTIPLE
PATHWAYS FOR COMPLIANCE
AVAILABLE TO FLEET OPERATORS. SP
1393 CREATES AN APPEALS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WITH THE MONTHLY
MEETING REQUIREMENT TO REVIEW
DENIED REQUESTS. AND WHILE YOU
SEE US APPRECIATES THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSOR, TAKING THE TIME
TO MEET WITH US, AND WE
UNDERSTAND THEIR PERSPECTIVE,
THE WIDE RANGE OF EXEMPTIONS
BUILT INTO CFR, VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD AND IT APPEALS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE WOULD ONLY
SERVE TO UNNECESSARILY DELAY.
THE COMPLAINTS FOR LARGE FLEETS
ARE CAPABLE OF MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE
REGULATION. AFTER A MULTIYEAR
PROCESS. REGULATION IS FLEXIBLE
ENOUGH, AND THE AGENCIES NEED TO
SPEND THE RESOURCES IMPLEMENTING
THIS VITALLY IMPORTANT RULE
RATHER THAN CREATE A DELAY THAT
WILL INTERFERE WITH THE GOAL OF
THE REGULATION. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
SB 1393 AND A JOURNAL VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YES THANK
YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS MELISSA
ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS. THIS BILL
WILL ULTIMATELY UNDERCUT THE
INTENT OF THE ADVANCED CLEAN
FLEETS PROGRAM TO DE CARBONIZED
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IN A
TIMELY MANNER. THE ADVANCED
CLEAN FLEET PROGRAM IS ONE OF
THE STATES CRITICAL TOOLS TO
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR, WHICH IS
IDENTIFIED BY THE 2020 22
SCOPING PLAN AS THE LARGEST
CONTRIBUTING SECTOR IN
CALIFORNIA. THE PROGRAM HAS
ESTABLISHED CONDITIONS FOR
EXEMPTIONS TO APPEAL OR FURTHER
EXEMPT CERTAIN VEHICLES FROM
THESE REQUIREMENTS WOULD BE
COUNTERINTUITIVE TO OUR CLIMATE
GOALS. MOREOVER THE CREATION OF
SUCH AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE WOULD
COMPLICATE AND HINDER THE
PROCESS IS ALREADY IN PLACE TO
REVIEW EXEMPTION APPLICATIONS.
AND FOR THESE REGIONS REASONS WE
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR FOLKS
WHO WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL OR OPPOSITION. YES,
OKAY. THEY'RE A LITTLE WITH NRDC
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY, LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
YES MR VICE CHAIR. I JUST WANT
TO SAY I'LL MOVE THE BILL. I
KNOW THIS BILL IS PROBABLY A
TOUGH TIME, BUT I WANT TO JUST
STATE THE FACTS. THE FACTS ARE
YEAH, THERE IS A PROCESS AND THE
PROCESS DOESN'T WORK VERY WELL
REPRESENT TAHOE, WHERE WE HAVE
PUBLIC DETAILS. SO THESE ARE
THESE ARE PEOPLE HAVE TO CLEAR
THE ROADS, COUNTY CITIES. AND
THEY'RE FORCED TO FIVE VEHICLES
THAT ARE EMISSION EFFICIENT ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES, WHICH DON'T
WHICH CAN GET THE JOB DONE. AND
THESE ARE MILLION DOLLAR PIECES
OF EQUIPMENT OR MORE THAT
SOMETIMES DON'T EVEN EXIST, AND
I DON'T WORK WELL IN COLD
CLIMATE AREAS, AND WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO GET THE ABILITY TO GET
SOME EXEMPTIONS TO OPERATE THESE
OTHER VEHICLES THAT THEY ALREADY
HAVE AND OWN FOR SHORT PERIODS
OF TIME. AND THERE'S BEEN SOME
CONSTERNATION DOING THAT. SO I
BELIEVE THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW US
TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION WHERE
WE NEED UM, TO HAVE SOME
EXEMPTIONS FOR NOT ONLY FOR THE
PUBLIC NOT TO HAVE TO PURCHASE
THESE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
TRANSPORTATION PROVIDERS FOR THE
PUBLIC OR HAVING TO COME UP WITH
THE RESOURCES TO BUY THESE
VEHICLES AND THEN PUT THE
SYSTEMS INTO CHARGE THEM AT THE
SAME TIME, THEY'RE NOT WORKING,
SO I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
OPPORTUNITY SOMEWHERE TO HAVE
SOME EXEMPTIONS THAT ARE JUST
COMMON SENSE EXEMPTIONS. FOR
THOSE SPECIALTY VEHICLES THAT
THE TECHNOLOGY HASN'T QUITE
CAUGHT UP WITH IF WE ACTUALLY
HAD HYDROGEN AVAILABLE FOR THOSE
VEHICLES, WE COULD SWITCH OUT
AND NOT HAVE TO CHARGE THEM AS
QUICK. BUT WE DON'T HAVE THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE TO US AS TV AND
IT'S NOT WORKING OUT WELL, SO I
JUST WANT TO GO ON RECORD TO LET
THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOME ALTERNATIVE TO
FORCING AGAIN. GETTING THE
PERFECT IN THE WAY OF THE GOOD
IS A PROBLEM FOR A LOT OF THESE
AREAS THROUGHOUT THE SIERRAS AND
THE SPECIALTY PIECES EQUIPMENT
THAT THE TECHNOLOGY IS NOT THERE
FOR OKAY? YEAH I MEAN, I THERE'S
A LONG LIST OF EXEMPTIONS THAT
ARE LISTED OUT ON PAGE FIVE OF
THE ANALYSIS THAT CARB HAS
WORKED ON. YOU KNOW FOR FLEETS,
WHEREAS AS AN OPTION AND SO
HAPPY TO, YOU KNOW, CARB IS
WANTS PEOPLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THESE. SO IF IT'S A MATTER OF
ADDING TO THE LIST ARE LOOKING
MORE CAREFULLY AT THE WAY THAT
IT'S CRAFTED, YOU KNOW,
CERTAINLY OPEN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS OPEN TO THE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY, YOU KNOW, I AM REALLY
WORRIED ABOUT TYING THE HANDS OF
CREATING MORE CHALLENGE FOR
CARBON DO. IT'S THE WORK THAT
WE'VE TASKED IT WITH. BUT LET ME
JUST ASK THE QUESTION. WHAT
PIECE OF EQUIPMENT AS DID I MAKE
THE STATEMENT RIGHT THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE THOSE TYPES OF PEACE
EQUIPMENT THAT THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWING YOU TO. THEY'RE FORCING
YOU. CAN YOU GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE?
BECAUSE WE CAN GET HIS GRAND ON
THAT LACK OF CONFIGURATION
AVAILABILITY AND DUTY CYCLES AND
BATTERY LIMITATIONS. YOU MIGHT
WANT TO GET SENATOR HELPED TO
WRITE HELPED CARB RIGHT THOSE
EXEMPTIONS WE SUBMITTED 38
PIECES OF EQUIPMENT
DESCRIPTIONS, PICTURES. JOBS
THEY DO AND SO FORTH. HOWEVER
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF A
VEHICLE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
THREE AXLE DAY CAB, WHICH YOU
CAN GO BY FROM KENWORTH OR
CASCADIA. YOU CAN BUY AN
ELECTRIC RIGHT NOW. YES IT'S
MORE EXPENSIVE. IT'S 2.8 TIMES
AS MUCH, HOWEVER Tð HOOK UP TO A
LOW BOY TRAILER TO HAUL OUR
ASPHALT GRINDER TO FIX OUR
ROADS. THE FRAME HAS TO BE CUT
AND WELDED AND MADE INTO A RAMP
INSTEAD OF A BOX. STAND FRAME TO
US. NOTHING YOU CAN BOLT ON. YOU
HAVE TO ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW. HE
CUT WORLD. AND SO I ASKED
KENWORTH. IF SO, IT'S NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR AN EXEMPTION
BECAUSE KENWORTH CAN SELL THE
TRUCK. HOWEVER WE CAN'T MODIFY
IT. KENWORTH HAS FOR SIX MONTHS
NOW. I'VE BEEN WAITING FOR THEM
THEIR ENGINEERS TO GET BACK TO
ME. TO LET ME KNOW IF WE HAVE TO
TAKE THE ELECTRIC MOTOR AND ALL
OF THE BATTERIES AND ALL OF THE,
UH, MODULES CONTROL MODULES OUT.
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT HEAVY
WELDING, UH SO THAT THEY DON'T
GET DESTROYED DURING THAT
PROCESS. SO I TALKED TO CARP AND
CARP SAID YOU DON'T NEED AN
EXEMPTION. JUST BUY A DIESEL FOR
NOW AND BY A LIGHTNING AND THAT
GIVES YOU YOUR 50. AH, SO I
THINK THAT'S UH NOT DOING US ANY
GOOD RIGHT THERE. SO IF YOU IF
THEY WERE TO DENY THAT EXEMPTION
AND WE COULD HAVE AN APPEALS
PROCESS FOR THAT. YEAH WELL,
LOOK, I MEAN, THAT SOUNDS LIKE A
CASE THAT WE NEED TO LOOK INTO
AND ENGAGE WITH IT. AND BY THE
WAY, IT SOUNDS PRETTY BAD FOR
KENWORTH NOT TO BE RESPONDING
WHEN THEY'VE GOT SUCH A VESTED
INTEREST IN THIS KIND OF THING
RESOLVED, BUT SORT OF CREATE
THIS MAN. YOU KNOW THIS WHOLE,
UM IT SEEMS THAT THAT THAT THAT
WE COULD. THAT'S THE KIND OF
ISSUE THAT CAN AND SHOULD BE
RESOLVED THROUGH A DIFFERENT
MECHANISM THAN CREATING A WHOLE
NEW APPEALS PROCESS, BUT, UM
THAT'S WHERE I AM I YOU KNOW, I
DON'T I DON'T DISCOUNT THE NEED
TO GET THAT KIND OF CHALLENGE
ADDRESSED. IF I MIGHT OFFER LESS
GRANULAR INSIGHT ON THIS FIRST
OF ALL, WHO AM I REPRESENTING
HERE? I'M REPRESENTING FLEET
MANAGERS. THEY'RE NOT POLITICAL.
THEY WANT TO JUST BE ABLE TO
DELIVER THE ESSENTIAL SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED TO DELIVER TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES, WHATEVER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES MAY BE THE GOAL TO
ME HAVE ANY REGULATION IS 100%
COMPLIANCE? WE HAVE BEEN
EXPRESSING GRANULAR EXAMPLES
LIKE THIS COOPERATIVELY WITH
CARBS SINCE BEFORE THIS EVEN WAS
ON THE TABLE, AND WE CONTINUE TO
DO IT ON A REGULAR BASIS. AND IT
YOU THIS INFORMATION NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. I ACTUALLY THINK MORE
INFORMATION. WE'LL ALLOW FOR
MORE CLARITY FOR POSSIBLE
COMPLIANCE, AND THAT'S THE GOAL
OF A REGULATION 100% COMPLIANCE.
I RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH THE
DELAY IN THIS, WE'RE NOT TAKING
AWAY FROM THEIR JURISDICTION.
THEY DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE TO PAY
ATTENTION. BUT IF I WAS INTERNAL
DOING GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS WITH
CARB, I WOULD SAY, YOU KNOW,
THIS COULD HELP YOU BECAUSE YOU
ONLY HAVE YOUR SLICE. WE'RE
BRINGING ALL THE KEY
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE,
INCLUDING THE OEMS THAT CAN TELL
YOU THAT A CHASSIS FOR A
PARTICULAR CONFIGURATION IS NOT
EVEN ON THE R AND D PHASE
AMONGST ANY OF THE E V. O E. M
S. SO OKAY. WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
THROW BOMBS WERE ACTUALLY I
THINK TRYING TO IMPROVE A CF.
APPRECIATE THAT A GREAT DEAL
JUST TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE. WE
DID PASS EDDIE GARCIA, XABI 1594
LAST YEAR, WHICH WHICH DID FIX
TO SPECIFIC APPLICATIONS OF
EXEMPTIONS. SO I MEAN, SO
ANYWAY, LET ME JUST SAY I'M I'M
NOT COMFORTABLE SUPPORTING
BUILDING. LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS
WITH THE VOTES THAT IF IT DOES
NOT PASS, I DO PERSONALLY COMMIT
MYSELF TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE PROPONENTS AND
THE STAFF TO SIT DOWN WITH CARB
AND TRY TO GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
DEEP IN THE WEEDS ON THESE KINDS
OF CHALLENGES THAT YOU'RE
RUNNING INTO. I APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH TO BE RESPONSIVE,
RIGHT? I MEAN, YOU KNOW THEY'VE
GOT A JOB TO DO. WE'VE TASKED
WITH THAT JOB. IT'S A VERY
SECRET JOB AND SOMETHING THAT WE
BELIEVE IN DEEPLY AND THIS
COMMITTEE AND YET WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE WORKING WITH
THE FOLKS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
HANDLING THE FLEET ON THE
GROUND. APPRECIATE THAT THE
STATE SO, UM SO, UH, SO I DON'T
I DON'T WANT MY LACK OF SUPPORT
FOR THIS PARTICULAR APPROACH TO
SUGGEST A LACK OF INTEREST IN
GETTING THESE KINDS OF
CHALLENGES RESOLVED BUT
CERTAINLY HAPPY FOR MEMBERS TO
SUPPORT THE BILL IF THEY SO
DESIRE. UM ANYHOW, LET'S THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED UNLESS THERE'S
ANOTHER COMMENTS LOVE TO GIVE
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE
YEAH. OKAY THANK YOU. FOR THE
FOR THE, UM EXAMPLE. AND I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT THE ONLY PEOPLE
THAT ARE FORCED TO DO THIS OUR
PUBLIC FLEETS RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
FORCED TO HAVE TO BUY
ELECTRICITY. I'M IN THE TRUCKING
BUSINESS. I HAVE A 359 PETERBILT
WITH 600 HORSE. CUMMINGS IN IT,
AND I HAVE RAMPS ON IT SO I CAN
HOLD THIS THING. I'M NOT FORCED
TO DO IT. PUBLIC FLEETS ARE
FORCED TO DO IT AND THE CAUSE
THIS IS FOR ME. IT'S LIKE WE
TALKED ABOUT COSTS IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF WHY OF MY 15 COUNTIES
. MOST OF THEM ARE VERY RULE,
AND THEY'RE FORCED TO HAVE TO
BUY THESE TRUCKS THAT DON'T
WORK. AND THEY CAN'T DO IT. THEY
CAN'T DO IT. AND WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA DO? YOU'RE STUCK IN A SPOT
WHERE YOU HAVE SOMETHING THAT
WORKS AND YOU'RE FORCED TO BUY
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T WORK OR
DOESN'T EXIST, AND SOMEHOW WE
HAVE TO GIVE THESE PEOPLE THAT
ARE PUBLIC AGENCIES HAVE SOME
FREEDOM AND TELL THE TECHNOLOGY
COMES AND TELL KENWORTH
PETERBILT OR SOMEBODY DOES THE
WORK AND WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE
THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE IN A BOX,
AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK THE
SENATORS TRYING TO BRING FORTH.
WE NEED SOME COMMON SENSE HERE
FOR CRYING OUT LOUD DRIVE THE
COST DOWN AND WHEN THE
TECHNOLOGY IS THERE WILL GET
THEIR THEIR THESE GENTLEMEN ARE
ACTUALLY WORKING WITH THEM. I
THINK THERE'S DEFINITELY AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE SOMEWHERE.
BECAUSE I KNOW THE PRIVATE SIDE.
I'LL NEVER DO IT. I DON'T HAVE
TO BECAUSE I CAN'T AFFORD TO.
AND IT JUST DOESN'T WORK. BUT
THE PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT WE
REPRESENT THE COUNTIES AND
CITIES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
IN A BOX AND I HEAR IT FROM MY
SNOW REMOVAL. PEOPLE ALL
THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR'S WHO ARE
FORCED TO BUY BATTERY OPERATED
SNOWBLOWERS THAT DON'T EXIST OR
DON'T WORK FOR MORE THAN FOUR
HOURS AT A TIME. OKAY SOMEWHERE.
WE GOTTA GET IT RIGHT. THE
ISSUE'S BEEN MOVED. I AM LET'S
ALL LET'S ALL GET TOGETHER. TALK
ABOUT IT. I'M SERIOUSLY I AM
VERY INTERESTED IN AND OPEN TO
IT. PLEASE CALL ROB. I'M SORRY.
SORRY. YEAH. I'M SORRY. SORRY
YEAH. THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS. SO UM, I HEARD
WHAT I HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION
IS THAT THIS WILL UNNECESSARILY
DELAY THINGS. IT WILL COMPLICATE
THE REVIEW PROCESS. IT WILL
ULTIMATELY UNDERCUT THE
REGULATION. AND WHAT WE'VE GOT
IS FLEXIBLE ENOUGH, AND I WOULD
JUST SUGGEST THAT PERHAPS THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
LEGISLATION PROPOSES, AND THAT
IS AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE. IT
WON'T AFFECT THE REVIEW AT ALL.
THE ADVICE WILL COME AFTER THE
REVIEW AND A DECISION THAT'S
BEEN MADE BASED UPON THE REVIEW.
THAT WAS NEGATIVE TO THE ENTITY
THAT WAS SEEKING THE EXCEPTION.
IT DOESN'T AFFECT THE DELAY AT
ALL. IT DOESN'T HAVE TO. IT
DOESN'T AFFECT THE REVIEW AT ALL
. EXCUSE ME, AND IT DOESN'T IT
CERTAINLY IS NOT UNDERCUTTING
THIS BODY DOES NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO MAKE DECISIONS OR IN
ANY WAY AFFECT THE REGULATION OR
IN ANY WAY FORCE AN EXCEPTION
AND THE UNNECESSARY DELAY. WELL
CARB DOESN'T EVEN HAVE TO LISTEN
TO THEM. IT'S ADVISORY ONLY, AND
I'D ALSO POINT OUT AS I DID IN
MY TESTIMONY INITIALLY, BUT THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY HAS AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. THE OSHA HAS AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE HAS AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY, UH,
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT HAS AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. I WILL TELL
YOU THAT. PROBABLY 20% OF THE
MEETINGS THAT I'VE HAD SO FAR
THIS YEAR. WITH CONSTITUENTS AND
OTHERS. HAS DEALT WITH THIS VERY
ISSUE. UM SPECIAL DISTRICTS
CITIES. COUNTIES. PRIVATE
COMPANIES. DEALERS IT IS A BROAD
AND WIDE INTEREST OF PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTOR ENTITIES THAT ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THE REGULATION IS AHEAD OF
THE TECHNOLOGY, AND THEY DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S GOING TO STILL BE
THE CASE WHEN THE REQUIREMENT
HITS A CLIFF, IF YOU WILL. AND
WHAT THEY'RE REALLY SAYING IS
THEY'RE BEGGING THEY'RE PLAYING.
WE NEED TO HAVE CERTAINTY THAT
WE ARE GOING TO MEET THE
REGULATION AND BY THE WAY,
NOBODY HAS SAID TO ME THAT THEY
DISAGREE WITH IT. WHETHER THEY
DO OR NOT, THEY DON'T STATE IT
THAT WAY. THEY ARE VERY
CONCERNED THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE FORCED INTO DO SOMETHING AS
SENATOR DOLLY WAS EXPLAINING
THAT THEY CAN'T MEET NOW I NO
CARB HAS TO KNOW. THAT THE
REGULATION IS IN ADVANCE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY. IT'S PLAYING FOR
EVERYBODY TO SEE. BUT THIS IS
NOT UNCOMMON. AH BACK WHEN, UH
EMISSION CONTROLS WERE FIRST
IMPOSED ON THE ON THE PASSENGER
AUTOMOBILES IN THE EARLY
SEVENTIES, WHEN I WAS JUST
ENTERING THE RETAIL CAR
BUSINESS. THE REGULATION WAS WAY
IN ADVANCE OF THE AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY, AND I WILL TELL YOU
WE HAD A NIGHTMARE IN OUR
SERVICE DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE THE
MANUFACTURERS COULD NOT MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS WITHOUT PRODUCING
CARS THAT WERE HORRIBLY
UNRELIABLE. SO THIS IS NOT AN
UNCOMMON APPROACH IN THE
REGULATORY FIELD. AND IN OTHER
CASES WHEN CARB HAS BEEN AHEAD
OF TECHNOLOGY AND THEIR
REGULATION THEY HAVE BACKED OFF
WHEN THEY GET CLOSE TO THE
DEADLINE, AND I WOULD ASSUME
THAT THIS WOULD HAPPEN HERE. BUT
I WILL TELL YOU THE USERS.
SPECIAL DISTRICTS, THE CITIES,
THE COUNTY'S THE PRIVATE FLEET
OPERATORS, DEALERS, ETCETERA.
THAT'S NOT VERY MUCH COMFORT TO
THEM. AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE
WOULD AT LEAST HAVE THEM ALLOW
THEM A MOUTHPIECE AND THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF A REGULATION
INVOLVES THE PARTICIPATION. BOTH
OF THE REGULATOR AS WELL AS THE
REGULAR T. AND SO FAR, WE DO NOT
HAVE THE COMFORT OF THE
REGULATOR, REGULAR T THAT THIS
IS THAT THIS CAN BE MADE, AND
THIS WOULD PROVIDE AT LEAST SOME
COMFORT TO THEM, SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LOOK FORWARD
TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS THAT
ITEMS SPEND MOVED BY THE VICE
CHAIR. YEAH. SB 1393. THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AND RE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
SENATORS ALLEN DOLLY DIÆN
GONZALES GONZALES KNOW HER
TAITO. FINE. HER TAITO I
MENJIVAR WHEN I WHEN I SKINNER
OKAY, THANK YOU. AND THAT'S
YEAH. THROUGH ONE WILL CAUSE THE
ROLE ON THAT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR WOULD REQUEST RE
CLINTON CONSIDERATION IF YOU'RE
WILLING TO TALK ABOUT IT A
LITTLE. OBJECTION. YEAH. UM
THANK YOU. OKAY LET'S HEAR FROM
SENATOR NEWMAN. AS J. R 13 ITEM
ONE. YOU MENTIONED WE HAVE
BECAUSE HE'S YOU KNOW. OKAY
SENATOR MAY PURSUE WHEN WITH ALL
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, MR.
SOMEDAY YOU WILL BE IN THE
SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
CHAIRMAN HALL OF FAME. I WOULD
HOPE SO FORWARD TO THE CEREMONY.
I AM PLEASED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT STR 13
BEFORE I BEGIN. LET ME MAKE
CLEAR THAT I'M ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENT SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION BEFORE YOUR
URGES THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS
AND PRESIDENT BRIAN TO
APPROPRIATE $100 MILLION IN
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING TO ADDRESS
ONGOING IMPACT ON PUBLIC HEALTH,
THE ENVIRONMENT, THE LOCAL
ECONOMY THEY WERE CAUSED BY
DAMAGE AND FALLOUT ASSOCIATED
WITH A RECENT MASSIVE FIRE AT
THE FORMER MARINE CORPS AIR
STATION IN THE CITY OF TUSTIN
ALSO CALLS ON THE PRESIDENT TO
DECLARE A NATIONAL EMERGENCY. IN
RESPONSE TO THE ONGOING IMPACTS
THE FIRE AS MY WITNESS WILL
EXPLAIN. THE NAVY NORTH HANGER
FIRE HAS HAD A DEVASTATING
IMPACT ON THE CITY OF TUSTIN AND
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY BOTH
FINANCIALLY AND ENVIRONMENTALLY.
THE FALLOUT FROM THE BLAZE HAS
LEFT THE CITY GRAPPLING WITH AN
UNPRECEDENTED FINANCIAL BURDEN
AS EMERGENCY EXPENSES HAVE WELL
SURPASSED 100 100% OF THE ANNUAL
BUDGET FOR THE COMING YEAR. THE
FALLOUT FROM THE FIREBOAT,
LITERAL AND FIGURATIVE REMAINS A
SOURCE OF FRUSTRATION AND
CONCERN IN THE COMMUNITY. SO FAR
THE CITY HAS INCURRED OVER $80
MILLION IN CLEAN UP COSTS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE NAVY HAS BEEN
A GOOD PARTNERS SO FAR, BUT THE
SCALE AND EXPENSIVE THE CLEANUP,
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
CITY'S FAIRLY LIMITED RESOURCES,
SPEAKS TO THE NEED FOR
FORMALIZING THE REQUESTED
FEDERAL SUPPORT AND A DISASTER
DECLARATION. STR 13 URGES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SUPPORT THE
PRESSING NEEDS CREATED BY THE
DAMAGE CAUSED BY THE FIRE HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SCR 13
IS TESTING CITY MANAGER NICOLE
BERNARD. I AM RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE. CHAIRMAN ALAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS NICOLE
BERNARD. I AM THE ACTING CITY
MANAGER FOR TEST IN AND ON
BEHALF OF THE MAYOR AND COUNCIL
WHO COULD NOT JOIN ME TODAY.
THEY DO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU TODAY. I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO
THINK SENATOR NEWMAN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND OUT OF RESPECT
FOR EVERYONE'S TIME. I WILL TRY
TO BE AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE TO
EXPLAIN THE STORY. NOVEMBER 7TH
2023 IS WHEN THE FIRE BROKE OUT
AT THE NAVY'S NORTH HANGAR,
WHICH IS ONE OF TWO HISTORIC
HANGARS AT THE FORMER MARINE
CORPS. AIR BASE STATION.
INTESTINE DECOMMISSIONED IN 1999
AND HAS BEEN REDEVELOPED
PRIMARILY BY THE CITY, WHICH IS
A FEDERAL LOOK. RIOS AUTHORITY
DESIGNATION. FOR THOSE WHO MAY
NOT BE FAMILIAR WITH THE ACTUAL
DIMENSIONS OF THE HANGERS. I
JUST WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT AND
CLARIFY THAT THESE STRUCTURES
BOTH OF THEM ARE 17 STORIES TALL
. THERE ARE 1000 FT, LONG AND
300 FT WIDE AND BY THE MATH
THAT'S ALMOST SIX ACRES OF A
WOODEN BUILDING STRUCTURE EACH,
SO IT IS QUITE A SIGNIFICANT, UM
UH, BUILDING THE FIRE BURNED FOR
24 DAYS, AND THERE WERE SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT OUR CITY THAT WERE
CLOSED PARKS THAT WERE CLOSED
THE CITY AND THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS STILL CLEARED LOCAL
EMERGENCIES, AND IT WAS A VERY
DISRUPTIVE SITUATION FOR OUR
ENTIRE COMMUNITY. VERY UM,
UNCERTAIN TIME DURING THOSE 24
DAYS WHERE WE WERE AWARE THAT
THERE WAS ASBESTOS DEBRIS THAT
WAS COMING FROM THE FIRE.
FORTUNATELY THE AIR QUALITY
REMAINED HEALTHY. IT WAS JUST
THE DEBRIS IN CONTACT WITH THE
DEBRIS IS WHAT PEOPLE WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT, AND IT WAS A
WIDESPREAD FALL OUT OF THE
DEBRIS OVER 6.5 SQUARE MILES
WERE IMPACTED 14,000 RESIDENTS
SO THE NAVY ASKED THE CITY TO
TAKE OVER THE RESPONSE EFFORT
BECAUSE IT'S A DECOMMISSIONED
SITE. THERE WAS NO ACTIVE NAVY
TO BE OF ASSISTANCE, THE CITY
AGREED TO TAKE THAT ON FOR ITS
RESIDENTS, AND WE'VE INCURRED
SIGNIFICANT EXPENSES THAT EXCEED
OUR OPERATING BUDGET. WITH THAT
WE DO REQUEST THAT YOU ALL ACT
TO ASK CONGRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT TO PROVIDE
SUPPLEMENTAL FEDERAL FUNDING TO
ASSIST THE NAVY AND REIMBURSING
THE CITY. IN THIS RESPONSE, I
JUST WANT TO ADD THAT THIS IS AN
ONGOING SITUATION. THERE IS
STILL DEBRIS THAT THE CITY IS
ACTIVELY CLEANING UP. THIS IS
NOT A THERE HAS BEEN NO END TO
THIS YET. WITH THAT I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. ANYONE
ELSE WHO WANTS TO VOICE SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL? OPPOSITION? LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS, THOUGHTS.
COMMENTS MOVED BY SENATOR
MENJIVAR THANK YOU FOR COMING
AND BRINGING ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE. LET'S CALL THE ROLL. YES,
SIR. YOU DIDN'T APPRECIATE THE
WINNERS BEING HERE THESE BY THE
WAY. THESE ARE TWO OF THE
LARGEST WOODEN STRUCTURES IN THE
WORLD AND THE WIRING WAS FULL OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES. $80 MILLION
THUS FAR, PROBABLY $50 MILLION
IN ADDITIONAL COST. LOOKING
FORWARD, WE NEED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SUPPORT TO ADDRESS
THE SITUATION, SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. MOVE BY. SENTIMENT WORK
THIS COLOR ALL YES, J. R S J. R
13. THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS ALLEN DALLI DALLI, AYE,
GONZALES GONZALES. I HEARD TATO.
HER TATO I MENJIVAR MENJIVAR. I
WIN WHEN I SKINNER SKINNER I
SEVEN. OKAY AT 70 CLOSE THE
ROLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WITHOUT OBJECTION. LET'S GO TO
SENATOR GONZALEZ, WHO IS HERE?
WHO WANTS TO PRESENT SB 1308?
THAT'S ITEM 13. IN YOUR AGENDAS
ITEM 13 RELATING TO INDOOR AIR
CLEANING DEVICES. WATCH OUT
BOGUS HERE, TOO. OKAY SHE'S GOT
OKAY. I HAVE A WIT. OKAY LET'S
PROCEED. I DIDN'T SEE YOU. BUT
I'M SORRY. I KNOW WE HAVE
WITNESSES. GOD SHOULD BE REALLY
QUICK BILL. IF THAT'S OKAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU. LET'S
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND, UM, I AM HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE BILL 13
8, WHICH WILL ENSURE THAT INDOOR
AIR CLEANING DEVICES CONTINUED
TO SERVE THEIR INTENDED PURPOSE
OF IMPROVING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS LIVING
WITH RESPIRATORY CONDITIONS.
WITH THE SURGE OF COVID 19 AND
WORSENING IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND AIR POLLUTION,
THERE'S BEEN A GROWING INTEREST
IN IMPROVING INDOOR AIR QUALITY
AIR CLEANERS ARE INEFFICIENT
TOOLS PROVEN TO PROVE THIS AIR
QUALITY, HELPING PEOPLE WITH
ASTHMA AND OTHER RESPIRATORY
DISEASES. AND UNFORTUNATELY,
ELECTRONIC AIR CLEANERS RELY ON
TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN PRODUCE
OZONE OR OTHER BY PRODUCTS
HARMFUL TO HEALTH AND A RECENT
PAPER, PUBLISHED BY UC DAVIS AND
SPONSORED BY CARB FOUND CONCERNS
ABOUT THE HEALTH EFFECTS OF
ELECTRONIC AIR CLEANERS AND HOW
THEY CREATE OZONE RESEARCH.
FOUND ANY MORE STRINGENT. I WAS
ON EMISSION STANDARD OF FIVE
PARTS PER BILLION CAN HELP
REDUCE THIS SECONDARY BYPRODUCT
FORMATION DRIVEN BY OZONE
CHEMISTRY. SP 1308 WILL ADDRESS
THIS RISK. AND TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE TODAY,
AND KELSEY LAMB, DIRECTOR OF THE
REGIONAL ASTHMA MANAGEMENT AND
PREVENTION, AND TERESA PISTA
GINI, CO DIRECTOR OF ENGINEERING
AT THE UC DAVIS ENERGY
EFFICIENCY INSTITUTE, AND
WESTERN COOLING EFFICIENCY
CENTER TO ASSIST I RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR AN I VOTE. THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED. DREAM CHAIR
REMEMBERS. I AM AN KELSEY LAMB,
THE DIRECTOR OF REGIONAL ASTHMA
MANAGEMENT AND PREVENTION, A
PROJECT OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE, AIR POLLUTION AND ITS
JUST PROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAS LONG
BEEN ONE OF OUR TOP CONCERNS AS
IT CAN BOTH EXACERBATE AND CAUSE
ASTHMA. IN RECENT YEARS, THE
GROWING PROBLEM OF WILDFIRE
SMOKE HAS ADDED TO THE URGENT
NEED TO FIND WAYS FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
TO BREATHE CLEAN AIR. PORTABLE
AIR CLEANERS CAN HELP REDUCE THE
IMPACT OF AIR POLLUTION IN
RESPONSE TO THE GROWING THREAT,
AIR DISTRICTS, PORTS, HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS AND OTHER AGENCIES
HAVE BEGUN PROVIDING PORTABLE
AIR CLEANERS TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE AT
INCREASED RISK FROM EXPOSURE TO
AIR POLLUTION, INCLUDING PEOPLE
WITH ASTHMA. THIS INCREASE IN
THE USE OF AIR CLEANERS AMONG
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS MAKES IT
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO ENSURE
THAT THE AIR CLEANERS THEY'RE
USING ARE SAFE. UNFORTUNATELY
SOME AIR CLEANERS ACTUALLY
WORSEN INDOOR AIR QUALITY BY
EMITTING OZONE. CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES SUPPORT ALL PORTABLE
AIR CLEANERS SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
TO MEET AN OZONE EMISSION LIMIT
OF 50 PARTS PER BILLION. HOWEVER
SINCE THE ORIGINAL LAW WENT INTO
PLACE, SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT EVEN EXTREMELY
LOW LEVELS OF OZONE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS. SP 1308 WILL ADDRESS
THAT. IT WON'T CHANGE ANYTHING
ABOUT WHICH DEVICES CARB
REGULATES. IT'S SIMPLY REDUCES
THE ALLOWABLE OZONE LEVEL FROM
50 PARTS PER BILLION TO FIVE. IT
WILL ALIGN CALIFORNIA'S AIR
CLEANER REGULATION WITH CURRENT
SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION TO
PROTECT AND PROMOTE THE HEALTH
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS. THANK YOU. HELLO I AM
TERESA PISTA KEANEY, A
RESEARCHER AT UC DAVIS AND CO
AUTHOR OF A WHITE PAPER WRITTEN
FOR CARB THAT RECOMMENDED
CALIFORNIA REQUIRE ELECTRONIC
AIR CLEANERS COMPLY WITH U L
2998 MORE STRINGENT OZONE
EMISSION STANDARD OF FIVE PARTS
PER BILLION PPB. THE MAIN SOURCE
OF OZONE AND BUILDINGS IS FROM
OUTDOORS. THE FEDERAL REGULATION
FOR OUTDOOR OZONE IS 70 PPB, AND
MORE THAN HALF OF CALIFORNIANS
LIVE IN AREAS THAT EXCEED THE
STANDARD. ALLOWING DEVICES ON
OUR BUILDINGS THAT PRODUCE
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF OZONE
INCREASE EXPOSURE ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT IS ALREADY
TRANSFERRED FROM OUTDOORS,
WORKING AGAINST DECADES OF
EFFORT TO REDUCE OZONE IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR BACKGROUND YOU
ALL TO 998 MEASURES OZONE
EMISSIONS FROM ONE DEVICE IN A
TEST CHAMBER. WELL BUILDING
DESIGN ADVICE. INSTALLATION
AFFECT ACTUAL OZONE LEVELS.
LET'S ASSUME FOR SIMPLICITY THAT
A DEVICE PASSING YOU ALL TO 9898
WILL RAISE THE CONCENTRATION,
ACTUAL BUILDING BY FIVE PARTS
PER BILLION FOR REFERENCE THE
STUDY I LED IN 2018 IN
CALIFORNIA CLASSROOMS MEASURED
AVERAGE INDOOR OZONE
CONCENTRATIONS OF 8 TO 15 PARTS
PER BILLION. WHICH WAS ABOUT 30%
OF OUTDOORS IN THIS CASE, ADDING
JUST FIVE PPB FROM AN AIR
CLEANER WHEN INCREASED OZONE
LEVELS BY 30 TO 60. THE CURRENT
CARD REGULATION, WHICH ALLOWS
EMISSIONS OF 250 PPB PERMITS
EXTREME INCREASES IN INDOOR
OZONE. I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
OPPOSITION FROM RESEARCHERS AND
MANUFACTURERS WORKING ON
EMERGING 222 NANOMETER UV
TECHNOLOGY FOR THE PURPOSES OF
PATHOGEN MITIGATION.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS WAVELENGTH OF
LIGHT ALSO GENERATES OZONE.
BASED ON MY LITERATURE REVIEW,
IT IS POSSIBLE TO DESIGN THIS
TECHNOLOGY TO MEET THE UL 298
STANDARD BY ADJUSTING LAMP POWER
AND WAVELENGTH FILTERING. IT
WOULD BE FORWARD THINKING TO
CONTINUE TO COVER UV TECHNOLOGY
IN THE PROPOSED LEGISLATION,
ENSURING THAT MANUFACTURERS
DESIGN UV TO LIMIT OZONE
PRODUCTION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. OTHERS WISHING
TO SUPPORT HERE IN 1200. HELLO
I'M GABRIELLE GABRIELLE CLAN WAX
, SPEAKING FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH
NONPROFIT ONE DAY SOONER. UM AND
WE TAKE AN IN BETWEEN POSITION
OR SUPPORT IF AMENDED, SO AS TO
EXEMPT TECHNOLOGIES WHOSE HEALTH
BENEFITS OUTWEIGH THEIR COSTS
DUE TO EFFICIENCY AT PATHOGEN
REMOVAL. THANK YOU. OH, THIS
ONE. MAKING SOME WAY. RETIRED
NURSE AND UM, PERSON WITH ASTHMA
IN SUPPORT. POSITION.
OPPOSITION. OKAY? OH THIS IS
SUPPORTING. THIS IS ALL SUPPORT.
YEAH. HI ARIANNA CREED WITH
CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS DOT ORG AND
SUPPORT ALSO THOSE IN SUPPORT
OUR CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL, HEALTH AND
JUSTICE, FACTS, GRANDPARENTS AND
ACTION MAMA'S NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE INTERFAITH
COALITION FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND N. C. C. C. A THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THEY'RE A LITTLE
WITHIN OUR D C AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I AM KEVIN
MESSNER WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
HOME APPLIANCE MANUFACTURERS. WE
REPRESENT RESIDENTIAL AIR
CLEANERS. I DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THIS, BUT I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT WE
SUPPORT THE OBJECTIVES AND
UNDERSTAND THE INTENT TO REDUCE
HOME ZONE DOWN 50 PARTS PER
MILLION TO FIVE WANT TO WORK
THROUGH SOME DETAILS, BUT THE
KIND OF THRUST OF THE BILL MAKES
SENSE TO US, BUT WE DO HAVE
SOMETHING. WE WANT TO WORK WITH
THE LEADER'S OFFICE WITHIN THE
COMMITTEE AND YOU ARE SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY ALRIGHT.
OPPOSITION YOU WANTED TO RAISE
SOME CONCERNS. YES. THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING. MY NAME IS HARDER
. CLOSE I'M CALIFORNIA CITIZEN
AND ALSO AN EXPERT IN GERMAN
SEIDEL, UV AND ESPECIALLY IN FOR
UBC TECHNOLOGY. AND I ALSO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION AND VARIOUS
MANUFACTURERS OF FOUR U. V C
DEVICES. WE ARE VERY DEEPLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE NEW OZONE
LIMITS BECAUSE THEY WOULD
ACCIDENTALLY OR INTENTIONALLY.
CRIMINALIZE OR PREVENT THE USE
OF FOR UBC DEVICES IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY NOT WIDELY USED. A
LOT OF RESEARCH IS STILL GOING
ON, BUT IT IS VERY CLEAR FROM
THE SCIENTIFIC FACTS THAT IT IS
A VERY EFFECTIVE TECHNOLOGY TO
PREVENT AH! INFECTIONS AND IT
CAN BE USED IN OCCUPIED SPACES.
IT UH ACCIDENTALLY FALLS UNDER
COP WHICH CONSIDERS THESE
DISINFECTION DEVICES AIR
CLEANERS. FOR YOUR INFORMATION
SUCH A FOUR YEAR BC DEVICE HAS
ABOUT THE SIZE OF ONE OF THESE
LAMPS HERE HAS NO RESEMBLANCE OF
AN AIR CLEANER. AND IT DOES NOT
REMOVE ANY PARTICLES FROM THE
AIR. IT ONLY KILLS GERMS IN THE
AIR. JUST FOUR WEEKS AGO, I WAS
A PENALTY SPEAKER AT THE
WORKSHOP IN WASHINGTON, D. C.
AND I WANT TO INFORM YOU THAT
RIGHT NOW. CDC EPA, D O AND D O
D. SHOW INTEREST AND SEE
POTENTIAL IN THIS TECHNOLOGY.
AMONG THE INTERESTS OR THE
POTENTIAL TO MITIGATE FUTURE
PANDEMICS. BIOTERRORISM
BIOWARFARE IS TAX AND INCREASED
PROTECTION OF ESSENTIAL
STRATEGIC ASSETS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE UNITED
STATES. UNFORTUNATELY AS YOU
ALREADY HEARD, THIS TECHNOLOGY
CREATES LITTLE AMOUNTS OF OZONE.
TYPICAL DEVICES EMIT ABOUT 8 TO
20 PPB OF OZONE. SO ALL THE
DEVICES TODAY PASSED COP EASILY
BUT THEY WOULD ALL BE OUTLAWED.
UH IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
PROHIBITING THE USE OF FOUR YOU
RECEIVE IN CALIFORNIA WOULD
BASICALLY KILL LATER ON
RESIDENTS BECAUSE THE RESIDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA WOULD BE
PREVENTED. TO BE PROTECTED AND
THERE IS VARIOUS OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY INVESTIGATED.
THERE IS A LOT OF HOSPITAL
ACQUIRED INFECTIONS THAT CAN BE
PREVENTED WITH THE TECHNOLOGY. I
BEG YOU. I URGE YOU NOT TO
PROCEED WITH THIS BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM AND FIND WAYS AND
WORK WITH THE EXPERTS TO AMEND
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TO ECHO SMALLHOLDERS
STATEMENTS. MY NAME IS ALEX
FARRAN, BIOCHEMIST AND
TOXICOLOGISTS WORKING RIGHT NOW,
WITH A LOT OF HOSPITALS AND
INFECTION CONTROL EXPERTS FROM
THE VIENNA TO YALE TO THE
CLEVELAND CLINIC AND ALL SEEING
TREMENDOUS IMPACT THE DEVICES
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON. NOT
CREATED SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
INTEREST OF AIR FILTRATION, BUT
RATHER AS, UH, SIMILAR
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S ALREADY USED,
WHICH IS A LOT OF UV IS ALREADY
USED IN HEALTHCARE FACILITIES,
BUT THE FORMATS ACTUALLY SAFE
FOR OCCUPIED SPACES AND TO
SUPPRESS PATHOGENS, BASICALLY IN
REAL TIME, SO WE DON'T NOT
SUPPORT CLEAN AIR, AND, UM, THE
GOAL TO IMPROVE THESE AIR
CLEANERS THAT DO RELEASE OZONE.
HOWEVER WE THINK WE SHOULD LOOK
AT THE ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH IS
USED IN A HOSPITAL. YOU OFTEN
HAVE 4 TO 6 ACTUALLY SIX AIR
EXCHANGES PER HOUR AS A MINIMUM
AND THAT WOULD MITIGATE ANY OF
THE OZONE PRODUCED. AND IN FACT,
IT'S IRONIC THAT IF YOU OPEN THE
WINDOW, YOU WOULD ACTUALLY
EXCEED THE LEVELS THAT ARE
PROPOSED BY THIS BILL. SO WHAT
WE PROPOSE OR AMENDMENTS TO WORK
OUT HOW WE CAN APPLY THIS
PROMISING TECHNOLOGY AND
HEALTHCARE HOSPITALS AND FOR
ALSO FOR PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, OKAY.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION? OKAY?
THANK YOU. UM LET'S GIVE THE IF
YOU WANT TO THE AUTHOR, I KNOW
SOME OF THIS OPPOSITION WAS
LATE, THOUGH. CERTAINLY THAT
THERE THIS IS FIRST COMMITTEE
AND THERE'S SOME CONCERN. I KNOW
YOU ARE DOING SOME WORK WITH AND
IF YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE WE WILL CONTINUE WORKING
WITH EVERYONE, BUT I THINK EVEN
JUST FIVE PPB ADDITIONAL IS
HARMFUL. SO WE'RE BASING THIS
OFF OF 2006 LAW THAT WAS
AUTHORED BY THEN SENATOR FRAN
PAVLEY. SO I THINK IT'S TIME TO
UPDATE THIS, AND THERE IS A
SUBSTANTIAL HEALTH RESEARCH. BUT
IF MY WITNESSES WOULD LIKE TO
ADD TO THAT THAT WOULD BE GREAT
TOGETHER WITH THEM. WITH THE
OPPOSITION. UM WELL, I'VE MET
WITH WITH I MET WITH ONE WITH
WE'VE EVER HAD ABOUT THREE
MEETINGS. I WAS IN ONE OF THEM
WITH DIFFERENT MEMBERS THAT ARE
CONCERNED SPECIFICALLY ON THE
ISSUE. VC YES. UM I THINK THE
BIG CONCERN IS THAT THE FEDERAL
THE OUTDOOR ALL THE EPIDEMIOLOGY
STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN DONE THAT
HAVE SET OUTDOOR LIMITS ON
OZONE. I PRESUME THAT THE MAIN
SELLERS OF OZONE INDOORS COMES
FROM OUTDOORS, RIGHT? AND SO
THAT WE KIND OF GENERALLY LIVE
IN CALIFORNIA AND THIS, YOU KNOW
8 TO 20 PPB INSIDE ALREADY BASED
ON THESE FEDERAL HEALTH UPON
THIS FEDERAL AIR QUALITY
LEGISLATION. SO IF ALL OF A
SUDDEN WE START PRODUCING
EXCESSIVE AMOUNTS OF OZONE
INDOORS, RIGHT, THE HEALTH UH,
IMPACTS FROM THAT COULD BE QUITE
SIGNIFICANT. AND I DON'T EVEN
THINK WE CAN TOTALLY UNDERSTAND
THAT. SO ANYWAY, I, UH I WOULD
MY POSITION TALKING TO THE
OPPOSITION IS THAT THIS IS A
THIS WOULD BE AN IMPORTANT
STANDARD TO MEET THE FIVE PARTS
PER BILLION AND ESSENTIALLY TO
DESIGN AROUND THAT TO BALANCE
PATH AGAIN. MITIGATION WITH
OZONE PRODUCTION, ESSENTIALLY
OKAY? QUESTIONS, THOUGHTS.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. HE
CONCERNS OR THINGS PEOPLE WANT
TO RAISE. OKAY I APPRECIATE THE
WORK ON THIS AND I KNOW THERE'S
GOING TO BE SOME MORE WORK TO BE
DONE. AND I'M SURE THERE'S GONNA
BE SOME OF THESE FACILITIES ARE
GOING TO WEIGH IN. BUT YOU KNOW,
WE ALL KNOW WE GOT MAJOR
CHALLENGES WITH INDOOR AIR
QUALITY, AND I KNOW THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET OUT HERE.
SO WITH THAT I APPRECIATE THE
SENTIMENT OF ARE MOVING THE BILL
AND LET'S LET'S GIVE YOUR
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE. JUST WANT TO
THANK MY WITNESSES WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION.
THIS IS NOT BANNING ANY SPECIFIC
TYPE OF TECHNOLOGY. JUST
LOWERING THE PPB WOULD BE
SUBSTANTIAL FOR INDOOR AIR
QUALITY WITH THAT, I ASK
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, SECRETARY,
PLEASE CULTURAL SP 1308 MOTION
IS DO PASS AND RE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS ALAN ALAN. I DOLLY.
GONZALES GONZALES, I HEARD TATO
MENJIVAR MENJIVAR. I WIN WHEN I
SKINNER SKINNER. I OKAY? WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER FOLKS
DOWN ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT LET'S GO TO YOU TO
SENATOR OSHO BOG WHO'S HERE TO
PRESENT ITEM FIVE IN YOUR
PACKETS MEMBERS. THIS IS SB
1175.
BEEN A BUSY DAY FOR MANY OF US.
I'M NOT SURE I'VE HAD MANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO PRESENT BILLS
HERE. LITTLE INTIMIDATING WITH
ALL OF THESE VERY SMART STEM
PEOPLE. SO MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING, LET ME START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE TO
IMPROVE THE BILL. I ACCEPT ALL
OF THE COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS AND COMMIT TO WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS
THE REMAINING CONCERNS. CURRENT
REGULATIONS ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO APPLY FOR WAIVERS
FOR SOME OR ALL OF THE SP 1383
COLLECTION REQUIREMENTS FOR
AREAS THAT ARE AT A HIGH
ELEVATION, SPARSELY POPULATED OR
OR RURAL AREAS. HOWEVER THESE
WAIVERS ARE NOT BASED ON WELL
ESTABLISHED BOUNDARIES, SUCH AS
CITY OR COUNTY LINES BUTTON
CENSUS TRACTS, WHICH ARE
GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS CURRENTLY
USED ONLY FOR CENSUS PURPOSES.
THE RESULT IS THAT THE
BOUNDARIES OF AREAS ELIGIBLE FOR
WAIVERS MAKE LITTLE SENSE FOR
THE PURPOSES OF DISPOSING
ORGANIC WASTE. FOR EXAMPLE,
RUNNING SPRINGS AND
UNINCORPORATED TOWN IN SAN
MARINO MOUNTAINS IS SPLIT
BETWEEN TWO CENSUS TRACTS. ONE
WITH LOW POPULATION WAIT ONE
WITH A LOW POPULATION WAIVER AND
ONE WITH AN ELEVATION WAIVER.
THESE THIS MEANS THAT THE
NEIGHBORS LIVING ACROSS THE
STREET FROM EACH OTHER HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH DIFFERENT COLLECTION
REQUIREMENTS, WHICH POSES
LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES FOR WASTE
MANAGEMENT ENTITIES. TO PROVIDE
MORE FLEXIBILITY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN THEIR ATTEMPTS TO
REACH EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS.
SB 1175 WILL REQUIRE CALORIE
CYCLE TO CONSIDER ALTERNATIVES
IN ADDITION TO CENSUS TRACTS
WHEN DECIDING THE BOUNDARIES OF
A GENERAL JURISDICTION ELIGIBLE
FOR A WAIVER OF SOME OR ALL OF
THE COLLECTION REQUIREMENTS OF
SB 1383. THESE ALTERNATIVES
INCLUDE ESTABLISHED BOUNDARIES
OF CITIES AND CENSUS DESIGNED
DESIGNATED PLACES AS WELL AS
BOUNDARY MAPS SUBMITTED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO DEVELOPED WASTE
MANAGEMENT ROUTES WITH ME TO
TESTIFY AND SUPPORT IS JOHN
KENNEDY, SENIOR POLICY ADVOCATE
WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. HELLO AGAIN. JOHN
KENNEDY RC RC. WE APPRECIATE
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. WE
HAVE STRUGGLED WITH THIS OVER
MANY YEARS SINCE HAS BEEN 1393
BEGAN. WE'VE BEEN IMPLEMENTING
1383 ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING
PROGRAMS. A LOT OF THOSE
REGULATIONS CARA CYCLES
DEVELOPED ARE BETTER SUITED THE
DENSER, MORE URBAN AREAS,
IMPLEMENTATION IS MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT IN RURAL AREAS AND
LESS DENSELY POPULATED AREAS. WE
FOUND THAT 1383 DOES CONTAIN A
NUMBER OF LIMITED WAIVERS THAT
CAN APPLY IN VARIOUS
CIRCUMSTANCES, BUT ON THE WHOLE
THE WAY THAT 1383 REGS WERE
CRAFTED, THEY LEAVE VERY LITTLE
ROOM FOR CALORIE CYCLE TO
PROVIDE ANY FLEXIBILITY TO
RESPOND TO DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES TO SITUATIONS LIKE
THIS. SO THE LOW POPULATION
WAVER IN OUR EXPERIENCE FOR
UNINCORPORATED AREAS IS BASED ON
POPULATION ENTITY, 75 PERSONS
PER SQUARE MILE CHALLENGE HERE
WITH OUR EXPERIENCE AND CENSUS
TRACTS, AS YOU WILL HAVE A
CENSUS TRACK THAT'S ABOUT THE
SIZE OF THIS PAPER. THIS TINY
LITTLE CORNER HERE OF THE CENSUS
TRACT IS EMBEDDED IN A CITY
ANCHORED IN A CITY. THE REST OF
THE CENTRIST TRACT IS ALL VERY,
VERY SPARSELY POPULATED AND CAN
BE VERY DIFFERENT.
GEOGRAPHICALLY SO COLLECTION
SERVICES VERY DIFFICULT AND THE
REST OF THE CENSUS TRACT, BUT
THE CENSUS TRACT WILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS LOW POPULATION
WAIVER BECAUSE YOU HAVE A VERY
SMALL PORTION OF THAT AREA
THAT'S EMBEDDED IN THE CITY. SO
WE THINK THIS BILL PROVIDES THE
RIGHT APPROACH THAT ALLOWS CARA
CYCLE TO CONSIDER ALTERNATIVE
METRICS WHETHER THEIR CENSUS
BLOCKS WHICH ARE SUBDIVISIONS OF
CENSUS TRACTS, OTHER BOUNDARIES
ESTABLISHED BY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, OR THE BOUNDARIES OF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THEMSELVES
. NOT ONLY DOES THIS PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND EASE
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES, BUT
ALSO WILL HELP ADDRESS A LOT OF
HEADACHES THAT POWER CYCLE IS
HAVING NOW AND PROVIDE THEM WITH
A LITTLE MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
RESPOND TO THESE SITUATIONS THAT
ARE PRETTY ATYPICAL. THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT WEIRD YOU'RE
SUPPORTIVE. 1175 OKAY. OTHER
FOLKS WANT TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. COMING.
THE MIC. AND JUST SAY YOUR NAME
INFLATION. NICOLE WARD ULLMAN ON
BEHALF OF SAINT BERNARDINO
COUNTY AND SUPPORT, OKAY? GOOD
AFTERNOON, ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF
RIVERSIDE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MELISSA SPARKS CRANES WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
SUPPORT CHRIS ARENAS FROM
CALIFORNIANS WASTE BASED ON THE
AUTHOR'S COMMITMENTS TO
ACCEPTING OUR AMENDMENTS WERE
HAPPY TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON
ADDRESSING OUR CONCERNS. OKAY
THANK YOU. LET'S OPPOSITION
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL. I SEE
NONE. LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS. THOUGHTS MOTION MOTION
BY A CENTER SKINNER YOU MAKE
CLOTHES. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR,
ACCORDING TO THE 2023 REPORT BY
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION,
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE STRUGGLING
TO IMPLEMENT THE STATE'S ORGANIC
WASTE WERE PERSON FOR TIME,
RIGHT. OH, SORRY, AND YOU GOT
SUPPORT. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NICE THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
APPRECIATE THAT SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB 1175.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS ALAN ALAN, I DALLI
DALLI. AYE GONZALES HER TALK HER
TATO. MENJIVAR I WIN WHEN I
SKINNER SKINNER. I OKAY. GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. APPRECIATE IT
. WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FURTHER.
THE FOLKS THAT ADD ON SENATOR
LAIRD, YOU MAY COME FORWARD AND
PRESENT ITEM 10 SP 1280. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR CHAIR. I WAS
SO AFRAID SOMEBODY WAS GOING TO
WORK IN DURING THAT EXTENDED
CLOSE THEIR SECONDS EXACTLY
APPRECIATE YOUR ADMONITION. I
WANT TO FIRST THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL. THERE
WAS A LOT OF DIALOGUE BETWEEN
INTERESTED PARTIES AND A LOT OF
INFORMATION WAS SHARED. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S TÌM.
THIS BILL SIMPLY TRANSITIONS
CALIFORNIA TO MORE SUSTAINABLE
OUTDOOR RECREATION BY REQUIRING
SMALL PROPANE CYLINDER SOLD IN
THE STATE TO BE USABLE OR
REFILLABLE. STARTING ON JANUARY
1ST 2018 RIGHT NOW BOTH SINGLE
USE AND REFILLABLE ARE AVAILABLE
ON THE MARKET THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
ON THE RISE. AND THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL HAS A THREE DAY THREE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION DELAY TO ALLOW
THE REST OF THE MARKET TO COME
INTO PLAY. WHEN THIS HAPPENS,
THE ANALYSIS SUGGESTS A LONGER
TIMELINE FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
NOBODY'S APPROACHED US WITH ANY
SPECIFIC CHANGE, BUT WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT IT AND CAN
AND CONSIDER IT. THE FACT THAT
IS THESE CANISTERS ARE BURDEN AH
, ON OUR LOCAL PARK SYSTEMS,
BEACHES AND MATERIAL RECOVER RE
FACILITIES, 2021 REPORT FROM A
STATEWIDE COMMISSION ON
RECYCLING MARKETS AND CURBSIDE
RECYCLING, WHICH WAS CREATED BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR. UM REALLY RECOMMENDED
TO THE LEGISLATURE MOVING AWAY
FROM SINGLE USE £1 PROPANE
CYLINDERS BECAUSE THEY'RE A
THREAT TO HUMAN AND
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. THERE IS A
REASON THAT CITIES, COUNTIES AND
RURAL COUNTY SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT IS THOSE GOVERNMENTS
AND THE TAXPAYERS THAT SUPPORT
THEM THAT ARE THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE TO SUPPORT THE DISPOSAL OF
THESE RIGHT NOW. AND WE HAVE A
CLEAR PROBLEM. I HAVE TWO
PICTURES HERE AND THE ONE ON THE
RIGHT IS BECAUSE YOU SEMOLINA
NATIONAL PARK HAS TO PAY $75,000
A YEAR TO HAVE THE CYLINDERS
THEY COLLECT, DISPOSED OF, AND
EMPTIED OFF SITE. THEY HAVE TO
PAY $75,000 A YEAR TO DO THAT.
AND IF WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT
REQUIRES REFILLABLE OR RECYCLING
, WE NO LONGER HAVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
LEFT WITH THAT RESPONSIBILITY.
AND THIS HAS BEEN DIFFICULT
ANALYSIS SAYS. THIS BILL MAY
LOOK FAMILIAR. IT'S BECAUSE THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED THIS BILL AUTHORED BY
SENATOR WIECKOWSKI AND THE
GOVERNOR SAID HE WOULD WAS
REALLY INTERESTED IN EXTENDED
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY. AND YET
THAT PRESENTED A PROBLEM. WE
DIDN'T HAVE LANGUAGE BECAUSE WE
HAD EVERYBODY AT THE TABLE AND
THE BILL GOT STOPPED BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE LANGUAGE BECAUSE WE
WERE TALKING TO EVERYBODY AT THE
TABLE AND THEN WHEN WE DROP
LANGUAGE IN APPROPRIATIONS
DIDN'T MOVE IT NOW WE DON'T HAVE
CLEAR MONEY. THIS IS THE WAY TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM AND MOVE
THE BILL. AND THERE HAS HAS BEEN
SORT OF WHACK THEM ALL WITH THE
OPPOSITION. I MENTIONED WE WANT
LANGUAGE AND THEN WHEN YOU GET
LANGUAGE YOU DON'T LIKE IT COME
TO THE TABLE, BUT PEOPLE NOT
REALLY. THEY HOLD BACK AT THE
TABLE. THERE'S EVEN AN ARGUMENT
THAT THERE'S NOT A SYSTEM IN
PLACE YET AND YET WE WERE GIVEN
THREE YEARS AND OPEN TO MORE.
THAT ARGUMENT IS NOT VALID. THIS
IS THE PROBLEM. THESE ARE LEFT
ACROSS OUR PARKS IS PARKS AND
BEAT. AND THE TAXPAYERS PAY FOR
THEM, AND IT'S UP TO US. TO COME
UP WITH A SOLUTION THAT IS
EXTENDED PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY
THAT JUST TAKES THESE OFF THE
PLAYGROUNDS, THE PARKS, THE
BEACHES ACROSS AND AS SOMEBODY
THAT HAS A DISPROPORTIONATE
AMOUNT OF PARKS AND BEACHES, èC
TRASH CANS WITH THESE IN THEM,
AND WHEN THE WORKERS HAVE TO DO
THIS, THE WORKERS ARE SOMETIMES
AT RISK WITH WHAT IS LEFT IN THE
CANISTER. THAT'S ANOTHER REASON.
MUNICIPALITIES DON'T SUPPORT
THIS. SO THE CURRENT SYSTEM
ISN'T WORKING IN THE CHAIR AND I
BOTH HAVE BILLS THAT ADDRESSED
THE ISSUE IN GENERAL, AND THEY
ARE NOT INCONSISTENT, AND IT'S
CLEAR THAT THEY WOULD BE ALLOWED
TO MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT
INCONSISTENCY. I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES HERE, UM AND I HAVE A
FEELING BECAUSE JOHN KENNEDY WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE ONE. THERE. HE
OH, HE IS STILL HERE. HE HAS TO
LEAVE AT 1245. AND SO I WAS
WORRIED THAT HE WAS TESTIFYING
ON EVERYBODY ELSE'S BILL, BUT
WAS NOT GOING TO GET TO MIND.
AND SO WE HAVE PERSO, A
CORROSIVE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL, JOHN KENNEDY ON BEHALF
OF THE RURAL COUNTIES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE IN
JOHN SHOULD PROBABLY GO FIRST IN
CASE HE HAS TO LEAVE. WE'VE BEEN
HEARING A LOT FROM YOU TODAY,
JOHN. YES ALRIGHT. WELL, THANK
YOU HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY AND
SUPPORTED THIS BILL. IT'S A
CONCEPT. A LOT OF US ARE REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT OUR CRC. WE HAVE
40 COUNTIES. MOST OF THOSE
COUNTIES HAVE PERMANENT W
FACILITIES, AS YOU MENTIONED
WERE HOST TO MANY PARKS AND
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES. SO
WE SEE A LOT OF THESE CYLINDERS
COMING IN AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO MANAGE THEM. THEY'RE
VERY EXPENSIVE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MANAGE AND VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THEY'RE EMPTY, WHICH
MEANS THAT WE THEN HAVE TO
MANAGE THEM AS HAZARDOUS WASTE.
WE TRY TO KEEP OUR LOCAL HCV
DROP OFF PROGRAMS FREE FOR
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS, BECAUSE
IF WE CHARGE MONEY FOR THEM,
PEOPLE ARE JUST GOING TO DUMP
THEM ILLEGALLY, AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO MANAGE THAT
ILLEGAL DISPOSAL STREAM AND
INCUR THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT. IN TERMS OF COSTS, YOU
KNOW, OUR COST OF MANAGEMENT
OFTEN EXCEED THE COST FOR THE
CONSUMER TO BUY THESE PRODUCTS
IN THE MARKETPLACE. I HAD R H W
CONSULTANT LARRY SWEETZER LOOK
THIS MORNING, HE FOUND TO QUOTE
FOR MANAGING THESE SMALL
CYLINDERS. ONE WAS $15 PER
CYLINDER. THE OTHER WAS $30 PER
CYLINDER. THOSE COSTS WILL VARY
WILDLY BETWEEN JURISDICTIONS HOW
FAR SOMEONE HAS TO TRAVEL THE
NUMBER OF QUANTUM MATERIALS YOU
HAVE. TO HANDLE IT OR GIVEN
TIME. THESE COSTS ARE ULTIMATELY
BORNE BY ALL OF OUR TAXPAYERS BY
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. WE HAVE
LIMITED RESOURCES AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. SO THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY WE SPEND ON H W MANAGEMENT
IS LESS MONEY THAT WE CAN SPEND
ON SAFETY ON MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS. THINGS LIKE THAT. SO
WE THINK, AS B 1280 IS THE RIGHT
APPROACH, IT WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCE COSTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE LESS PRODUCTS AND THE
WASTE STREAM THAT WE HAVE TO
MANAGE. BUT I THINK JUST AS
IMPORTANTLY, VERY SMALL PRODUCT
REDESIGN HERE FOR THE
MANUFACTURERS WILL RESULT IN
MAJOR COST REDUCTIONS FOR
CONSUMERS AND FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE BOARD. SO
FOR THESE REASONS, WE'RE VERY
EXCITED TO BE HERE AND SUPPORT
OF SB 1280. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING, YOU KNOW, WORKING WITH
YOU AS THIS BILL MOVES TOWARDS
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS PER SILK EUROS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL JUST WANT TO
FIRST THANK SENATOR LAIRD FOR
HIS CONTINUED IN HIS STAFFERS
CONTINUE WORK FOR THE PAST YEAR
ON THIS ISSUE, NOR AVAILABLE £1
PROPANE CYLINDERS, POST
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES. AS JOHN
STATED THEY ARE VERY EXPENSIVE
TO MANAGE PROPERLY AND ARE
DANGEROUS TO THEIR FAMILY
PLAYABLE CONTENT. AS A SENATOR
NOTED, AND NOW, SIS NOTED, WE
DID RUN THIS BILL SIMILAR IN
2022 CENTER WIECKOWSKI THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED, BUT IT WAS
VETOED. AND YOU KNOW, SHORTLY
AFTER THE BILL WAS VETOED, WE
TOOK THAT UNDERSTANDING AND WE
WORKED WITH SENATOR LAIRD AND
THE OPPOSITION ON A CALIFORNIA
BASED MODEL PROGRAM. HOWEVER THE
OPPOSITION CONTINUED TO STALL
AND POST CHALLENGES THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS FOR PERSPECTIVE, WE
COULDN'T EVEN GET PAST THE
DEFINITE DEFINITION SECTION OF
THE BILL. INTERESTINGLY THE
OPPOSITION NOW APPEARS TO
SUPPORT THE CHAIRS H H W E P R
MEASURE. WHILE WE REMAIN
SUSPICIOUS OF THE TIMING, WE
RECOGNIZE THAT BOTH OF THESE
BILLS WE BELIEVE WORK HAND IN
HAND. ONE REMOVES THE PROBLEM
ACT DANGEROUS PRODUCTS FROM THE
WAIST ROOM AND THE OTHER IS A
SOLUTION TO THE END OF LIFE FOR
REPLACEMENT. QUESTION THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE TO REFILL AND
EXCHANGE THE CYLINDERS
AVAILABILITY FOR THE REFILLABLE
£1 PROPANE CYLINDER IS RAPIDLY
EXPANDING AND GROWING. WE'RE
SEEING A NETWORK. OF RETAILERS.
PROVIDING OPTIONS TO PURCHASE
REFILL EXCHANGE THESE CYLINDERS
OVER THE PAST FOUR YEARS WE'VE
SEEN A NUMBER OF LOCATIONS, A
NUMBER OF NATIONAL RETAILERS,
ACE HARDWARE, TRUE VALUE
HARDWARE, HOME DEPOT AND RE I
HAVE THIS MODEL AND HAVE THESE
AVAILABLE REFILLABLE £1 EXCHANGE
PROPANE CYLINDERS, AND WE'VE
ALSO SEEN THAT THE EXCHANGE
NETWORK HAS SEEN A 50% GROWTH IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS. AND THIS IS
JUST AN EASTERN WIDE. UM AN
OPPONENT'S QUESTION THE SAFETY
TO REFILL ALL REPORTED INJURIES.
IS IN FATALITIES HAVE BEEN
LINKED TO NON REFILLABLE
CYLINDERS. CYLINDERS ARE NOT
ENGINEERED TO BE REUSED WITH
CONTRACTS WITH THE RISING
CONSUMER DEMAND FOR REFILLABLE
OPTIONS. REFILLABLE CYLINDERS
HAVE POOR QUALITY ARE POORLY
BUILT AND ARE NOT SUITABLE FOR
REFILLING. AND THEY LACK THE
LEADER OF AL AND ESSENTIAL
SAFETY FEATURE THAT ALLOWS
CONSUMERS TO REFILL IF THAT IS,
YOU KNOW, THERE. UM PROVOCATIVE,
BUT BASICALLY WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WE HOPE
THAT THE COMMITTEE CAN CONSIDER
THIS AND WE HOPE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE SENATOR ON THIS
MEASURE. COBALT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL, TOO BROAD.
ANY TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THANK
YOU, OKAY. GOOD TO SEE YOU DONE.
ALL RIGHT, SO LET'S HEAR ANYONE
ELSE WHO WANTS TO ADD ON HIS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MR. THANK
YOU. MR CHAIR NUMBERS, JASON.
INFREQUENTLY TO TALK THINGS.
THANK YOU, MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
JASON SHELTER HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF SWAN
TO ALAMEDA COUNTY. STOP WASTE
AND WESTERN PLASTER WAGES,
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI. I'M COURTNEY SCOTT WITH ZERO
WASTE CINEMA IN SUPPORT. HI I'M
HEIDI SANBORN, THAT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THIS IS SOURCE
REDUCTION FIRST, AND THAT'S
HIGHEST ON THE WASTE HIERARCHY
PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MICHAEL
CAPRIO WITH REPUBLIC SERVICES
HERE IN SUPPORT. CHRIS ARENAS
FROM CALIFORNIANS WASTE HERE IN
SUPPORT. EMILY PAPPAS ON BEHALF
OF MICHELLE RADICOVA, WHO HAD TO
STEP OUT ON BEHALF OF HER
CLIENT. WE SPANISH BAND SUPPORT
MELISSA SPARKS CRANES WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
SUPPORT JOSH SIMPSON WITH LITTLE
CAPER PROPANE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OKAY MIKE. ONCE YOU
COME ON UP AND GIVE US YOUR
PERSPECTIVE. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MICROBES IN HERE ARE
FIRM REPRESENTS WORTHINGTON
ENTERPRISES, WHICH IS THE
MANUFACTURER OF ALL SIZES OF
PRESSURIZED REFILLABLE, NON
REFILLABLE CYLINDERS, INCLUDING
THE NON REFILLABLE PRODUCT.
THAT'S THE SUBJECT OF THAT WOULD
BE BANNED BY THIS BILL. UM BILL
BANDS, A PRODUCT THAT CONSUMERS
LIKE PROUD OF. IT'S SAFE. IT'S
SAFE TO USE AND UNLIKE THE
MARINE FLARES THAT YOU HEARD
EARLIER HAS PLENTY OF DISPOSAL
OPTIONS AND SAFE DISPOSAL
OPTIONS ON BILLS IF WE'RE GOING
TO BE CYNICAL ABOUT MY APPROACH
TO THIS IS, YOU KNOW THE
CYNICISM IS THAT SPILLS USING
THE LEGISLATURE FAVOR A PRODUCT
THAT'S ON THE ON THE MARKET. NOW
IT'S A COMPETITIVE PRODUCT ON
THE MARKET, AND CONSUMERS
HAVEN'T BEEN BUYING IT. AND YOU
KNOW, FOR INSTANCE, 2015. IT'S
JUST NOT. I MEAN, IT COULD HAVE
DOUBLED. BUT IF YOU'RE DOUBLING
FROM THIS, SMASHING, DOUBLING IT
JUST THAT MUCH. IT'S NOT
DOUBLING A LOT, BUT IN ANY CASE,
IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO CREATE A
MARKET FOR A PRODUCT THAT
CONSUMERS HAVEN'T BEEN BUYING.
SO LIKE ALL HOUSE HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE. THIS PRODUCT
HAS SOME DISPOSAL CHALLENGES
THAT CHALLENGES AND COSTS AND
THERE'S BEEN DOCUMENTED PICTURES
ARE INTERESTING BECAUSE WHAT
THEY SHOW IS THAT YOU CAN
COLLECT PRODUCTS SAFELY. YOU CAN
COLLECT IT AND DISPOSE OF IT AND
RECYCLE IT AND IT JUST COSTS
THEM MONEY AND WORTHINGTON IS
WILLING TO PAY FOR THAT. WILL
WORTHINGTON SUPPORT CPR AND WE
SUPPORTED WE SUPPORTED DPR LAST
YEAR WITH THE LAIRD BILL, AND
YOU KNOW THERE WAS SOME. THERE
WERE SOME CHALLENGES WITH SOME
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT NEVER
GOT RESOLVED. BILL GOT HELD IN
THE PROBES. IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
NICE TO RESOLVE THOSE PROBLEMS
AND THOSE ISSUES. I THINK THEY
WERE RESOLVABLE. BUT BECAUSE OF
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE SUPPORT CPR
AND RATHER THAN A BAND, AND
THAT'S WHY WE ARE SUPPORTING
SENATOR ALLEN'S BILL, WHICH
YOU'LL HEAR LATER. IT'S A GOOD
APPROACH. IT'S THE RIGHT
APPROACH. IT ACTUALLY ADDRESSES
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO, AND WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED WORTHINGTON HAS
EXPERIENCED IN OTHER STATES.
THEY'RE WORKING IN OTHER STATES.
THEY WORKED IN CONNECTICUT FOR
ALLAH AND AN IMPLICATION OF THAT
LOT. THEY HAVE WORKED THROUGHOUT
CANADA ON MPR SPECIFICALLY FOR
THESE CYLINDERS, AND SO THEY SO
THEY HAVE THE EXPERIENCE TO
SUPPORT AND HELP HELP CREATE AN
NPR PROGRAM FOR THIS PRODUCT.
AND, UM I WANT TO JUST REALLY
QUICKLY POINT OUT A COUPLE OF
THINGS I THINK NEED TO BE SAID,
IS THAT I SAID, THIS BILL IS
GOING TO ATTEMPT TO CREATE A
MARKET FOR A PRODUCT THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN BUYING. SO YOU HAVE £1
DISPOSABLE CYLINDER AND £1
REFILLABLE CYLINDER. BUT WHAT?
WHAT THIS BILL IS NOT
RECOGNIZING WHICH CENTER ROUNDS
BILL DOES RECOGNIZE IS THAT
THERE'S A WHOLE OTHER CLASS OF
PRODUCTS OUT THERE THAT
CONSUMERS CAN BUY. SO IF YOU BAN
THE COMMON THE COMMON CYLINDER
WITH THIS BILL, IF YOU BAN IT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW CONSUMERS ARE
GOING TO JUST AUTOMATICALLY GO
AND GRAVITATE TO A REFILLABLE
PRODUCT THAT COSTS THREE TIMES
AS MUCH. THEY'RE GOING TO GO TO
AN ICE, A BUTANE BUTANE CYLINDER
. THERE'S OTHER PRODUCTS OUT
THERE. JET BOIL AND OTHER THINGS
ARE USING CAMPING AND THOSE
PRODUCTS EXIST IN THE
MARKETPLACE. THEY'RE NOT BEING
BANNED BY THIS BILL, AND THEY'RE
JUST GOING TO PROLIFERATE. SO
YOU CAN JUST SWAP OUT ALL THAT
AND PUT JEB OIL IN THERE AND
INSTEAD OF COLEMAN, AND YOU'RE
JUST GONNA HAVE THE SAME
PROBLEM. THAT'S WHY SENATOR
ISLANDS BUILDS THE RIGHT
APPROACH. IN WHAT? WHY THIS BILL
SHOULD BE HELD IN THIS COMMITTEE
AND WE SHOULD MOVE FORWARD IN
AND DO A BILL PASSED. SB 1143
GET IT REFINED. GET IT, GET IT
WORKABLE, AND THEN WE'D HAVE AN
ANSWER. SO ANYHOW, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND APPRECIATE YOU LET
ME TESTIFY. THANK YOU. OTHER
FOLKS WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL. OPPOSITION.
YEAH. SARAH PALOMO HERE IN
RESPECT FOR OPPOSITION. I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATIONS. OKAY GREAT ITEMS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE THOUGHTS
COMMENTS SENTIMENTAL WHERE THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. UM, AVID
CAMPER HERE. ALL THE TIME. I'M
THIS YEAR LOOKING AT GETTING MY
FINAL MY TEARDROP TRAILER AND
THEY GO ALL THE TIME. AYE. I
MEAN, I THINK I'VE USED HALF OF
MORE THAN THIS MY WHOLE ENTIRE
LIFETIME. I WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE TO PURCHASE A LOT, BECAUSE
EVEN IF I BRING ONE, REFILLABLE
ONE, I'M STILL HAVE TO BRING A
LOT BECAUSE I QUICKLY GO THROUGH
THEM THROUGHOUT MY CAMPING TRIP.
SO I'M STRUGGLING TO FIND OUT
HOW THIS IS GOING TO EASE THE
PROBLEM. BECAUSE I'M STILL AS A
CONSUMER GOING TO HAVE TO BUY A
LOT OF THESE, WHETHER THE
REFILLABLE OR NOT, SO AT THE END
, I'M STILL GOING TO HAVE MY 10
WITH MY FRIENDS AND I HAVE TO
PUT SOMEWHERE I DO AGREE THAT
SENATOR ALLEN'S BILL IS THE
FIRST STEP. THAT IS WHAT THE
VETO MESSAGE ASKED FOR TO CREATE
A PROCESS OF HOW WE'RE GOING TO
GET TO A BETTER WAY TO DISPOSE
OF THIS. I THINK THIS IS IN LINE
WITH MY MENTALITY FOR ANY OF
THESE BILLS THAT I'M HERE FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION PART OF IT,
RATHER THAN THE LET'S GET AHEAD
OF SOMETHING WITHOUT HAVING A
PLAN. SENATOR WITH THAT IN MIND.
I DON'T THINK I CAN GO UP IN
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. ALRIGHT
INVITE MR VICE CHAIR WHO
ENFORCES IT, SENATOR HOOP,
NOBODY ENFORCEMENT ARMY BASE.
CALORIE CYCLE. I'M SORRY IS
THERE I DIDN'T SEE AN
ENFORCEMENT IN THE BILL FROM THE
BILL. SO I'M BEING TOLD BY STAFF
THAT ACTUALLY THERE. WAIT WAIT,
WAIT. THERE'S AN EXISTING CODE
SECTION THAT THIS BILL DOESN'T
CHANGE FOR THIS BILL DOESN'T
ADDRESS THAT SPEAKS TO THAT.
DTSC. YES DAD TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. UNDERSTANDS COVER
CYCLE, OKAY? BECAUSE BY THE
POWER CYCLE FURTHER QUESTIONS.
I'M ASKED TO BE RESTRICTED.
COVER CYCLES. YES, SO BE
UNDERCARRIAGE CYCLES OF 30. OKAY
THIS IS PUBLISHED THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE. THAT'S WHERE
CALORIE CYCLE LIST. HMM. WOW
OKAY, ALRIGHT. WITHIN CARROT
CYCLES DIVISION OF ENFORCEMENT
IS A MORE UNDERSTANDING. SO THEN
THIS BILL WILL BE THIS FISCAL
THEN. YEAH. YES NO. YES YES,
YES, YES, YES. SO IT WILL NEED
27 VOTE TO GET OUT OF THE
ATTACKS. NO IT'S NOT ATTACKS
ATTACKS DEFEAT. WHAT NO, IT'S
FISCAL BECAUSE OF WHETHER THERE
MIGHT BE ANY COST OF ENFORCEMENT
OR IMPLEMENTATION. YEAH. YOU
KNOW, I MEAN, SORRY. YEAH I
MEAN, THIS HAS BEEN A LONG AND
WINDING ROAD. OBVIOUSLY I MEAN,
THERE WAS A BAND THAT WAS
VETOED. CENTER WIECKOWSKI PUT
FORWARD. THIS IS SUBSTANTIALLY
SIMILAR. MM. I MEAN, WHAT'S THE
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE IN PLAY
BETWEEN THIS AND WIECKOWSKI?
BILL I THINK THAT THAT THE
WIECKOWSKI BILL WAS AN ACTUAL
BAN. WHAT THIS DOES IS ALLOWS A
PHASE IN OF REFILLABLE AND IF I
CAN USE AN ANALOGY WHEN I WAS IN
THE ASSEMBLY HER. I
UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO DO THE
BILLS ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF MORE EFFICIENT TOILETS AND I
TRY TO BUILD TO MAKE IT
REGULATORY AND PUT IT IN THE
CODE AND THE GOVERNOR AT THE
TIME, GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER
VETOED IT. SO THEN I WENT TO THE
MARKET AND I GAVE THE MARKET A
NUMBER OF YEARS TO FACE IT IN BY
PERCENTAGES. AND ALL THE TOILET
COMPANIES CAME ON BOARD. THE
GOVERNOR CAME ON BOARD AND THAT
WAS THE WAY THAT WE PROCEEDED
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS DOES. I
MEAN, THIS IS THE PLAN. THERE IS
A PLAN HERE AND THE PLAN IS THAT
YOU IMPLEMENT THIS OVER TIME IN
A WAY THAT THERE'S PLACES IN THE
MARKET NOW, AND THIS DOES ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO HAVE A NUMBER OF YEARS
AND WE CAN STILL TALK ABOUT HOW
MANY THAT IS TO FACE IT IN AND
DO IT. RIGHT DO YOU SEE? I MEAN,
I REALLY LIKE, WELL WHERE YOU
WERE TRYING TO GO LAST YEAR WITH
SP 560 E PR. WE'VE ALL BEEN
TALKING ABOUT IT. OBVIOUSLY YOU
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET OUT. SHE'LL
GET OUT OF MY ON THAT. IS THAT
IS THERE IS THERE A STRONG
POSSIBILITY? THAT'S WHERE THIS
MOVES? I DON'T THINK SO. MOSTLY
BECAUSE OF IS THAT WOULD NOW
COST A BUNCH OF MONEY IN A WAY
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DO IT THE LAST TWO YEARS, AND I
THINK THIS IS VERY INTERESTING,
DIFFICULT IN TERMS OF COST, AND
THIS PUTS IT ON THE MARKET. BUT
YOU CAN YOU CAN. YOU KNOW, I
MEAN SP 54, FOR EXAMPLE, IS NOT
CAUSING IT AND THAT COST TO THE
STATE IT'S ULTIMATELY PAID FOR.
I WILL ARGUE WITH THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THAT
THE COST IS NEGLIGIBLE IN THIS,
BUT NEVERTHELESS, IT WILL BE
TAGGED. TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION
AND THE REAL THING IS, YOU KNOW
IT'S INTERESTING IN THE
OPPOSITION, BECAUSE OH, YES, THE
DIFFERENCES YOU PAY WELL, IF YOU
SOMEBODY'S PAYING 75,000, AND
THEY'RE NOT EVEN ONE OF 58
COUNTIES OR 400 CITIES WHERE ALL
THE STATE PARKS ON THE BEACH,
THERE IS A TREMENDOUS COST THAT
IS BEING PAID NOW THAT WOULD NOT
BE PAID. IF THAT HAPPENED,
RIGHT? OKAY UM, WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION WHEN, WHEN APPROPRIATE
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW THAT WE
HAVE ANYONE SUPPORTIVE BESIDES
ME HERE, SO LET'S HOPE THAT
FOLKS COME BACK, BUT WITH THAT
WILL LET YOU GET THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION. AND I HAVE TO SAY
THAT THERE WAS NO FORMAL SUPPORT
LAST YEAR AND I WAS NOT FEELING
THE SUPPORT AT ANY TIME, SO IT'S
VERY INTERESTING THAT THAT WAS
REFLECTED TO THE COMMITTEE AND
SUPPORT WAS FROM US. I KNOW, BUT
HE WAS SPEAKING HERE. YOU KNOW,
THE CHAIR WON'T DO THAT. BUT I
WILL. UM AND SO I THINK THAT
THAT THIS IS THE SOLUTION THIS
REALLY IN A TIME OF FISCAL
EMERGENCY SHIFTS, THE COST AND
THE SAFETY ISSUES FROM PUBLIC
GOVERNMENTS FROM THE TAXPAYERS
TO THE MARKET AND ALLOWS A PHASE
IN OF THE MARKET OVER TIME, IN A
WAY THAT WILL ACTUALLY WORK AND
IT'S IF YOU HAVE TO GO BY
CYLINDER. YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO BUY THE SAME AMOUNT OF
RECYCLABLE ONES WERE REFILLABLE
ONES AS YOU ARE NON. IT JUST
MEANS IT WILL BE MORE
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND. WE WILL
NOT BE CLEANING THEM OFF OUR
BEACHES AND WE WILL NOT BE
HAVING THE SAFETY HAZARDS FROM
PUBLIC WORKERS HAVING TO CLEAN
THESE WHEN THEY COLLECT THEM,
AND THEY DO THAT. THIS IS THE
RIGHT DIRECTION, BOTH
ENVIRONMENTALLY FISCALLY AND THE
RIGHT DIRECTION FOR BUSINESS IN
TERMS OF ALLOWING BUSINESS TO
ADJUST TO WHAT WE'RE DOING, AND
WHEN IT WAS SAID. YOU KNOW THAT
THAT THE MARKET ISN'T WORKING.
LOOK AT WHAT WE DID ON TAILPIPE
EMISSION STANDARDS. ONE OF THE
REASONS PEOPLE DIDN'T DO IT IS
EFFICIENT. CARS WEREN'T WIDELY
AVAILABLE. YOU CAN GO ON AND ON
AND ON IN PLACES WHERE WE HAVE
ENACTED AN ENVIRONMENTAL WAY TO
DEAL WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. AND THIS DOES IT SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST DISCUSSION
THAT WE HAVE HAD TODAY. THANK
YOU. OK, UM, I THINK EVERYBODY
LET'S GO TO MENJIVAR, WHO'S
GOING TO PRESENT? CERTAINLY MS
SB 1266 NÓ NÓ NÓ EMOTIONS
SUPPORTIVE OK?
PERFECT. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR.
NON EXISTING COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
UH I AM NOT SITTING LIMÓN. UH,
SHE IS SAVING HER HER BOCO FOR
HER OWN COMMITTEE. A LITTLE
UNDER THE WEATHER HERE, BUT I'M
HERE TO PRESENT ON HER S¼ B
1266. UM IN SHE WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE AND
ANALYSIS. SO IN LIGHT OF THESE
AMENDMENTS, S¼ B 1266 1266 NOW
SEEKS TO PROHIBIT A MANUFACTURER
FROM SELLING CHILDREN FEEDING,
SUCKING OR TEETHING PRODUCTS
THAT CONTAIN ANY FORM OF BANS AT
A DETECTABLE LEVEL OF 0.1 PARTS
PER BILLION. BP IS A CHEMICAL
THAT IS TYPICALLY USED TO CREATE
POLYCARBONATE PLASTIC AND EPOXY
RESINS AND HAS BEEN AROUND SINCE
THE 19 SIXTIES. CALMLY PEOPLE
ARE FAMILIAR WITH BP S¼ CHILD BP
, WHICH IS FOUND IN A VARIETY OF
INDUSTRIAL AND CONSUMER
PRODUCTS, RANGING FROM
AUTOMOBILE PARTS TO FOOD
CONTAINERS, IS CONSIDERED AN
ENDOCRINE DISRUPTOR, WHICH MEANS
IT CAN INTERFERE WITH THE
HORMONE SYSTEM IN THE BODY. THIS
CHEMICAL IS ASSOCIATED WITH
HARMFUL HEALTH OUTCOMES, SUCH AS
ASTHMA, CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE
AND OBESITY. CHILDREN IN
PARTICULAR CHILDREN IN
PARTICULAR, INFANTS ARE EVEN
MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE HARMS OF
BEING LINKED TO BEHAVIORAL
DISORDERS SUCH AS A Dð, HÌ, Dð
AND HEALTH ISSUES SUCH AS
DIABETES, RECOGNIZING THE
ADVERSE HEALTH EFFECTS IMPACTS
OF THIS CHEMICAL IN 2012, THE U
THE U S¼ F Dð, A BANNED BP FROM
BOTTLES, BABY BOTTLES AND SIPPY
CUPS. UNFORTUNATELY ITEMS STILL
EXIST THAT HAVE THIS LIKE BABY
TETHER, UM, AND AS A RESULT HAVE
BEEN FOUND TO CONTAIN BP, A
ALTHOUGH MANUFACTURERS HAVE
ELIMINATED FROM BABY BOTTLES,
AND TO BECOMES LIKE A MIX
MENTIONED, THEY HAVE SHIFTED TO
USING ALTERNATIVE CHEMICALS TO
REPLACE IT, SUCH AS, AND EVERY
SINGLE LETTER IN THE ALPHABET,
WHICH HAVE BEEN FOUND TO BE EVEN
MORE HARMFUL THAN BP. A WHEN A B
1319 WAS SIGNED INTO LAW IN 2011
, CALIFORNIA MADE A COMMITMENT
TO ENSURE THAT YOUNG CHILDREN
ARE PROTECTED FROM HAZARDOUS
CHEMICALS. CALIFORNIA PARENTS
EXPECT CHILDREN'S PRODUCTS,
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT HAVE COME
INTO CONTACT WITH THEIR MOUTH TO
BE COMPLETELY SAFE. IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT WHEN TOXIC ARE
POTENTIALLY HARMFUL CHEMICALS
ARE PHASED OUT OR PRODUCTS THAT
ARE NOT SIMPLY REPLACED BY
ANOTHER HARMFUL TYPE OF PRODUCT.
WE'RE CLOSING THE LOOPHOLES HERE
. S¼ B 12 666, AUSTRALIANS THE
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT CHILDREN
FROM HARMFUL CHEMICALS AND
AUTHORIZES Dð Tð S¼ èC TO
ESTABLISH STANDARDS PRIOR
PRIORITIZING THE HEALTH AND
WELLNESS OF OUR CHILDREN. THE
AUTHOR IS TAKING NOTE OF IN THE
ANALYSIS, UM AND WILL BE
CONSIDERING MOVING THE
ENFORCEMENT INTO THAT
DEPARTMENT. I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
AND ASK THAT ALL QUESTIONS BE
DIRECTED TO THESE WITNESSES.
RYAN SPENCER AND CHRISTINA
HEIDEL BRAND. MR CHAIR, WE COULD
TURN TO HER AND THERE'S NÓ RED
POSITION WE'RE DESPERATELY
TRYING TO GET THROUGH. UM SO IF
YOU COULD MAKE YOUR TIME WE
GONNA SUPPORT THIS. RYAN SPENCER
BEHALF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
Ó BGY  N S¼ DISTRICT NINE. ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I APPRECIATE THAT. I TAKE
CUES. UM IF IT'S OK, I'LL SPEAK
A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN THAT, BUT
NOT BY MUCH. UM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU TO THE
STAFF WHO WORKED ON THIS
DILIGENTLY. MY NAME IS CHRISTINA
HILDEBRAND. I'M THE FOUNDER OF,
UH, A VOICE FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY.
WE EDUCATE FOR PEOPLE EDUCATE
AND ADVOCATE FOR PEOPLE'S RIGHTS
TO BE FULLY INFORMED ABOUT THE
COMPOSITION, QUALITY AND SHORT
AND LONG TERM HEALTH EFFECTS OF
ALL PRODUCTS THAT GO INTO
PEOPLE'S BODIES SUCH AS FOOD,
AIR, WATER, PHARMACEUTICALS,
COSMETICS, AND IN THIS CASE,
CHILDREN'S FEEDING, SUCKING AND
TEETHING PRODUCTS. OUR
ORGANIZATION HAS WORKED CLOSELY
WITH SENATOR LIM'S OFFICE ON
THIS BILL, AND I'M HERE BEFORE.
TODAY TO SHARE WITH YOU. WHY
THIS BILL IS SO IMPORTANT FOR
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF OUR
YOUNGEST GENERATION IN EXPANDING
THE CURRENT STATUTE TO REMOVE
ALL BISPHENOL NOT JUST BP OR
BIS. A. IT IS CLEAR FROM OUR
CONVERSATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES AND CONTROL
EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT WHILE
CALIFORNIA WAS A LEADER IN
BANNING BP IN BOTTLES AND SIPPY
CUPS OVER A DECADE AGO, MANY
MANUFACTURERS HAVE JUST REPLACED
BP WITH OTHER BISPHENOL SUCH AS
BISPHENOL S¼ AND BIOL P. THESE
ALTERNATES STILL POSE A
SIGNIFICANT THREAT TO OUR
CHILDREN'S HEALTHS HAVE BEEN
LINKED TO A MYRIAD OF ADVERSE
HEALTH OUTCOMES RANGING FROM
DEVELOPMENTAL DISORDERS TO
REPRODUCTIVE ABNORMALITIES. ONE
OF THE MOST CONCERNING ASPECTS
OF BISPHENOL EXPOSURE IS THE
IMPACT ON DEVELOPING BRAINS AND
BODIES OF CHILDREN. STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT EVEN AT LOW DOSES
BISPHENOL CAN, UH, DISRUPT
HORMONE FUNCTION LEADING TO
NEURO BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS,
LEARNING DISABILITIES AND
ATTENTION DEFICITS IN CHILDREN.
FURTHERMORE, BIS HAVE BEEN
ASSOCIATED WITH AN INCREASED
RISK OF OBESITY, DIABETES AND
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASES, COSTING
A LONG SHADOW OVER THE HEALTH OF
OUR CHILDREN'S OK. I'M SO SORRY,
MA'AM, I WE ALL SUPPORT THIS
BILL. UM WE'LL WE'LL ACCEPT YOUR
TESTIMONY IN WRITTEN FORM. I. I
REALLY APOLOGIZE. YOU'RE GOOD.
WE'RE GETTING HERE. SO LET'S
HEAR FROM FOLKS WHO WANNA VOICE
SUPPORT. PLEASE QUICKLY. I
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
PHIL ALLIO NOW IN SUPPORT IS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. GREAT. THANK
YOU. ARIANA CREEK. I'M SORRY. I
SHOULD SAY FOR THE RECORD WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP.
THANKS. ARIANA CREED WITH CLEAN
EARTH FOR KIDS.ORG AND SUPPORT
AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. JUSTICE
FACTS, GRANDPARENTS IN ACTION
MAMAS, NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE, INTERFAITH COALITION
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
NCC. MAKING SOME WAY FOR
SACRAMENTO, 350 IN CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE ACTION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HØI ANDREA VENTURA WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION AND SUPPORT.
WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN A LETTER IN
YET, BUT WE WILL NOW THAT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE IN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. REBECCA MARQUEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY AND SUPPORT. JAKE STOATS
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. KAREN UM SORRY. KAREN
AON, UM, ON BEHALF OF SOUND,
CAL, CALIFORNIA AND EDUCATE
ADVOCATE AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. OSHA SHARMA WITH PESTICIDE
ACTION NETWORK AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. OK, UM POSITION. FOLKS WHO
WANT TO RAISE CONCERNS. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
LARISSA SUES ON BEHALF OF THE
TOY ASSOCIATION. WE ARE NEUTRAL
ON THE BILL, AND WE APPLAUD THE
SENATOR'S LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. WE JUST HAD A CONCERN
REGARDING THE TERM CHILDREN'S
PRODUCT VERSUS JUVENILE PRODUCT
AND WE UNDERSTAND WE'LL WORK ON
THIS IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE, BUT
WE WANTED TO RAISE THAT. THANK
YOU. INTERESTING, OK? UM GREAT.
OK OPPOSITION FOLKS WHO WANNA
RAISE CONCERNS. BESIDES THAT. I
SAID, OK, GREAT. WE'LL BRING YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MOVED BY
THE VICE CHAIR. APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S, UH, ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE, AND, UM
YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I THAT'S
GREAT. ALL RIGHT, LET'S UH CALL
THE ROLL. SB 1266. THE MOTION IS
DUE TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REREFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH SENATORS ALLEN ALLEN, I
DALLY DALLY I. GONZALEZ HURTADO
MENJIVAR MENJIVAR. I WIN.
SKINNER. YES. 30 WE'LL HOLD THAT
OPEN. UH S¼ P 1143. ALLEN YOU'RE
READY. LET'S ROLL. GREAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. UH, MR VICE CHAIR.
UM SO I'M UH THIS BILL HAS BEEN
REFERRED TO ALREADY IT WOULD
ESTABLISH AN EXTENT PRODUCE
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAM FOR THE
MOST DANGEROUS HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE PRODUCTS NOW, UH
, WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF EVERYDAY
PRODUCTS THAT ARE CLASSIFIED AS
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE. THEY
POSE AS YOU KNOW, SERIOUS
THREATS TO HUMAN HEALTH. AND THE
ENVIRONMENT IF IMPROPERLY
MANAGED. UM AND YOU KNOW, I
THINK EVERYONE IN THE END OF THE
DAY KNOWS WHAT EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY IS ABOUT. IT'S
ABOUT ENSURING THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO COLLECT THESE PRODUCTS AND
DISPOSE OF THEM IN A SAFE MANNER
. ONE OF THE CHALLENGES, OF
COURSE, IS, UH, THAT EVEN IF A
PERSON KNOWS THAT A PRODUCT IS
TOXIC CAN'T SIMPLY BE THROWN
AWAY. MANY COMMUNITIES DON'T
HAVE A CONVENIENT SYSTEM FOR
SAFELY COLLECTING THE WASTE. AND
YOU KNOW, THIS UNIVERSITY OF
PRODUCTS CAN BE COLLECTED AT A
LOCAL, UM, WASTE FACILITY. AND
WHEN THOSE FACILITIES ARE OPEN
TO THE PUBLIC, YOU KNOW? THAT
THAT THAT DIFFERS FROM
JURISDICTION TO JURISDICTION.
BOTH ARE USUALLY A FUNCTION OF
WHAT JURISDICTION, UH
JURISDICTIONS CAN AFFORD. WE
START TO SEE COLLECTION AND, UH,
DISPOSAL COSTS, INCREASING
CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE NOW
HAVING TO RAISE THEIR RATES TO
COVER THE COSTS OR THEY HAVE TO
REDUCE THEIR SERVICES, FURTHER
REDUCING CONVENIENCE FOR LOCAL
RESIDENTS, AND THIS REALLY IS
IMPACTING OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT'S
ABILITY TO DO. UH, IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT WORK. THE STATES
OFFERED SOME LIMITED GRANTS. UH,
IN THIS SPACE TO PROVIDE FOR
SOME, YOU KNOW THE CONSTRUCTION
OF NEW FACILITIES OR EXPANDING
EXISTING FACILITIES, BUT FIND
YOU KNOW, FUNDING AS IS OFTEN
THE CASE IS FALLING REALLY SHORT
OF WHAT'S NEEDED TO KEEP PACE
AND JUST TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
CALVER CYCLES FACILITIES GRANT
PROGRAM HAS A CAP OF $5 MILLION
A YEAR, ONE NEW FACILITY IN
SONOMA. THE COST IS BETWEEN 13
AND 15 MILLION. SO WE GOT THESE
CRUSHING COSTS OF MANAGING THE
WASTE, UH, AND THE LACK OF
COMMUNITY ACCESS TO PROPER
DISPOSAL SYSTEMS. SO THIS BILL
STEPS IN AND ASKS THE PRODUCERS
TO HELP BE PART OF THE SOLUTION,
YOU KNOW, HELP US. UH, YOU KNOW
YOU YOU GUYS ARE THE ONES
PRODUCING THE MOST TOXIC
CONSUMER PRODUCT. UH OUT THERE,
PLEASE FORM A PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY ORGANIZATION
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED UNDER S¼, B, 54 AND
OTHER E PR LEGISLATION. UH, THAT
ORGANIZATION RUN BY INDUSTRY,
UH, WITH IMPORTANT SAFEGUARDS
AND OVERSIGHT WILL BE TASKED
WITH ENHANCING ACCESSIBILITY AND
FULLY FUNDING THE SAFE
COLLECTION, TRANSPORTATION AND
DISPOSAL OF THIS WASTE. SO JUST
LIKE IN SV 54, THE PROGRAM WILL
ACCOMPLISH SEVERAL IMPORTANT
GOALS. IT ALLOWS PRODUCERS
THEMSELVES TO COST EFFECTIVELY
IMPROVE ACCESS TO CONVENIENT
DISPOSAL OF HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS
WASTE, AND THEY CAN EITHER FUND
AN IMPROVED SYSTEM OR THEY CAN
CREATE AN ALTERNATIVE. UH, THE
BILLS ALSO REQUIRES ROBUST
EDUCATION. YOU KNOW AN OUTREACH
TO ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS KNOW
WHICH PRODUCTS ARE TOXIC AND HOW
TO HANDLE THEM PROPERLY. AND
LASTLY, SINCE THE BILL REQUIRES
PRODUCERS TO FUND THE SYSTEM AND
BASES, THE FEES ON THE MATERIALS
TOXICITY, THE BILL WILL
ENCOURAGE PRODUCERS ULTIMATELY
TO INVEST IN LESS TOXIC
ALTERNATIVES. IF A PRODUCER
WOULD PREFER NOT TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE PR, THEY CAN THEN
REFORMULATE THEIR PRODUCT TO A
NON TOXIC ALTERNATIVE, AND THUS
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE TO BE SUBJECT
TO THE RULES OF THE BILL. YOU
KNOW, THE PROBLEM IS THE
ESSENTIAL PROBLEM. IS THAT UNDER
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM, PRODUCERS DO
NOT CONSIDER END OF LIFE COSTS
WHEN FORMULATING THEIR PRODUCTS.
THOSE COSTS DON'T APPEAR ON
THEIR BALANCE SHEETS. THEY'RE
NOT PART OF THE CALCULATION.
THEY'RE NOT HELD ACCOUNTABLE,
ACCOUNTABLE, AND IT'S ULTIMATELY
THE TAXPAYERS. AN INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES WHOSE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE FORCED TO MAKE
THESE DIFFICULT DECISIONS ABOUT,
UH, YOU KNOW, AND THEY'RE
ULTIMATELY LEFT HOLDING THE BAG
WITH REGARDS TO THE, UM, THE
SAFE DISPOSAL OF THESE PRODUCTS
SO BY REQUIRING PRODUCERS TO
COVER THE COST OF SAFELY
DISPOSING OF THE PRODUCTS THAT
THEY'RE PUSHING OUT OF THE
MARKET PRODUCERS WILL FINALLY
HAVE SOME SKIN IN THE GAME.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS
ULTIMATELY ALL ABOUT, AND, UM,
HEIDI'S HERE TO PRESENT WITH
MELISSA FROM THE CITIES. THANK
YOU, SENATOR ALLEN. AND THANK
YOU, UM, VICE CHAIR, DOLLY AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS HEIDI
SANBORN. I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL. WE
ADVOCATE FOR AN EQUITABLE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND WE ARE
BASICALLY THE NATION'S EXPERTS
IN EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY POLICY. UM WE'RE
PROUD TO BE THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL AND HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS
WASTE IS SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN A
PASSION OF MINE FOR A VERY LONG
TIME. I'VE PERSONALLY WORKED ON
E PR SINCE 2006. WHEN I WAS A
CONSULTANT, I ACTUALLY DELIVERED
A REPORT TO THE THEN WASTE
MANAGEMENT BOARD ON THE END OF
LIFE FRAMEWORK FOR ANALYZING
POLICY APPROACHES FOR WASTE
MANAGEMENT, AND I CONCLUDED THAT
TIME AFTER LOOKING AT OVER 70
DIFFERENT POLICIES FROM AROUND
THE WORLD THAT THE VERY BEST
POLICY APPROACH, ESPECIALLY FOR
HAZARDOUS WASTE, WHICH HAS NÓ
END OF LIFE MARKET, THERE'S NÓ
WAY TO REALLY SELL. IT IS AN
EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY. APPROACH. AND
THE BOARD ACCEPTED THAT REPORT
BACK IN 2007. IN 2009 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHESBROUGH ACTUALLY
INTRODUCED A BILL THAT WAS A
FRAMEWORK APPROACH TO MANY WASTE
PRODUCTS. AB 280 THREE, WHICH
WOULD HAVE CREATED THE
CALIFORNIA STEWARDSHIP ACT AND
ESTABLISHED A FRAMEWORK OF
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY, BUT IT
FAILED TO PASS AND SINCE THEN
THE STATE HAS BEEN TAKING ON
PRODUCTS ONE PRODUCT AT A TIME,
AND THAT'S FINE. WE'VE LEARNED A
LOT FROM ALL THESE DIFFERENT
PRODUCTS THAT WE'VE PASSED BILLS
ON AND IN THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
CATEGORY. THE FIRST ONE THAT WE
WORKED ON AS COSPONSOR WAS
MERCURY THERMOSTATS IN 2008. AND
PAINT HAPPENED IN 2010. AND THEN
MATTRESSES IN 2013 MEDICINES AND
NEEDLES IN 2018, AND THEN
BATTERIES AND PACKAGING IN 2022.
SO THERE'S LOTS OF HISTORY. NOW
WE KNOW HOW TO DO THIS. WE KNOW
HOW TO DO IT WELL, AND IF WE
DON'T DO SOMETHING NOW, THAT'S
MORE OF A FRAMEWORK APPROACH FOR
THE REMAINING HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE. WE WILL END UP
WITH A PRODUCER RUN ORGANIZATION
, ONE BILL AT A TIME AS WE KEEP
GOING AND THAT IS VERY HARD.
WE'VE ALREADY TALKED TO CLEAN
HARBORS ONE OF THE WASTE HAULERS
AND THEY'VE TOLD US PLEASE DON'T
DO ANY MORE. PR S¼ JUST GIVE US
ONE PR Ó, UM I WAS APPOINTED TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
COMMISSION ON RECYCLING MARKETS
AND CURBSIDE RECYCLING WHERE I
WAS ELECTED CHAIR BY MY FELLOW
AND WE DEVELOPED 34 POLICY
APPROACHES THAT WE GAVE TO THE
LEGISLATURE, MANY OF WHICH,
THANKFULLY HAVE BECOME LAW SINCE
, BUT THE NUMBER ONE
RECOMMENDATION IN THE FIRST ONE
THAT WE MADE WAS THAT HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE GO UNDER AN E PR
APPROACH, AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE
SO EXCITED THAT SENATOR ELLEN
AGREED TO CARRY THE BILL AND
SEES IT AS A PRIORITY AND THE
COMMISSIONERS ALL SUPPORTED IT.
WE HAD THE TEAMSTERS WE HAD THE
WASTE HAULERS. WE HAD A BROAD
STAKEHOLDER GROUP OF 17
COMMISSIONERS ON THAT
COMMISSION. AND IN FEBRUARY, WE
PARTICIPATED IN A TOUR THAT
INCLUDED THE COW WASTE RECOVERY
FACILITY IN LODI. AND WELL,
ACTUALLY, GAULT, AND THEY
ACTUALLY ONLY ACCEPT BLUE BIN
RECYCLING MATERIALS, AND THEY
ARE SPENDING 100 AND $50,000 A
YEAR PROCESSING £183,000 OF
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE THAT'S
ENDING UP IN THE RECYCLING BINS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE AN
ALTERNATIVE, AND I KNOW TIME IS
OF THE ESSENCE. SO I'M GOING TO
WRAP IT UP BY SAYING, UM, WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS IS
FINALLY COMING TO THE FRONT AND
HOPEFULLY THIS WILL BE THE LAST
BIG BILL IN THIS CATEGORY. THANK
VERY MUCH. WE ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU GOT ABOUT A
MINUTE. OK, MAKE IT QUICK. GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MELISSA SPARKS KRANS WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT OF SB 140, THREE. UM AS
MENTIONED, LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
INCLUDING CITIES AND COUNTIES
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR SOLID WASTE
IN HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE
MANAGEMENT. OUR JURISDICTIONS,
OPERATE PERMANENT FACILITIES,
TEMPORARY EVENTS AND USE OIL
COLLECTION SITES. THERE ARE 151
PERMANENT HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS
WASTE FACILITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. OUR PROGRAMS ACCEPT
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE FROM
HOUSEHOLDS FROM SMALL BUSINESSES
FROM ABANDONED SITES AND SOLID
WASTE LOAD. PROGRAMS WE STRIVE
TO KEEP THESE PROGRAMS FREE OR
AS LOW COST FOR RESIDENTIAL
HOUSEHOLDS TO AVOID ILLEGAL
DUMPING THAT WE ULTIMATELY HAVE
TO MANAGE THROUGH ABANDONED
WASTE SITES. UM, SO AS MENTIONED
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE IS
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MANAGE. UM A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE NÓ
CONTROL OVER THE MANUFACTURERS
AND WHAT'S INTRODUCED INTO THIS
STREAM, AND WE AND OUR TAXPAYERS
HAVE TO MANAGE THOSE COSTS AND
MANAGE THE END OF LIFE OF THE
MATERIALS AGAIN. MANY PRODUCTS
COST US MUCH MORE THAN WHAT IT
IS AT THE END OF LIFE, THEN IT
COSTS CONSUMERS TO PAY AT THE
POINT OF SALE, AND WE BELIEVE
THAT S¼ B 1140 THREE, UH, FILLS
A BIG GAP IN OUR EXISTING E PR
PROGRAMS. SO THANK YOU, AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO REGISTER THE
SUPPORT OF OUR RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA AS
WELL. THANK YOU. THOSE WISHING
TO ADD ON AS ME TOOS AND SUPPORT
HERE IN 1200. GOOD AFTERNOON.
DOUG COBOLT, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL. UH WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH SENATOR ALLEN
AND THE SPONSORS ON THIS BILL TO
AND FULLY SUPPORT THE BILL AND
CONTINUE TO HAVE ALL THE FAITH
IN THE WORLD THAT, UH, THIS, UH,
SENATOR ALLEN WILL, UH, GET THIS
F THROUGH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR CHAIR MEMBERS, JASON
SCHMELTZER HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN PLASTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THIS IS HUGELY
EXPENSIVE FOR US. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CIARA ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE TOWN OF TRUCKEE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ALLIO
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP CAME
ON AFTER THE ANALYSIS. THANK
YOU. THAT TO SHARMA ON BEHALF OF
PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK IN
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM IN SUPPORT. KAYLA
ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF RETHINK
WASTE IN SEVENTH GENERATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. PRISCILLA
KUDOS ON BEHALF OF, UH ALAMEDA,
STOP WASTE AND SUPPORT. HØI I'M
COURTNEY SCOTT, THE HOUSEHOLD
HAZARDOUS WASTE PROGRAM MANAGER
FOR ZERO WASTE SONOMA. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AND THROUGH THE
NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL. WE HAVE PERMISSION TO
ALSO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR NAPA
RECYCLING AND WASTE SERVICES IN
SANITARY SERVICE AND SEA HUGGER.
HER STORY IS, UM A PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S AGAINST WASTE AND
SUPPORT AS WELL AS ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTS. ON BEHALF OF SAN
MATEO COUNTY AND SUPPORT. JANET
COX AND STRONG SUPPORT FOR
CLINTON ACTION. CALIFORNIA THREE
50, SACRAMENTO AND THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF CLIMATE
REALITY PROJECT. THANK YOU. JAKE
STOATS WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU HAVE
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. I'M.
ARIANA CREED WITH CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS.ORG AND SUPPORT. ALSO
THOSE IN SUPPORT ARE CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL,
HEALTH AND JUSTICE, FACTS,
GRANDPARENTS AND ACTION MAMAS,
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE,
INTERFAITH COALITION FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND NCC.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MICHAEL CAPRIO HERE ON BEHALF OF
REPUBLIC SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
UH, JOSH SIMPSON LITTLE CAMPER
PROPANE IN SUPPORT. MILAN FOR
THE ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS AND HEAL THE BAY.
THANK YOU. YEAH UM, MIKE ROBESON
ONCE AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
WORTHINGTON ENTERPRISES, UH, IN
SUPPORT. LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU. FAMILY PAPPAS, NELA,
PAPPAS AND ASSOCIATES. WE ARE IN
A BETWEEN, UH WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION YET. UM BUT WE WANTED
ON BEHALF OF ANIMAL HEALTH
INSTITUTE, THE MANUFACTURERS AND
PRODUCERS OF ANIMAL MEDICINES,
AND WE BELIEVE THAT WITH THE
ADDITION OF THE AMENDMENTS
AROUND PESTICIDES THAT LOOPS US
IN WE ARE FEDERALLY REGULATED
AND LOOKING. WE HAD A GOOD
CONVERSATION WITH TINA YESTERDAY
AND LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEMBERS DAVID
GONZALEZ TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS OF MS PAPPAS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH, UH, THE
AUTHOR. OK, THANK YOU. OK THOSE
WE HAVE OPPOSITION. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO COME UP. FOUR
MINUTES. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS. UH NICOLE QUINON IS
REPRESENTING THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
GRET IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1143.
OUR MEMBERS MANUFACTURE SEVERAL
OF THE PRODUCTS INCLUDED IN THE
SCOPE OF THIS BILL FROM
PESTICIDES, INCLUDING HOUSEHOLD
PRODUCTS LIKE DISINFECTANTS TO
AEROSOL PRODUCTS TO AUTOMOTIVE
PRODUCTS AND OTHERS. FIRST I
WANNA SAY WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS
FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE
WITH US ON THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC.
WE DO HAVE A HISTORY OF WORKING
WELL TOGETHER ON TOUGH ISSUES,
AND WE COMMITTED TO DOING THE
SAME ON THIS BILL AS WELL,
HOWEVER, UM, WE DO BELIEVE
ADDITIONAL STUDY IS WARRANTED
PRIOR TO PASSING ANOTHER LARGE E
PR PROGRAM. HAZARDOUS WASTE IN
CALIFORNIA IS COMPLICATED. THE
STATE HAS ADOPTED CRITERIA TO
DETERMINE WHAT IS HAZARDOUS
WASTE, RESULTING IN A NUMBER OF
ADDITIONAL PRODUCTS BEING
MANAGED AS HÌ HÌ W, THEN WOULD
BE IN OTHER STATES OR UNDER
FEDERAL RULES AS PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROLS HAZARDOUS WASTE
MANAGEMENT PLAN. WHICH IS DUE IN
2025 Dð Tð S¼ E INTENDS TO
EVALUATE SEVERAL ISSUES RELATED
TO HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT IN
THE STATE, INCLUDING THE
CRITERIA USED IN CALIFORNIA TO
DETERMINE WHAT IS HAZARDOUS.
THIS PLAN WILL ALSO INCLUDE A
WASTE REDUCTION IN CAPACITY
ASSURANCE STRATEGY AS CAPACITY
TO MANAGE IT. HAZARDOUS WASTE
WITHIN THE STATE HAS DECREASED.
WE BELIEVE THIS WORK WILL BE
INCREDIBLY INFORMATIVE ON HOW TO
BETTER MANAGE HÌ HÌ W IN THE
STATE. AND WHILE WE APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO CLARIFY THE SCOPE OF THE
PROGRAM, WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
THIS WOULD CREATE UNFAIR
TREATMENT UNDER THE LAW, WHERE
MANUFACTURERS REQUIRED TO JOIN
THE PR WOULD BE SUBSIDIZING
PRODUCTS WHICH ARE NOT IN THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL BUT STILL MEET
THE CRITERIA FOR HÌ HÌ W,
ADDRESSING THE CRITERIA ITSELF
WOULD CREATE A MORE EVEN PLAYING
FIELD AND LESS CONFUSION FOR
CONSUMERS AS THE FIRST STEP
TOWARDS STRENGTHENING EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PROGRAMS. WE
ALSO SUPPORT CONDUCTING A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT TO FORM BASELINE OF
GOAL SETTING AND DETERMINE THE
CORRECT POLICY RESPONSES. WE
RECOGNIZE E PR CAN BE A
SUCCESSFUL IN CERTAIN
APPLICATIONS, BUT THAT DOESN'T
MEAN IT IS THE ONLY OPTION
PASSING LEGISLATION BEFORE IT
NEEDS ASSESSMENT HAS BEEN
CONDUCTED. AND Dð Tð S¼ èC HAS
SUFFICIENTLY EVALUATED. THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE CRITERIA IS
PREMATURE AND COULD BE AN
INEFFICIENT USE OF THE STATE'S
MANUFACTURERS AND CONSTITUENT
RESOURCES. LASTLY CALIFORNIA
RECENTLY ENACTED S¼ B 54, THE
MOST COMPREHENSIVE AND RIGOROUS
E PR PROGRAM IN THE UM, SENATOR
ALLEN KNOWS IT WELL AND DESIGNED
, WHICH IS DESIGNED TO MANAGE
PACKAGING AND WASTE AND SOURCE
REDUCTION TO BE SUCCESSFUL. THIS
PROGRAM DEMANDS THE RESOURCES
AND TIME OF MANY OF THE SAME
COMPANIES WITHIN THE SCOPE OF
THIS BILL ACROSS DIVERSE
INDUSTRIES, AS WELL AS STATE
STAFF WHO ARE CURRENTLY
IMPLEMENTING THE PROGRAM, SO WE
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO ALLOW S¼
B 54 TO BE FULLY IMPLEMENTED
BEFORE LAYING LAYERING NEW E PR
E PR PROGRAMS ON TOP OF IT. FOR
THESE REASONS, WE ARE OPPOSED TO
B. 40 THREE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, UH, THOSE WISHING TO
REGISTER OPPOSITION HERE IN
1200. THANK YOU, MISTER. VICE
CHAIR. DON KEPKE WITH MCHUGH
KEMPKE PR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION, ALSO IN
OPPOSITION, FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY MS QUINONEZ. WE DO,
HOWEVER, LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SENATOR
AND SPONSORS. I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, KELLY
LARUE WITH THE AMERICAN CLEANING
INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, TIM SS WITH THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL. WE
DO HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
WORKING ON E PR ISSUES
CONSTRUCTIVELY AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING THAT WORK. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. I DON'T SEE ANYBODY ELSE
UP THERE, SO WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DIOCESE QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. SENATOR SKINNER. A GOOD
BILL, AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR BRINGING IT FORWARD. I
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AND
I'LL MOVE IT. YEAH, I HAVE A
MOTION ANY FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
SEEING NON CENTER ALLEN, YOU MAY
CLOSE. I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION. I REALLY DO. LOOK
FORWARD TO, UM, YOU KNOW, THIS
IS ALWAYS HARD GETTING THE
DETAILS AND THERE ARE DIFFERENT
DETAILS. THIS IS THIS IS A
DIFFERENT SIMILAR FRAMEWORK TO
54, BUT A DIFFERENT SET OF
PRODUCTS. AND SO I DO APPRECIATE
THAT. I APPRECIATE THOSE
DISTINCTIONS AND UM, I. I WILL
SAY WE'VE GOT A SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL BURDEN CURRENTLY ON
OUR CITIES AND COUNTIES. AND YOU
KNOW EVERY STEP OF THE WAY THAT
YOU KNOW, CITIES AND COUNTIES
HAVE BEEN SUCH AN IMPORTANT
PARTNER HERE. I MEAN,
ULTIMATELY, THIS IS, YOU KNOW,
BURDENING OUR RATEPAYERS AND
THAT DOESN'T EVEN START TO GET
INTO THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
HEALTH CONCERNS ASSOCIATED WITH
WITH HAZARDOUS PRODUCTS. SO UM,
THAT'S WHY WE BELIEVE WE REALLY
CAN'T WAIT TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM LOOK FORWARD TO THE
NEGOTIATIONS AND CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WE'RE GOING TO BE
HAVING WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
VARIOUS REPRESENTATIVES FROM UM
FROM INDUSTRY BUT CERTAINLY DO
APPRECIATE WOULD APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
RESPECT FOR US WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU. CALL THE ROLL,
PLEASE. SB 1143. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AND REREFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. SENATORS
ALLEN ALLEN, I DALLY. AY, NÓ
GONZALEZ HURTADO. MENJIVAR
MENJIVAR. I WIN. YOU DON'T WANT
NÓ SKINNER SKINNER. I. OK, LET'S
UH LET'S THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
EVERYBODY UM, LET'S CALL CENTER
SKINNER. TO THE DÍAS TO PRESENT
S¼ B 903.
THANK YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
PLEASED TO PRESENT S¼ B 903. UM
THIS COMMITTEE IS FAMILIAR WITH
PF, ALSO DUBBED AS FOREVER
CHEMICALS BECAUSE OF THEIR
UBIQUITOUS USE THE FOREVER
CHEMICALS IS BECAUSE THEY
PERSIST. THEY DON'T BREAK DOWN.
BUT THE NOTION OF THEIR
UBIQUITOUS USES THEY ARE NOW
PRESENT IN SO MANY PRODUCTS. SO
MUCH PACKAGING SO MUCH
EVERYTHING. AND ONCE THEY GET
INTO OUR SOILS OR WATERWAYS,
THEY'RE ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO GET
RID OF TO THE POINT THAT TODAY.
98% OF CALIFORNIANS. 98% SO ONLY
2% OF US WE PUT IN THIS
CATEGORY. HAVE MEASURABLY
DETECTABLE LEVELS OF PFAS IN
THEIR BLOOD. AND PFAS HAS A
RANGE OF HEALTH HARMS NOW I
OPENED IT WITH WORD FAMILIAR
WITH THIS BECAUSE A NUMBER OF
BILLS HAVE BEEN PRESENTED OVER
THE YEARS BEFORE EQ. BUT THOSE
BILLS HAVE APPROACHED. LET'S GET
PF OUT OF THIS PRODUCT. LET'S
GET PF OUT OF THAT ONE. AND I'VE
SUPPORTED THEM. THOSE ARE GOOD,
BUT YOU KNOW WHEN WE LOOK LONG
TERM OF THE LEGS, HISTORY
LEGISLATE. LEGISLATURES HISTORY
THERE HAS BEEN AN ATTEMPT TO TRY
TO APPROACH SUCH TOXIC
SUBSTANCES AS PFAS IN A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY, RATHER THAN
JUST A ONE OFF. AND SO WHAT? MY
BILL IS PROVIDING IS A
COMPREHENSIVE SCIENCE BASED
APPROACH SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO TAKE EACH TIME. PFAS IS
INTRODUCED INTO A NEW PRODUCT
AND TRY TO BÀN THAT PARTICULAR
USE IN THAT PRODUCT, BUT RATHER
HAVE A FORMAT WHERE DTSC WORKS,
AND THERE IS WHEN PFAS IS AN
ESSENTIAL USE IN A PRODUCT THERE
IS NOT AN ALTERNATIVE OR THE
PRODUCT ITSELF IS SO NECESSARY
IN A MEDICAL DEVICE, FOR EXAMPLE
, THAT THERE IS NÓ OTHER PRODUCT
AVAILABLE THAT PFAS WOULD
CONTINUE TO BE USED, BUT WHERE
PFAS IS, IN EFFECT, WHAT WE
MIGHT CALL ELECTIVE WHERE IT IS
NOT NECESSARY OR ESSENTIAL TO
THE FUNCTIONING OF THE PROJECT
THAT THERE IS ALTERNATIVES TO
THAT. THEN IT WOULD NOT BE AND
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
ESTABLISH IN THIS BILL RATHER
THAN US HAVING TO FACE TRYING TO
ELIMINATE EACH AND EVERY NEW
PRODUCT THAT MIGHT HAVE PFAS AND
STILL FACING THIS INCREDIBLE
CONTAMINATION IN OUR WATERWAYS
IN OUR SUBWAYS AND THE EFFECT IT
HAS ON HEALTH, AND OF COURSE, I
COULD TALK A LOT ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT. IT'S AN ENDOCRINE
DISRUPTOR. IT'S A CARCINOGEN
VARIOUS THINGS, BUT ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES THAT WE'RE NOW,
UM, MEDICAL SCIENCE. THE
RESEARCH IS SHOWING IS IT ACT ON
FERTILITY RATES. WE'RE TALKING
THE FERTILITY OF MEN AND WOMEN,
NOT JUST WOMEN ABILITY FOR A
WOMAN TO CARRY A BABY, BUT
LITERALLY FERTILITY RATES IN
BOTH MALES AND FEMALES. SO WITH
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT SPEAK TO
IT AND HAPPY TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION AND ANSWER QUESTIONS.
SO WE HAVE ANNA REID, WHO IS THE
SENIOR SCIENTIST AT NRDC AND
JESSICA GOUGER, WHOSE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SANITATION AGENCIES. PERCENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. UH, ENERGY.
èC SUPPORTS STRONG ACTION ON
PFAS, WHICH NOW CONSTITUTE A
MAJOR GLOBAL ENVIRONMENTAL AND
PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT. HAVE BEEN
LINKED TO SERIOUS HEALTH EFFECTS
, INCLUDING CANCER, KIDNEY AND
LIVER DAMAGE, DEVELOPMENTAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE EFFECTS AND
SUPPRESSION OF THE IMMUNE
SYSTEM. CALIFORNIA. PUBLIC
HEALTH GOALS FOR BFAS ARE BELOW
THE PARTS PER TRILLION RANGE AND
THE EQUIVALENT OF ONE DROP OF
WATER AND 20 OLYMPIC SIZE POOLS.
BECAUSE OF WIDESPREAD CHRONIC
EXPOSURES TO THESE HARMFUL
CHEMICALS. HEALTH CARE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PFAS HAVE BEEN
ESTIMATED TO RANGE IN THE TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS PER YEAR
IN THE U S¼ COMPOUNDING THIS
PROBLEM, PFAS ARE EXTREMELY
PERSISTENT OR TRANSFORM INTO,
UH, EXTREMELY PERSISTENT P VS
LASTING TO HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF YEARS IN THE ENVIRONMENT
WITHOUT LACK OF SAFE DISPOSAL
METHODS THAT THEY WILL CONTINUE
TO BUILD UP UNLESS WE REDUCE
BFAS USE. IN ADDITION, THEY TEND
TO BE HIGHLY MOBILE, MAKING
CONTAMINATION HARD TO CONTROL
AND CLEAN UP IN CALIFORNIA PUM
CONTAMINATED DRINKING WATER
SOURCES SERVING UP TO 25 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITH CONTAMINATION
MORE PREVALENT IN STATE
IDENTIFIED DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. PFAS CAN ALSO
BACCULA, AS THE SENATOR SAID
THERE, UH, NOW PRESENT IN 98% OF
OUR BODIES. THE MAGNITUDE OF
THIS PROBLEM DEMANDS
COMPREHENSIVE AND EFFICIENT
ACTION TO REDUCE THESE EXPOSURES
, WHICH IS WHY SCIENTISTS FROM
AROUND THE WORLD ARE URGING
CLASS BASED APPROACH FOR
MANAGING PFAS, WHICH INCLUDES
THE PHASE OUT OF ALL NON
ESSENTIAL USES OF PFAS.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY BANNED
THE USE OF PFAS IN MULTIPLE
PRODUCT CATEGORIES. YET THERE'S
STILL MANY UNNECESSARY USES OF
PFAS ACROSS THE ECONOMY. LAST
YEAR. I CO-AUTHORED A PAPER ON
ESSENTIAL USE APPROACH FOR
MANAGING HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS.
THE BASIC IDEA IS THAT CHEMICALS
OF CONCERN LIKE PFAS SHOULD NOT
BE USED UNLESS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY. THE APPROACH IS
PRAGMATIC AND FOCUSES ON
DISCONTINUING UNNECESSARY USES
OF TOXIC CHEMICALS, WHILE
ALLOWING ESSENTIAL USES TO
CONTINUE UNTIL SAFER
ALTERNATIVES ARE DEVELOPED.
OUTLINING AND DIRECTING CLEAR
CRITERIA FOR G Tð S¼ èC TO
IMPLEMENT THIS APPROACH. S¼ B
903 RESPONDS TO THE MAGNITUDE
AND URGENCY OF THE PS CRISIS. WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS JESSICA
GAER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
A BROAD COALITION REPRESENTING
WATER, WASTE WATER AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S¼ B 90 THREE PF
CONTAMINATION OF OUR PUBLIC
RESOURCES IS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT WATER QUALITY
CHALLENGES OF OUR TIME. WE KNOW
FROM RECENT DATA FROM THE
WATERBOARD STATEWIDE PS
MONITORING AND REPORTING ORDER
THAT THESE UBIQUITOUS CHEMICALS
ARE PRESENT ACROSS THE SPECTRUM
OF SERVICES WE PROVIDE, AND WE
ARE NOT USING THEM. SO THIS IS
CONTAMINATION FROM PFAS. IN
COMMERCE THAT ULTIMATELY ENDS UP
IN OUR WATERSHEDS AND WASTE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS AS PUBLIC
AGENCIES PROVIDING ESSENTIAL
PUBLIC SERVICES. AFFORDABILITY
IS CENTRAL TO ALL THAT. WE DO
REGULATORY LIMITS FOR PFOS AND
DRINKING WATER, GUIDED BY HUMAN
HEALTH THRESHOLDS ARE CURRENTLY
BEING CONSIDERED BY U S¼ èC P
A. THE EPA ESTIMATES THAT
DRINKING WATER COMPLIANCE FOR
MEETING THIS NEW REGULATORY
LIMIT, WHICH IS ONLY FOR SIX PF
S¼ CHEMICALS WILL LIKELY RESULT
IN COSTS TO UTILITIES BETWEEN
650 MILLION TO A BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. WE ANTICIPATE THE COST
WILL BE MAGNITUDES HIGHER AS
ONE'S. THE LIMIT IS IMPOSED, IT
CAN BECOME A DE FACTO LIMIT FOR
OTHER REGULATORY ACTIONS, SUCH
AS BEING INCORPORATED INTO OUR
DISCHARGE PERMITS BY REFERENCE,
THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE POLICY
APPROACH TO REDUCE PFAS
CONCENTRATIONS IN OUR PUBLIC
RESOURCES IS SOURCE CONTROL. S¼
B 903 PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK TO
SYSTEMATICALLY REDUCE SOURCES OF
CONTAMINATION IN A WAY THAT
DOESN'T BURDEN THE RATE PAYING
PUBLIC TO CLEAN IT UP ON THE
BACK END. FOR THESE REASONS. OUR
COALITION STRONGLY SUPPORTS S¼ B
903 AND WOULD URGE YOUR IVO ALL
RIGHT, FOLKS WHO WANT TO WEIGH
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. HØI BILL
ALL FOR ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING
GROUP IS A CO SPONSOR AND ALSO
HERE FOR CLIMATE ACTION.
CALIFORNIA CLEAN PRODUCTION
ACTION CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AND INTEGRATED RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HELLO ANDREA VENTURA
COSPONSOR CLEAN WATER ACTION
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB, CALIFORNIA, SAN FRANCISCO
BAYKEEPER PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY IN LOS ANGELES,
SAN FRANCISCO PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY, SANTA
CRUZ CLIMATE ACTION NETWORK AND
THE BROCKOVICH FOUNDATION. THANK
YOU. MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAT
MORAN WITH ERIN REID AND
ASSOCIATES, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS MULLAN FOR HEAL
THE BAIRN STRONG SUPPORT. MM. IN
SOME WAY, AND UM, REPRESENTING
SACRAMENTO, 350 IN CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE ACTION AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NANCY BIER, BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNER, CO SPONSOR
OF THE LEGISLATION. ALSO HERE IN
UH ON BEHALF OF THE GREEN
SCIENCE POLICY INSTITUTE AND THE
NATIONAL PF S¼ CONTAMINATION
COALITION ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. HèA. SHARMA ON BEHALF OF
PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK IN
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM AND STRONG SUPPORT. FOR
SILOS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL AND ITS ASSOCIATION,
NORTH AMERICA LEGISLATIVE TASK
FORCE AND STRONG SUPPORT.
REBECCA MARCUS ON BEHALF OF CPG
AND THE CENTER FOR FOOD, SAFETY
AND SUPPORT. THANKS ARENAS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA WASTE IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, CATHY
VELLA WITH EAST BAY MUNICIPAL
UTILITY DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. Kò ROBINSON
ON BEHALF OF SEVENTH GENERATION
AND STORIA STAFF AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR.
MEGAN SOBER IS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SPORT. MARTIN
RADOSEVIC ON BEHALF OF SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CHELSEA
HAINES ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT BETH OLA ON BEHALF OF
WATER REUSE, CALIFORNIA INLAND
EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY AND
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SHAKE
STATE WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ARIANA CREED
WITH CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS.ORG
AND SUPPORT AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL, HEALTH AND
JUSTICE, FACTS, GRANDPARENTS AND
ACTION MAMAS NORTH COUNTY EQUITY
AND JUSTICE, INTERFAITH
COALITION FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND A THANK YOU. MELISSA
SPARKS CRANS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
HEIDI SANBORN AT THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTION COUNCIL ON
SUPPORT THERE A LITTLE WITH  N R
Dð èC REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR
SEA HUGGER GO GREEN INITIATIVE
RESPONSIBLE PURCHASING NETWORK
IN THE VISIBLE AUTO PASADENA
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR B  N S¼
UPPF ACTION GROUP 350, THE
SACRAMENTO RETHINK DISPOSABLE IN
CALIFORNIA BARRIER ENVIRONMENTAL
VOTERS. THANK YOU. JANET COX FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR SKINNER. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. YOU CAN COME UP,
USE TWO OF THE SEATS HERE.
ALL RIGHT, YOU GO FIRST, A OK?
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR CHAIRMAN,
THANK YOU AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY THIS AFTERNOON. I'M
CHRIS, CURRENT PRESIDENT AND èC
E Ó OF A G èC AMERICA. A G èC
HAS MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
MANUFACTURING BUSINESSES HERE IN
THE U S¼, ALL OF WHICH ARE GOING
TO BE IMPACTED BY S¼ B 90 THREE.
THERE IS A NUMBER OF ISSUES WITH
THIS BILL, BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THIS
BILL WILL IMPACT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PRODUCTS. THAT ARE
CURRENTLY BEING SOLD AND USED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT
WILL INCLUDE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT FOR
TRANSITIONING THE STATE TO
RENEWABLE ENERGY TO GET OUT AND
BECOME CARBON NEUTRAL AND AFFECT
THE BENEFITS TO THOSE OWN AND
LAYER AND AS WELL AS THE NEED TO
HAVE GOOD RENEWABLE ENERGY FOR
THE FUTURE OF THE STATE IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT INCLUDES ELECTRIC
VEHICLES THAT INCLUDES, UM
HYDROGEN FUEL CELLS THAT INCLUDE
SOLAR PANELS, AND IT INCLUDES
WINDMILLS, THEY WOULD ALL BE
AFFECTED BY THIS BILL. ONE THING
THAT'S IMPORTANT IS THIS
LEGISLATION TREATS ALL 14,000
PLUS COMPOUNDS THAT ARE
CLASSIFIED AS PFOS AS THE SAME
THEY'RE NOT. ONE OF THE GREAT
EXAMPLE IS FLU POLYMERS, WHICH
IS SOMETHING THAT OUR COMPANY
MAKES AND SELLS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES. LAURA POLYMERS
ARE CONSIDERED AS A POLYMER OF
LOW CONCERN UNDER
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
STANDARDS THAT BASICALLY MEANS
THAT IT IS IT HAS AN
INSIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENT. MORE
IMPORTANTLY, FOUR POLYMERS ARE
QUITE DIFFERENT FROM OTHER PFOS
COMPOUNDS. THERE ARE INERT, THEY
DO NOT DISSOLVE IN WATER.
THEY'RE NOT BIOAVAILABLE. THEY
CAN'T GET INTO YOUR BLOODSTREAM
AND THEY'RE EXTREMELY DURABLE
AND RELIABLE. AND THAT'S WHY
THEY ARE EXCELLENT MATERIALS FOR
THINGS LIKE INSULATING WIRE IN
ELECTRIC VEHICLES OR INSULATING
WIRE IN AIRPLANES, OR, UH,
MEMBRANES THAT ARE ESSENTIAL FOR
HYDROGEN FUEL CELLS TO WORK OR
FUEL HOSES THAT ARE NECESSARY IN
MULTIPLE APPLICATIONS. UM I
COULD GO ON WITH A LAUNDRY LIST.
MEDICAL DEVICES IS ANOTHER AREA
WHERE FOUR POLYMERS ARE USED,
INCLUDING IN THE WIRING IN THOSE
DEVICES. BUT ONE THING IS FOR
SURE IF THIS BILL IS PASSED,
THOSE ALL OF THOSE PRODUCTS
COULD POTENTIALLY BE BANNED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS OF
2030. OR THEY WOULD BE SUBJECT
TO A VERY, VERY DIFFICULT AND
EXPENSIVE REGULATORY PROCESS.
THAT'S GOING TO PUT A HUGE
BURDEN ON Dð Tð S¼ E.
ESTABLISHES A PROCESS THAT WILL
SUBJECT COMPANIES LIKE OURSELVES
TO HAVING TO HAVE BASICALLY A
FIVE YEAR BUSINESS PLAN. NÓ
GUARANTEE YOU CAN SELL YOUR
PRODUCTS IN THE FUTURE AND
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO BASICALLY
PUT FORTH A WHOLE BUNCH OF
STUDIES AND OTHER INFORMATION
EVERY FIVE YEARS IN ORDER TO TRY
TO MAINTAIN YOUR PRODUCT. THAT
IS NOT A NOT ONLY A PRACTICAL
BUT IT IS NOT WORKABLE FOR Dð Tð
S¼ èC AND WILL CAUSE A
SIGNIFICANT BURDEN AND INCREASE
IN COSTS FOR THEM TO TRY TO
REGULATE THAT. SO THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE. WE
HAVE PROVIDED WRITTEN TESTIMONY.
WE'RE CERTAINLY HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE BILL SPONSORED TO
CONSIDER HOW BEST TO APPROACH
THIS ISSUE IN THE FUTURE. BUT WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF S¼ B 90
THREE. THANK YOU. MR ALA. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ALLEN, MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, ADAM REGULARLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND OPPOSITION TO S¼ B
90 THREE AS A JOB KILLER.
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA FACES A
CONUNDRUM CERTAIN PFOS
CHEMISTRIES THAT CONTAMINATE
WATERWAYS RAISES PROFOUND
CONCERNS. THESE CHEMISTRIES ARE
ALSO ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO A
VAST RANGE OF PRODUCTS THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR BOTH CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS AND CALIFORNIA'S LONG
TERM POLICY GOALS. A LOT OF
THOSE DISCUSSIONS TODAY REVOLVE
AROUND DECARBONISING, CALIFORNIA
BEING A LEADER ON CLIMATE CHANGE
OR FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE AND
BUILDING HOUSING IN A STATE THAT
IS SEVERELY FACING CRITICAL
SHORTAGES. WITHOUT WIND AND
SOLAR POWER. YOU CANNOT LEAD ON
CLIMATE CHANGE WITHOUT HYDROGEN
FUEL CELLS OR LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES. YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
BE MOVING CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION FLEET TO ZERO
EMISSIONS. PS ARE EMPLOYED IN
SEISMIC DAMPENERS TO USE TO MAKE
STRUCTURES AND BRIDGES MORE RES.
RESILIENT TO EARTHQUAKES, WHICH
WE JUST SAW IN THE INTERNATIONAL
NEWS IS SIGNIFICANT RISKS
INVOLVED WITH ARBITRARILY
BANNING WITHOUT FULLY
CONSIDERING THE IMPACTS OF THE
POLICY. WITHOUT SEMICONDUCTORS
LITERALLY ARE SUCCESS STORY IN
SILICON VALLEY WOULD NOT EXIST
AS WE KNOW IT TODAY. THESE ARE
NOT HYPERBOLIC STATEMENTS. ALL
OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES RELY ON
THESE CHEMISTRIES. THE BILL
ITSELF ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THERE
ARE UNAVOIDABLE USES THROUGH
THIS EXEMPTION PROCESS. DESPITE
THAT ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF
UNAVOIDABLE USES S¼ NINE THREE
FAILS TO BALANCE THESE COMPETING
CONCERNS IN AN UNWORKABLE
FRAMEWORK. I'LL FOCUS JUST ON
THE PETITION PROCESS THAT
MANUFACTURERS ARE EXPECTED TO GO
THROUGH. FIRST IT BANS ALL PS
PRODUCTS IN 2030. THAT MEANS
IMMEDIATELY THESE CONSUMERS
CANNOT GET, FOR EXAMPLE, AN
ELECTRIC CAR BECAUSE THE E VÆ,
UH TECHNOLOGY OR THE LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES RELIES ON PFAS. THEY
CANNOT GET PACEMAKERS. THEY
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO GET
COMPUTERS THE SEMICONDUCTOR
INDUSTRY IS RELYING ON INSIDE
THE CONDUITS. ONLY IN 2030. DOES
THE BILL ALLOW YOU AFTER IT'S
BEEN BANNED TO THEN PETITION
DTSC IN A TWO YEAR WINDOW TO GET
THE EXEMPTION. THOSE PRODUCTS
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO BE SOLD UNTIL
THAT EXEMPTION IS GRANTED, AS MY
COLLEAGUE HAS NOTED TENS, IF NOT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PETITIONS ARE GOING TO INUNDATE
THE AGENCY. ALL OF THOSE
PRODUCTS REMAIN BANAN. UNTIL THE
AGENCY WADES THROUGH EACH 11 BY
ONE. THIS PROCESS WILL TAKE
DECADES. SO EVEN IF YOU AGREE
THAT THERE ARE CRITICAL PRODUCTS
WITH UNAVOIDABLE USES LIKE A
PACEMAKER, THERE WILL BE YEARS
WHERE THEY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
BE SOLD IN CALIFORNIA THAT THAT
IS AN UNACCEPTABLE AND UN
UNWORKABLE FRAMEWORK FOR
CONSUMERS FOR INDUSTRY AND FOR
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE PERSONALLY
SPOKEN TO INDUSTRIES ACROSS
SECTORS WHO SAY THAT IF THIS
BILL WERE TO PASS, THEY WOULD
HAVE NÓ OTHER CHOICE BUT TO
LEAVE CALIFORNIA. COW CHAMBER
HAS A RECORD OF YEARS OF GOOD
FAITH. ENGAGEMENT ON WORKABLE
FRAMEWORKS IN THE PFAS ARENA
CHAIR. WE WORKED ON FIREFIGHTING
FOAM. I'VE WORKED ON COSMETICS,
JUVENILE PRODUCTS, COOKWARE AND
MORE TO PHASE OUT UNDER A
WORKABLE PS REGULATIONS. IT IS
VITAL THAT CALIFORNIA GETS IT
RIGHT BECAUSE AN UNWORKABLE
FRAMEWORK IS NÓ FRAMEWORK AT ALL
FOR THE INDUSTRY. FOR ALL OF
THESE REASONS, WE MUST STRONGLY
OPPOSE S¼ P 903 AS A JOB KILLER.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR NÓ VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, LET'S HEAR
, UH FOLKS WHO WANT TO VOICE
THEIR OPPOSITION. PLEASE COME UP
AND STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. SARAH PALOMO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. WE'RE IN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. ALL WITH
GREENBERG TRAURIG ON BEHALF OF
TWO CLIENTS, KIA AND THE WESTERN
STATES PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU. FAIRNESS ON BELF OF
THE NATIONAL MARINE
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. STEPHANIE MORE ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION AND THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION.
MARGIE LEE SAMPSON ADVISORS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF FOOD
PRODUCERS IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MOIRA TOP ON BEHALF
OF BIO. COM CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON,
LARISSA CSPI, ITS ON BEHALF OF
THE TOY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON,
ASHLEY WALKER ON BEHALF OF THE
MOTORCYCLE INDUSTRY COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION. DÂN ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL
IN OPPOSITION. NICOLE QUINONE IS
WITH THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
WITH AN OPPO UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. THANK YOU. EMILY
PAPPAS, RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED ON
BEHALF OF ANIMAL HEALTH
INSTITUTE, WHO, UM, USES A PF AS
ONE OF THEIR ACTIVE INGREDIENTS
IN THEIR ANIMAL MEDICINE. THANK
YOU DON KEPKE WITH MCH KEPKE
PADRONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION, AIR
CONDITIONING, HEATING AND
REFRIGERATION INSTITUTE AND THE
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, KELLY HIT ON
BEHALF OF THE PLASTICS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, SILVIO
FERRARI ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND THE ASSOCIATION OF HOME
APPLIANCE MANUFACTURERS POST.
GOOD AFTERNOON, RJ CERVANTES ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN CLEANING
INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. TIM SHES, WITH THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL, ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. KELLY LE ROUX ON ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN FORESTS
AND PAPER ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. DENNIS I ON BEHALF
OF THE SUSTAINABLE PFOS ACTION
NETWORK. WE ARE ACTUALLY
OPPOSING, LESS AMENDED BASED ON
S¼. WE PROMOTE A RISK-BASED
SYSTEM AS WELL AS WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WE WOULDN'T USE
THE GREEN CHEMISTRY PROGRAM THAT
WE ALREADY HAVE YOU. JERRY
DESMOND ON BEHALF OF PLUMBING
MANUFACTURERS INTERNATIONAL AND
THE NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN MEDAL
FINISHING ASSOCIATIONS IN
OPPOSITION. DAVID GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES, AS WELL AS THE TRUCK
AND ENGINE MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION. RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NÓ MORE. LET US
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
FOR QUESTIONS, COMMENTS.
THOUGHTS. UH, SENATOR DOLLY.
SENATOR MINAR. THANK YOU,
GENTLEMEN. SENATOR I'D LIKE TO
IF YOU CAN, UM ANSWER SOME OF
THE CONCERNS BECAUSE AND I KNOW
IN YOUR ONE OF THE EARLIER
THINGS YOU MENTIONED YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE MEDICAL DEVICES THAT
YOU WANNA MAKE SURE THERE IS AN
EXEMPTION FOR THAT. BUT YOU CAN
USE SPEAK AND ADDRESS HOW LONG
UM, THAT PROCESS WILL TAKE AND
WILL IN FACT, ONLY START AFTER
THIS BÀN AFTER 2030. I'LL START
WITH THAT QUESTION. I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION SO I WANT TO JUST
AS A PRECURSOR, SO CLEARLY WITH
THE LEVEL OF OPPOSITION THAT WAS
SHOWN IT SHOWS HOW UBIQUITOUS
THIS PARTICULAR CATEGORY OF
CHEMICALS ARE AND IF THEY WERE
MORE BENIGN AND NOT EVER PRESENT
, THEN I WOULD NOT BE TRYING TO
DO SUCH COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
BUT BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT BENIGN,
AND THEY ARE SO UBIQUITOUS AND
THEY DO NOT BREAK DOWN, WE NEED
A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH. NOW WE
ARE WORKING WITH SPECIFIC ANSWER
TO THE QUESTION. MY OFFICE IS
WORKING WITH Dð Tð S¼ èC NOW TO
FIGURE OUT AN APPROPRIATE
TIMELINE. THE BILL IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS. IT IS CLEARLY AN
AMBITIOUS BILL. AND I ALREADY
ANTICIPATE WE WILL BE ADJUSTING
DATES DATES SUCH THAT THE DATE
FOR YOU KNOW, THE ACTUAL BÀN
WOULD BE MOVED OUT AND ALSO THE
DATE FOR WHEN ANY, UH, YOU KNOW,
ENTITIES COULD START. REQUESTING
REVIEW WOULD BE MUCH SOONER, SO
THAT WOULD BE A MUCH EARLIER
TIME FRAME WITHIN A YEAR OR TWO.
EVEN FROM NOW, SO THERE WAS A
LONG LONG ON RAMP FOR THAT
ABILITY TO DETERMINE THE
ESSENTIAL USES, AND WE'RE ALSO
CONSIDERING WHETHER THERE IS THE
ABILITY TO LOOK NOW AND WE'RE
TALKING TO Dð Tð S¼ èC ABOUT
THAT WHETHER THERE'S ALREADY
SOME EXPLICITLY ESSENTIAL USES
THAT WE MIGHT INCLUDE THAT
ALREADY HAVE THE SO THAT YOU
KNOW WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO
NECESSARILY GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS. UM SO THOSE ARE THE
KINDS OF THINGS WE ARE LOOKING
AT RIGHT NOW, IN TERMS OF
AMENDING AND MEETING WITH Dð Tð
S¼ èC SO THAT WE CAN DESIGN
SOMETHING THAT IS MORE EFFICIENT
AND EFFECTIVE. UM AND I. I
DIDN'T MENTION IN MY OPENING
THAT BOTH THE STATES OF MAIN AND
MINNESOTA HAVE SOME VERY SIMILAR
POLICIES AS THIS SO MUCH OF THIS
BILL WAS COPIED AFTER SO THEY
ARE AT LEAST BEGUN IN THIS
PROCESS, AND WE CAN LEARN FROM
THEM. BUT DID YOU NOTICE FROM
THE NUMBER OF WATER AGENCIES AND
WATER ASSOCIATIONS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE? THEY ARE CRYING FOR
THIS HELP, BECAUSE THEY ARE NOW
ALL OF OUR ALL OF OUR WATER
SOURCES ARE CONTAMINATED WITH
PFAS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT
COMMITMENT, SENATOR. I
APPRECIATE YOU CONTINUE TO WORK
AND REARRANGE THE DATES AND SO
FORTH. UM, LAST QUESTION ON
THIS, MR CHAIR IS WHAT DO WE
WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE?
ENFORCEMENT IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE THIS IS CAPTURING SO MUCH
CAN THE DEPARTMENT UM HANDLE
THIS KIND OF ENFORCEMENT. THAT'S
AN EXCELLENT QUESTION. THAT'S
ANOTHER THING THAT WE ARE
TALKING TO Dð Tð S¼ èC ABOUT
AND AS WE KNOW, WITH, UM, A
NUMBER OF OUR CALIFORNIA
STATUTES, WE THERE IS AN ELEMENT
OF WHAT DO WE CALL IT? GOODWILL
AND TRUST THAT ONCE WE PUT A
STATUTE INTO EFFECT, AND ONCE
THE REGS ARE DEVELOPED THAT THE
ENTITIES ARE FOLLOWING IT. NOW
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S ENTITIES
THAT DON'T ALWAYS AND SO THAT'S
WHEN ENFORCEMENT COMES IN. BUT
CERTAINLY WHAT IF WE LOOK AT
ALMOST ANY STATUTE THAT WE DO?
THERE IS ALMOST ALWAYS EMBEDDED
IN IT. A TRUST THAT THE AFFECTED
ENTITIES WILL FOLLOW THE LAW.
OK, SENATOR DOLLY! WELL, THANK
YOU, MR CHAIRMAN. SENATOR I KNOW
THAT SO FAR. I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I'M A LITTLE BIT
FRUSTRATED. UM ACTUALLY LAST, I
THINK I VOTED FOR ALMOST EVERY
SINGLE PFOS BILL THAT'S CAME
THROUGH HERE AND I UNDERSTAND
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE HEALTH
RISK. UM, THE FIREFIGHTERS WERE
THE FIRST ONES THAT EDUCATED ME
ON WHERE WE WHAT PFOS REALLY
WAS. UM SO AND LAST YEAR I ASKED
THIS COMMITTEE NOT ONCE. NOT
TWICE, BUT TWO OR THREE TIMES
THAT WE DO A STUDY A HEARING AND
ACTUALLY BRING EVERYBODY TO THE
TABLE. THE LOOK AT THAT WE HAD A
WHOLE BUNCH OF OPPOSITION. WE
HAD A WHOLE BUNCH OF SUPPORT.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
NEEDS MORE THAN A BILL GOING
FORWARD. THAT HAS A WHOLE HELL
OF A LOT IN IT. UM, AND A LOT
OF, UM UNCERTAINTY QUITE FRANKLY
, A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY AND I FOR
ME, UM, THAT'S THAT'S NOT HOW WE
SHOULD DO A SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. SO I'M AND I KNOW
THAT THE SENATOR CALLED ME. WE
TALKED ABOUT IT OVER THE BREAK.
UH AND THEN SHE ASKED ME TO COME
ON THE BILL AND I SAID WELCOME,
DANNY. AND YES, WELL, BUT I
ASKED FOR A HEARING. I ASKED FOR
HEARING. SO WE GET ALL THESE
PEOPLE ON THE TABLE AND WE
DIDN'T GET THAT. SO I'M A LITTLE
BIT FRUSTRATED WITH THAT,
BECAUSE I DO NUMBER ONE KNOW
THAT THERE'S CONCERN ABOUT
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND OUR
WATERWAYS AND I THINK THERE'S
GOING TO BE BILL AFTER BILL
AFTER BILL AND SO I SUGGESTED
THAT WE HAVE THAT WE DIDN'T GET
THAT. SO I HAVE, UH, I WANT YOU
TO BEAR WITH ME, MR CHAIRMAN,
BECAUSE THIS IS SOMETHING I DO
WANT TO NAIL DOWN BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. FIRST
OF ALL, YOU MENTIONED THE
MINNESOTA LAW. UM AND THIS KIND
OF MIRRORS THAT AND THEY'RE
HAVING ALL KINDS OF, I
RESEARCHED. THEY'RE HAVING ALL
KINDS OF PROBLEMS WITH THEIR LAW
AND THE THEIR DEPARTMENT BEING
ABLE TO HANDLE IT. SO NUMBER ONE
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT TRYING
TO PROCESS WHAT DID YOU WHAT DO
YOU WHAT DO YOU ENVISION FOR
THEM TO PROCESS ALL THIS
INFORMATION IN A TIMELY MANNER
TO GET DONE WHAT THE OPPOSITION
WAS ASKING ABOUT? WELL, THAT'S
WHY WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM
RIGHT NOW. AND SO I DON'T GET
HALF A DEFINITIVE ANSWER FOR
YOU. AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE ALSO
WE WILL BE MODIFYING IT WITH
DATES AND SUCH TO ADDRESS THOSE
THINGS SO THAT THAT MY FOLLOW UP
QUESTION IS ONE OF THE
OPPOSITION BROUGHT UP GREEN
CHEMISTRY. WE HAVE A AGENCY SET
WITH SCIENTISTS ABLE TO DO THE
WORK THAT WE AND I BELIEVE THAT
WAS A BIPARTISAN BILL THAT MADE
UP THE GREEN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL.
WHY DON'T WE USE THAT? Dð Tð S¼
èC IS ALREADY OVERWHELMED. WE
ARE. WE'RE IN SUB TWO. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO CONTINUE TO FUND ALL
THE THINGS THAT THEY HAVE TO DO.
AND QUITE FRANKLY, EVEN THE EVEN
THE MANUFACTURERS ARE COMING AND
HAVING PROBLEMS WITH Dð Tð S¼ E,
SO WHY NOT USE GREEN CHEMISTRY?
GREEN CHEMISTRY, AS YOU PROBABLY
ARE AWARE HAS EXISTED SINCE PRE
2008. I BELIEVE IT WAS 2006. AND
YET PF S¼, THE RESEARCH ABOUT
ITS HEALTH. HARMFUL HEALTH
IMPACTS AND ITS UBIQUITOUSNESS
AND ITS PRESENCE IN WATER, AND
IT'S DETECTED IN FETUSES. IT'S
DETECTED AT THE MOMENT OF BIRTH.
UM ALL OF THAT HAS BEEN OUT
THERE FOR YEARS. GREEN CHEMISTRY
HAS NOT TAKEN IT UP. SO
SOMETIMES WE JUST HAVE TO ACT.
OK, SO MY THE FOLLOW UP QUESTION
THAT WOULD BE SO ARE ALL THE
PFOS IS THE SAME. THEY ARE ALL
IN THAT CATEGORY OF CHEMICAL.
THEY ARE ALL FOREVER. THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY THERE'S ONE COULD
CERTAINLY GET INTO OK, THIS, UH
EIGHT OR 10 ARE THE MOST
UTILIZED OR THE MOST, YOU KNOW,
SO MAYBE IT SHOULD BE. SHOULD BE
REFINED DOWN TO, HOWEVER, IF WE
TAKE I JUST GIVE THE EXAMPLE OF
ROUNDUP. YOU KNOW, FOR YEARS WE
THOUGHT ROUNDUP WAS BENIGN. AND,
UH, UH, YOU KNOW, WE ALLOWED NOT
ONLY ALLOWED. I MEAN EVERYWHERE.
I WAS ON A PARK DISTRICT. IT WAS
. YEAH THIS IS THE SAFE, YOU
KNOW, UH, HERBICIDE OR WEED
KILLER. AND NOW WHAT? LOOK WHAT
WE KNOW ABOUT THAT PARTICULAR
WEED KILLER, SO IT'S PART OF
THIS IS THE PRECAUTIONARY
PRINCIPLE. AND IF THE IF IT IS
NOT AN ESSENTIAL USE THEN SHOULD
WE REALLY BE TAKING THE RISK?
WHO IS GOING TO DETERMINE THE
ESSENTIAL USE THINGS LIKE THE
OPPOSITION BROUGHT UP. ELECTRIC
BATTERIES, SOLAR PANELS, WIND
ENERGY. I MEAN, I GUESS YOU
COULD SAY THAT THOSE ARE EVERY
DAY. WE NEED ELECTRICITY EVERY
DAY. WE MIGHT ONE OF THE THINGS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH Dð Tð
S¼ èC IS WHETHER WE ARE ALREADY
IDENTIFY A SET OF PRODUCTS OR
USES THAT DO NOT HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE WHOLE PROOF PROCESS
BECAUSE RIGHT THAT THERE'S
ALREADY GOOD EVIDENCE THEY ARE
AND SO THEY THEY ARE ALLOWED. I
MEAN, THE WAY THE BILL IS
CONSTRUCTED IS THAT EVEN A
ALLOWABLE USE CAN BE CAN BE DTS
CAN STEP IN WHEN, AT CERTAIN
POINT, THERE IS CLEARLY AN
ALTERNATIVE OR CLEARLY A PRODUCT
THAT REPLACES IT RIGHT, BUT WE
MAY BE ABLE TO PUT SOME IN CæA
IN BEFOREHAND. ALL RIGHT. I
APPRECIATE THOSE, UH, ANSWERS TO
THE QUESTION. I DO HAVE ONE FOR
THE OPPOSITION THAT YOU I FORGOT
YOUR NAME, SIR. BUT IF I MAY, MR
CHAIR, SO, YOU TALKING ABOUT
DIFFERENT FORMS OF PS, CAN YOU?
CAN YOU MAYBE GIVE US A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON THAT A LITTLE BIT
OF THE DIFFERENCES OF PF? GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR AND THE, UM THERE ARE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PFAS. I MEAN,
THERE ARE ACTUALLY THREE
DIFFERENT GROUPINGS OF PFOS,
CHEMICALS OR SOLIDS. THERE'S
LIQUIDS. THERE'S GASSES. UM
THERE ARE CERTAINLY PFOS
CHEMICALS, WHICH ARE CLEARLY
IDENTIFIED AS BEING A PROBLEM.
PF Ó A PF Ó S¼ HÌ F  N A AND
THERE'S 6 TO 10 THAT ARE IN THE
DRINKING WATER. THEY'RE IN
GROUNDWATER, SO IT'S CERTAINLY A
MAJOR CONCERN. BUT FLORA
POLYMERS, FOR EXAMPLE, ARE A
SOLID AND THEY DON'T DEGRADE.
THEY DON'T DISSOLVE. THEY DON'T,
UM, BREAK DOWN OVER TIME, AND
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE SO GOOD IN
THE APPLICATIONS THAT THEY'RE
BEING USED FOR TODAY, AND THERE
ARE OTHER PFOS MATERIALS THAT
HAVE SIMILAR CHARACTERISTICS IN
THOSE OTHER GROUPS THAT I THINK
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERTS IN THOSE
MATERIALS WOULD TELL YOU. THERE
ARE REASONS THAT THEY ACTUALLY
ARE NOT SHOULD NOT BE CONSIDERED
IN THE SAME GROUP. SO YOU YOU
DON'T FIND FLOOR POLYMERS IN THE
GROUNDWATER OF CALIFORNIA. I
IT'S P FA PF S¼ HÌ F  N A AND
SIX OR SEVEN DIFFERENT ONES THAT
WILL SHOW UP. THOSE ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE CERTAINLY A CONCERN.
LEGISLATURE CAN CERTAINLY LOOK
AT IT AT DEALING WITH. YOU KNOW
FURTHER RESTRICTIONS IF THEY'RE
NEEDED IN THAT AREA, BUT
BROADENING IT TO INCLUDE ALL
COMPOUNDS. JUST NOT ONLY DOES IT
MAKE SENSE. IF YOU LISTEN TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE, WHO DID A
EXTENSIVE STUDY ON PFOS LAST
YEAR IN PRODUCTS USED IN THE IN
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE,
THEY SAY THE SAME THING. YOU
CAN'T TREAT THEM ALL THE SAME.
YOU HAVE TO REALLY LOOK AT THE
EFFECTS OF THE DIFFERENT TYPES
AND YOU CAN'T JUST PUT THEM ALL
IN ONE BASKET AND SAY THEY'RE
ALL BAD AND THEY ALL SHOULDN'T
BE USED AND I THINK THAT'S THE
POINT. WE WANT TO MAKE TO THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, MR CHAIR, SO I AM
OBVIOUSLY NOT GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. I'M
FRUSTRATED AT THE FACT THAT, UM
WE AREN'T HAVING A HEARING WHERE
WE COULD HAVE ALL THESE WITH
SOME SCIENTISTS AND SOME PEOPLE,
EXPERTS WEIGH IN ON WHAT
ESSENTIAL THINGS WE REALLY NEED
TO KEEP OUR SOCIETY GOING, UH,
FOR HEALTH DEVICES FOR WIND
GENERATION FOR SOLAR FOR YOU.
NAME IT. UM AND WE'RE DOING A
BILL. THAT IS A HUGE BILL, WHICH
I BELIEVE, UM YOU KNOW, MAY IT
PASS? MAY NOT, I DON'T KNOW, BUT
I ASSUME HE'S GONNA GET OUT OF
HERE. NÓ PROBLEM TODAY, BUT I
THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
REALLY NEED TO DO THIS RIGHT?
AND I AND I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
SOME HEALTH. UH AND IT'S IN OUR
WATER AND IT'S OUR SANITATION
DISTRICTS AND I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE SOME PROBLEMS. I AGREE WITH
THAT. BUT I THINK HOW WE DO IT
IS CRITICAL. AND I THINK THIS IS
THE WRONG APPROACH. THE RIGHT
APPROACH TO ME IS GET EVERYBODY
AT THE TABLE. TALK ABOUT WHERE
WHERE THOSE SET SOME OF THE
STUFF IN THE PARKING LOT THAT WE
KNOW WE HAVE TO HAVE. AND THEN
THIS FOCUS ON THE THINGS THAT
ARE NUMBER ONE, CAUSING THE
BIGGEST HEALTH ISSUES AND LET'S
FOCUS ON THOSE AND THEN
SECONDLY, YOU GET GREEN
CHEMISTRY OR FIGURE OUT HOW
WE'RE GONNA DO. WE'RE GONNA FUND
UP Dð Tð S¼ E TO DO THE WORK
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU TALKING
ABOUT 14,000 TO 38,000. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE REAL NUMBER IS,
BUT I LOOKED THERE. IT'S FROM
14,000 TO 38,000 SOMEWHERE IN
BETWEEN THERE A PRODUCTS THAT
HAVE THAT NEED THESE NEED THIS
STUFF TO OPERATE, SO I THINK
WE'RE CHATTING ON SOME ROUGH
GROUND HERE. SO FOR TODAY, I
WON'T BE SUPPORTING THE
LEGISLATION. CINNA SENATOR, I
JUST FINAL THOUGHTS HERE. YOU
KNOW, I JUST PRESENTED SENATOR
LIMON'S BILL, AND IT TALKED
ABOUT HOW, UH, BP A WAS, UM,
BANNED OUT OF PRODUCTS. BUT THEN
SOME OF THOSE PRODUCTS STARTED
USING MORE HARMFUL, HURTFUL
PRODUCTS FOR JUST BEING MINDFUL
AS WE'RE BANNING SOMETHING THAT
MANUFACTURERS ARE NOT GOING TO
GET PUT EVEN MORE HURTFUL
PRODUCTS IN HERE. UM, I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT, BUT
I JUST WANNA KNOW THAT. UM I AM
RESERVING MY RIGHT. I WILL BE
VOTING ON THIS BILL, BUT WE'RE
RESERVING MY RIGHT. UM, ONCE IT
GETS, UH FURTHER DOWN POLICY. UM
FS. THANK YOU, RIGHT. AND YOU'VE
GOT REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTIONS,
LANGUAGE. IN THE BILL, RIGHT?
YEAH OK. DID YOU WANNA RESPOND
TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE JUST MADE? SURE UM, UH, IN
TERMS OF PF BEING U, UNIQUE AND
NOT BEING A CLASS TOGETHER IN
TERMS OF HOW WE MANAGE PF, UM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
SPENT YEARS DEVELOPING THE
SCIENTIFIC FRAMEWORK FOR WHY WE
SHOULD BE MANAGING PFAS AS A
CLASS G Tð S¼ èC HAS PAPERS
PUBLISHED ON IT AND EXTENSIVE
TECHNICAL DOCUMENTS SUPPORTING
WHY PF NEEDS TO BE REGULATED AS
A CLASS. UM ALL ALL CHEMICALS.
WITHIN THE PF S¼ CLASS ARE
HIGHLY PERSISTENT OR BREAK DOWN
INTO HIGHLY PERSISTENT CHEMICALS
. THAT MEANS THAT THE MORE WE
PRODUCE THEM, THE MORE THEY WILL
BUILD UP AND THEN THE MORE
LIKELY THEY WILL INCREASE THE
RISK OF HARM. UM ALL PF S¼ THAT
HAVE BEEN STUDIED WELL HAVE
HEALTH HARMS ASSOCIATED WITH
THEM, INCLUDING ONES THAT WE
STARTED OFF WITH AND WHICH ARE
THE MOST. UM YOU KNOW, THE MOST
TRADITIONALLY USED THAT ALL OF
THE REPLACEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PUT FORWARD THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO STUDY AS SCIENTISTS HAVE
THE SIMILAR HEALTH EFFECTS AS
ORIGINAL ONES THAT WERE REPLACED
. THAT IS WHY WE ARE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTIONS BY
TREATING P VÆ AS A CLASS IN
TERMS OF FLORAL POLYMERS. UM
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT FLORA
POLYMERS, THE ARGUMENT IS THAT
THEY ARE NOT ACCESSIBLE TO OUR
BODIES BECAUSE THEY ARE, UM
THERE'S A LOT OF THEM PUT
TOGETHER AND IT'S A BIG MOLECULE
AND THEY THEY CAN'T GET INTO OUR
BODIES. THE PROBLEM WITH THAT IS
THAT WE'RE NOT THINKING ABOUT
THE ENTIRE LIFE CYCLE OF FLORA,
POLYMERS 80% OF PEOPLE, UH,
CONTAMINATION IN WEST VIRGINIA.
UM AND IN OTHER PLACES THAT HAVE
REALLY BAD PFAS CONTAMINATION
CAME FROM THE PRODUCTION OF
FLORAL POLYMERS. YOU NEED PF S¼
TO MAKE FOR POLYMERS. AND SO YOU
HAVE THAT REALLY LARGE. SOURCE
OF PFAS WASTE. AND THEN ALSO,
YOU HAVE P A BREAKDOWN, UM, INTO
SMALLER PIECES FROM THE FLOOR
POLYMERS AT END OF LIFE BECAUSE
WE CAN'T CONTROL WHAT HAPPENS TO
PRODUCTS WHEN THEY HAVE PF AT
END OF LIFE. THEY END UP IN OUR
OUR LANDFILLS. THEY END UP BEING
INCINERATED. AND WHAT WE SEE IS
THAT P FS BECOME ACCESSIBLE
PIECES OF PS, BREAK OFF AND
BECOME ACCESSIBLE AND END UP
CONTAMINATING OUR ENVIRONMENT,
MUCH LIKE PLASTICS AND
MICROPLASTICS, RIGHT, SO THE
PLASTICS ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO, UM
NOT SUPPOSED TO FALL APART. YOU
DON'T HAVE A PLASTIC BOTTLE FALL
APART IN FRONT OF US, BUT
EVENTUALLY IN THE LANDFILL. THEY
DO BREAK APART AND BECOME SMALL
LITTLE PIECES THAT DO, UH, CAUSE
HARM TO OUR ENVIRONMENT. AND TO
OUR TO OUR HEALTH. LET ME ASK
THE CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR THAT
ANSWER. UM OUR OUR FRIEND FROM
THE CHAMBER WAS BRINGING UP THE
IMPLICATIONS THIS MIGHT HAVE FOR
OUR OTHER CLIMATE GOALS. CLEAN
ENERGY PROJECTS, ETCETERA. DO
YOU HAVE KIND OF THOUGHTS ON IT,
AND WITH RESPECT. IT IF I WERE
TO BE PRESENTING THE ALTER THE
OPPOSITION ARGUMENT, I WOULD
ALWAYS USE THOSE THINGS THAT WE
ARE VERY INVESTED IN THAT WE
KNOW, FOR EXAMPLE, WE ARE
RELYING ON TO ADDRESS OUR
CLIMATE CRISIS. NOW IT IS NOT
CLEAR TO ME THAT IN IN EVERY
SINGLE PRODUCT THAT WHEN
STEPPING BACK THE NUMBER OF
PRODUCTS THAT WERE REFERENCED,
THAT'S THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PRODUCTS THAT USE THIS TODAY USE
DIFFERENT FORMS OF TODAY. IT IS
NOT CLEAR THAT EVERY ONE OF
THOSE IT IS EITHER AN ESSENTIAL
USE OR FOR WHICH THERE IS NÓ
ALTERNATIVE. SO WHAT WE DON'T
KNOW IS WHAT OF THE ONES THAT
WERE MENTIONED ARE ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL WITH NÓ ALTERNATIVE
RIGHT. SO TO JUST CATEGORICALLY
SAY THAT THIS WOULD STOP ALL
WINDMILLS. WIND TURBINES ALL S¼.
ALL I THINK IS A RATHER LARGE
OVERSTATEMENT. OK, UM. YEAH, BY
THE WAY, I YOU KNOW, I'M TALKING
TO MY STAFF HERE. I DON'T WE
DON'T CALL A REQUEST FOR A
HEARING. BUT BUT HAPPY TO HAVE
ONE, OK? I'D LOVE YOU TO FIND
THE VIDEO, MY FRIEND. UM WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE ONE. I MEAN,
HONESTLY, I, I MAYBE IT WAS A
IA. I ASKED FOR IT. OK II I
SKINNER AND I TALKED ABOUT IF
THAT'S THE CASE. I APOLOGIZE IF
THAT WAS SOMETHING BALL DROP ON
MY SIDE, BUT BUT CERTAINLY HAPPY
TO HAVE ONE IN THE PRO, QUITE
FRANKLY, PROBABLY MOST LIKELY IN
THE INTERIM, OR OR AT LEAST WHEN
WE'RE DURING A RECESS BECAUSE
THINGS ARE SO CRAZY, BUT, UM
HAPPY TO DO IT HAPPY TO DO IT,
BUT BUT DON'T SEEM TO RECALL IT.
THE REQUEST. UM ANYHOW, I THIS
IS A MASSIVE BILL AND YOU HAVE A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS, OBVIOUSLY,
UM, AND THERE'S A LOT OF KIND OF
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS AND
CHALLENGES THAT YOU I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE, AND YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO. ON THIS. I'M THINKING OF IT
LIKE, UH, I DON'T REMEMBER THE,
UM BILL NUMBER NOW, BUT THE
NUMBER WHERE I WAS CO-AUTHOR
WITH YOU, SENATOR ALLEN ON OUR
PLASTICS SPILL. YES, THE LEVEL
OF COMPLEXITY AND THE AMOUNT
STAKEHOLDERS OF PRODUCTS AND YES
, EXACTLY. YES YEAH, OK, ALL
RIGHT, UM MOVED BY SENATOR
MENJIVAR GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE UM I
APPRECIATE THAT. THIS, UM. THE
OPPOSITION'S POINTS ABOUT THE
CURRENT CONSTRUCTION OF A DATE
AND THE CONSTRUCT RIGHT NOW OF
THE WAY THE LEGISLATION IS
WRITTEN THAT YOU WOULDN'T EVEN
BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR THE
EXEMPTION UNTIL AFTER AND WE
WILL FIX THOSE, BUT THERE IS
ANOTHER ASPECT TO THAT OF WHEN
IT GOES INTO EFFECT. THOSE
ENTITIES FOR WHICH THERE IS AN
ALTERNATIVE, USE AN ALTERNATIVE
SUBSTANCE TO USE. INSTEAD THEY
CAN COMPLY WITHOUT HAVING TO GO
BEFORE, SO I JUST WANT TO PUT
THAT ON THE RECORD. THE OTHER
ISSUE IS THAT YOU KNOW IT. WE AS
LEGISLATORS DON'T ALWAYS LIKE TO
TAKE ON THESE. THESE VERY
COMPLEX AND BIG CHALLENGES,
HOWEVER. WE ALL EVERY ONE OF US,
MEANING EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN
THE ON THE PLANET NOW IN THE U
S¼, BUT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, WE ARE BEING
BOMBARDED WITH THESE CHEMICALS.
AND AT A CERTAIN POINT WE'VE GOT
TO GET CONTROL OF IT. AND WHAT
WE WHY YOU HAD ALL OF OUR WATER
AGENCIES COMING FORWARD IS IT IS
IN ALL OF OUR WATERWAYS. THEY
CAN'T GET IT OUT. THERE'S NOT
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO. THAT
DOESN'T MATTER HOW MUCH MONEY
THEY SPEND. SO TO EXPECT TO PUT
ON OUR PUBLIC AGENCIES THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT US
AGAINST THIS CONTAMINANT. WHEN
IT IS SO UTILIZED. IT IS IN SO
MANY PRODUCTS, AND IT'S NOT
CLEAR THAT IT IS NECESSARY IN
ALL THOSE PRODUCTS THAT THAT'S
WHEN WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
STEP IN AND TRY TO DO OUR BEST
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT. SO YOU
HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
WORK ON THIS BILL. I REALIZE IT
IS DEFINITELY A WORK IN PROGRESS
. IT DOES NEED SOME SOME
REFINEMENTS AND I WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO DO
THAT. SO YOU DO HAVE MY
COMMITMENT. BUT YOU ALSO HAVE MY
COMMITMENT, TOO, WHILE I'M STILL
IN THIS LEGISLATURE TO TAKE ON
THIS ISSUE OF PFAS IN A
COMPREHENSIVE WAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, UM,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL ALL S¼ B
903. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND
REREFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. SENATORS ALLEN ALLEN,
I DALLY DOLLY NÓ GONZALEZ.
HURTADO MENJIVAR MENJIVAR. I
WIN. SKINNER SKINNER EYE OK,
WE'LL HOLD THAT ROW OPEN FOR
SENATOR GONZALEZ, WHO I HOPE WAS
ON HER WAY. OK LET'S UM AND
SENATOR NGUYEN TOO, I. I GUESS
AS A BANKING I WE GOT THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE IS WAITING. WE GOT TO
LIFT CALLS. UM SO PLEASE,
SENATOR NGUYEN, AND, UH GONZALEZ
, IF YOU IF YOU CAN HEAR US,
COME, COME, COME. ALL RIGHT. UM,
THE ROLE IS ALREADY CLOSED ON
ITEM ONE. SO LET'S GO TO ITEM
TWO. BLAKE SPIRIT S¼ B 1066.
FILE ITEM. TWO SB 1066. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND REREFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
AND CHAIR VOTING. I SHARE VOTING
. GONZALEZ HURTADO HURTADO, I
WIN. SKINNER. HØI IN HER EYE. OK
UM, WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN FOR
LENA AND JANET. ITEM THREE S¼ B
1361. FILE ITEM THREE. S¼ B 1000
THREE 161. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING CHAIR.
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I.
GONZALEZ HURTADO HURTADO. I WIN.
SKINNER SKINNER. I OK. HOLD THAT
OPEN ITEM FOUR S¼ P 159. OK THAT
IS MOTIONS. A MOTION. YEAH, THAT
DOES NEED A MOTION. THIS WAS THE
FIRST IT'D IT WAS A SUBCOMITTEE.
THIS WAS DODD'S BILL. OK MOVED
BY SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. COLOR OK? FILE ITEM
FOUR S¼ B 1059 MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
AND WATER. SENATORS ALLEN ALLEN,
I DOY DOY I GONZALEZ HURTADO.
HER TAO I MENJIVAR MENJIVAR. I
WIN. SKINNER SKINNER. I OK, OCHO
BOG. THIS IS, UH S¼ B 1175. FIVE
ITEM FIVE. S¼ B 175 MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED AND REREFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR. VOTING I
VICE CHAIR VOTING I GONZALEZ.
POTATO HURTADO. I OK, WE WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN ITEM SIX. THAT'S
OH, NÓ SORRY, I'M SEVEN MILO'S
S¼ P 1259 OK, FILE ITEM SEVEN S¼
VÆ 1259. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY ALLEN. UM DALLY IS
VOTING VICE CHAIR IS VOTING I
GONZALEZ HURTADO. MENJIVAR. WHEN
I WHEN I SKINNER OK, SO THAT
FAILS, UH, 2 TO 0. OK UM WE'LL
CALL HER ONE MORE TIME ON ITEM
EIGHT. THIS IS S¼ P 13,000 THREE
193 MILO FILE ITEM EIGHT. HE DID
ON THIS ONE. S¼ VÆ 1393 DO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION ALLEN. VICE
CHAIRS VOTING I GONZALEZ. OH,
I'M SORRY. GONZALES. SORRY.
VOTED SKINNER. OK THAT ONE FAILS
. LET'S GO TO ITEM NINE S¼ B
1266. S¼ U  N MR. CHAIR POINT OF
CLARIFICATION. I KNOW THAT THE
CHAIR THE AUTHOR ASKED FOR
RECONSIDERATION, SO WE DID ONE
MORE ROUND OF VOTE. BUT IF WOULD
YOU WANT TO? NÓ I'M JUST
CONFUSED BECAUSE, I KNOW HE HAS
TWO GIRLS AND I TELL WHICH ONE
IS THE BICYCLES AND SAY, GIRL
THAT WAS RED WEISER. SO WE DID.
WE DID VOTES FOR BOTH OF HIS
BILLS. JUST NOW. 459 IS THERE.
ARE YOU INTERESTED IN CHANGING
YOUR VOTE? RIGHT NOW? WE HAVE
YOU AS A NÓ VOTE RECORDED FOR
BOTH FOR 1059 AND 1000. THREE,
190 THREE. IS THAT ACCURATE FOR
EVERYBODY? YEAH MR. MR CHAIR. UM
I WOULD LIKE TO CHANGE MY VOTE
ON 1393. I HAD ON THE FIRST.
VOTE COUNT VOTED I AND I'D LIKE
TO KEEP MY VOTE THE SAME. YOU
WANT TO KEEP IT THE SAME. YEAH
YES. SO WE HAVE YOU AS A NÓ VOTE
RECORDER ON 1259 AND I ON 1390
THREE 59. I WAS ABSTAINED AND 90
THREE. I VOTED I THAT'S WHAT I
HATS ON THERE. WE'VE GOT THAT,
OK? ALL RIGHT, OK. YEAH EXACTLY.
THAT WAS THREE TO ONE. YES 3 TO
1. BUT YOU YEAH, OK. FILE ITEM.
NINE S¼ B 1266. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED AND REREFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH CHAIR
. VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I,
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. I HURTADO
HURTADO. I WIN WHEN I SKINNER
OK, THE NUMBER ONE THING. YES I
GET 700 CLOSER. ALL IN THAT.
LAYERED SB 1280 NEEDS A MOTION
IF ANYONE'S SO INCLINED SO MOVED
BY HURTADO. SECRETARY OF PEACE
COLOR MOVE BY HER, TOO. FILE
ITEM. 10 S¼ B 1280. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASS AND REREFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY SENATORS
ALLEN ALLEN, I DALLY DOLLY NÓ
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. I HURTADO.
HER. TATO I MENJIVAR. WHEN THE
WHEN NÓ. SKINNER SKINNER, I DID
YOU WANNA RECONSIDER YOUR OH,
SORRY. OF COURSE, OK, THAT'S
FOUR SNEAK SNEAKS BY ALL RIGHT,
42. LET'S GO TO, UM 11, MRS
CABALLERO. FILE ITEM 11 S¼ B 4
1420. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED AND REREFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY, UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS CHAIR. VOTING
I VICE CHAIR VOTING I GONZALEZ.
HURTADO. HURTADO. I MENJIVAR.
WHEN I WHEN I OK, WE'LL CLOSE IT
ALL. THAT'S FIVE VOTES NEXT, UH,
SKINNER SPILL JUST FILE ITEM. 12
S¼ B 900 THREE. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING NÓ
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. I HURTADO.
WHEN NÓ WHEN NOW THAT'S FOUR
VOTES. WE'LL CLOSE IT ALL ON
THAT 4242 NEXT WE'LL GO TO THE
GONZALEZ BILL S¼ P 1308 FILE
ITEM. 13 SB 1308. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AND REREFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR. VOTING. I DALLY. GONZALEZ
IS A I HURTADO. HURTADO I THAT'S
IT. OK THAT'S SIX VOTES. WE'LL
CLOSE THE ROLL ON THAT. LET US
NOW. ALLENS BILL S¼ B 1140
THREE. FILE ITEM. 14 S¼ B 143.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND WE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING NÓ GONZALEZ.
GONZALES. I HURTADO. HURTADO. I
FIVE. OK, IT'S 5 TO 2. WE'LL
CLOSE A ROLL ON THAT. OK, LET US
GO BACK TO THE ROLE. UM, ITEM
TWO BLAKESPEAR. 1066 FILE ITEM.
TWO SB 1066. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AND REREFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY CHAIR.
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. I WIN. WIN
70. WE'LL CLOSE A RULE ON THAT.
UH, BLAKESPEAR 1361 FILE ITEM.
THREE SB 1361 MOTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED AND REREFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING CHAIR.
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I,
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. I WIN. I WIN.
I ZERO. 70.11 59. FILE ITEM FOUR
S¼ B 159. THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
AND REREFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR. VOTING I,
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. I WIN. I WIN.
I 7070 ONE MORE BOGUE. FIVE ITEM
. FIVE SB 1175 MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED AND REREFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING. I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. I 7070 ALL
RIGHT. I THINK THAT'S IT. YOU'RE
SURE HE ASKED FOR RECONSTRUCTION
? YES ON ON 1390 THREE ASKED FOR
A RECON ON 1390 THREE. OK THANK
YOU, UH, MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
STAFF FOR YOUR HARD WORK A TOUGH
AND, UM ME MEETING AND ALSO MY
APOLOGIES TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. YEAH AND IRWIN NÓ AS
WELL. IS HERE. GOOD TO SEE YOU,
UH, THIS WAS A LONG MEETING. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR FORBEARANCE AND
SENATOR NEWMAN. IT'S ALWAYS GOOD
TO SEE YOU. YOU ADDED TO THE
PROBLEM. ALL RIGHT. THIS IS
ADJOURNED.